A GOOD START. THANK YOU ALL FOR
TAKING THE TIME TO BE WITH US
TODAY THIS IS AN INFORMATIONAL
HEARING. OF FOUR DIFFERENT
COMMITTEES AND WE WANT TO TAKE
A MOMENT TO SAY THANK YOU ON
BEHALF OF THE PARTNERSHIP OF
THE SENATE GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE THE SENATE
HOUSING COMMITTEE SIMPLY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTING OF COURSE
THE ASSEMBLY HOUSING CAN BE AS
WELL- AT WORK WELL THAT ALL OF
YOU HAVE. AND CAN ALL AGREE
THAT CAP HAS A HOUSING CRISIS
CITIES AND SMALL IN AS A RESULT.
POLICY BEING SCRUTINIZED IN THE
SAGE YOUR MAXIMUM BILL. IT'S IN
THE MOST EFFICIENT PERIOD OF
TIME. THE ISSUE OF BUILDING
FEES WHICH WERE THE FOCUS ON
TODAY IN HOUSING AFFORDABILITY
IS A CRITICAL SUBJECT THAT IS
ME ONE. OF THE CENTRAL POINTS
OF DISCUSSION AROUND HOUSING
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS. IN
AS YOU CAN. THE NUMBER OF CARE
SAID HAVE COME TOGETHER TODAY
ONE THAT THE LEGISLATURE TAKES
SERIOUSLY. WE WANT TO SAY HOW
GRATEFUL WE PARTNER AN IN HOUSE
COMMITTEE THE ASSEMBLY HOUSE
NEED DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE AND
ESPECIALLY THE- ASSEMBLY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE CHAIRED
BY. ASSEMBLY WOMAN AND WE ARE
CURRY. THE WOMAN NINE. TO SAY
THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR WOMAN
FOR HER WORK AND I WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU. TO BOTH THE CHAIRMAN
OF HOW- A CHAIRMAN OF. THE
SENATE AS WELL AS THE ASSEMBLY
FOR THEIR PARTNER. HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY IS A SUBJECT ON
IT CALIFORNIANS MIND. THERE ARE
MANY REASONS THAT HOUSING COSTS
WHAT IT DOES IN THE GOLDEN
STATE TODAY. WERE GATHERED
UNDERSTAND ONE CONTRIBUTOR OF
THE COST OF HOMEBUILDING THAT'S
THE FEES IT DEVELOPERS PAY TO
OFFSET THE IMPACT OF NEW
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT. THERE ARE
SOME SIMPLE NARRATIVES OUT
THERE ON THE EFFECTIVE IMPACT
FEES YET WE BELIEVED EIGHT THIS
DESERVES A- DIVE DEEPER DIVE
INTO HE'S IN HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY. THROUGH THIS
HEARING IS COMMITTEES DIG DEEP
CLEANED IMPACT FEES A ROLE IN
LOCAL. FINING WHAT TRIP. COME
ALONG WITH. THE COMMITTEES WILL
RECEIVE AN OVERVIEW OF LOW
FISCAL CONSTRAINTS. BRIBING
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS POSED IMPACT
IT. IS WELL AS A DESCRIPTION OF
LEGAL REQUIREMENTS THAT IMPACT.
MIGHT IN THE- SECOND IS WE FROM
LOCAL GUY. TO PROVIDE OUR USE
IN THE BACK FEES. THE IMPORTANT
OF THESE FEES TO THEIR ABILITY.
TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE. IS TO
RESIT. THE PAN CAN A HIGH.
INSTANCES WITHIN THEIR
JURISDICTIONS IN FINELY GROUND
IN THIS OFF THE COMMITTEES ARE
GONNA HEAR FROM DEVELOPERS BOTH
FOR PROFIT AND NONPROFIT- AS
WELL AS THE TURNERS HERE FOR
HOUSING INVASION. ON THE
EFFECTIVE IMPACT FEES AND
SUPPLY IN ALTERNATELY HOUSING
PRICES. IF STRUCTURE
APPROPRIATELY IMPACT FEES CAN
CONTINUE TO SERVE AS A KEY
RESOURCE FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO BUILD INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
RESIDENTS WHILE V<c.cyan>. MAJOR</c>
IMPACTS IN SUPPLY. THEN IF
EITHER REALLY IMPACT FEES CAN
ENCOURAGE IF YOU STRUCTURE THEY
CAN HELP USERS IN- IN
INDIVIDUALS BUILDING HOUSING IN
THIS STATE TO BE ABLE TO DIG
OUT OF THIS. IS THAT WE'RE IN-
AND TO BE ABLE TO GET MORE
UNITS BUILT IN MORE FAMILY'S
HOUSE. AGAIN THANK YOU ALL FOR
TAKING THE IME TO BE A TO JOIN
US JUST TO OUR PANELISTS WILL
BE COMING UP IN JUST A MOMENT
WE'RE GONNA ASK YOU DEBATE KEEP
ON TIME. AS WE HAVE- SEVERAL
INDIVIDUALS WILL BE SPEAKING TO
FROM ACROSS THE STATE WE'RE
TRULY GRATEFUL WITHOUT FURTHER
ADO AND TURN OVER THE CHAIR
WOMAN. LOCAL WOMEN IN THE
ASSEMBLY. I'M YOU WILL GO TO
ASSIST SENATOR FROM THE SENATE
HOUSING COMMITTEE AT. MISTER
WEINER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
THE CENTER MCGUIRE AND I'M
REALLY THRILLED THAT WORK IS
WORKING ON THE OTHER HAVING
THIS HEARING TODAY- AND I WANT
TO PARTICULARLY- THANK AYE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON WHO'S
BEEN A REAL LEADER ON SORT OF
ELEVATING AND FLAGGING THIS
ISSUE FOR THREE FOUR YEARS NOW-
AND- I KNOW IT'S A IT'S A THANK.
ASKED BY ONE OF TO SEE
PERSONALLY YOU FOR. OUR
LEADERSHIP- WE DO HAVE A
HOUSING CRISIS IN CALIFORNIA
BUT- BUT TO BE CLEAR
FUNDAMENTALLY WE HAVE A HOUSING
SHORTAGE- IN CALIFORNIA- OF
EVERY CONCEIVABLE TYPE OF
HOUSING RANGING FROM SUPPORT.
HOUSING FOR FROM ALMOST PEOPLE
TO- MODERATE INCOME HOUSING TO
MARKET RATE HOUSING SHORTAGE OF
AT EVERY SINGLE. LEVEL ON THE
TOTALS IN THE MILLIONS IN TERMS
OF HOW MANY HOMES WERE SHORT-
AND CALIFORNIA RANKS THE NINE
OUT OF FIFTY STATES IN HOMES
PER CAPITA. IN THE LAST SIXTY
YEARS WALKER BEFORE HIS
POPULATION HAS ALMOST TRIPLED
OUR HOUSING PRODUCTION HAS
KALAU BY SOMEWHERE BETWEEN TWO
THIRDS THREE QUARTERS SO ANYWAY
YOU LOOK AT IT. WE WERE
DRAMATIC- HOUSING SHORTAGE.
KIND OF HOUSING. AT AND- TAXIS
PART OF THAT OTHER ISSUES OF
COURSE RESTRICTIVE TING. THE
SLOW PACE OF APPROVING HOUSING
IN THE NEED NEED FOR
STREAMLINING THE NEED FOR MORE
FUNDING THE NEED TO KEEP OUR
RENTER'S STABLE IN THEIR
HOUSING AND SO FORTH. IMPACT
FEES IS DOUBLY PART OF THAT BUT
AS WE DISCUSSES ISSUE ONE THING
THAT I WANT TO MAKE CLEAR AND I
KNOW THAT OTHERS- I THINK OR
I'M SURE IN AGREEMENT.
SOMETIMES THIS ISSUE GETS
PICKED SAYS- DEMONIZING CITIES%
AND LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIALS BUT
YOU DID AXE- YOU MADE IT HARDER
APPROVED. BUT THE RESTRICT
DONATE. YOUR I IMPACT FEES. AND
I THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO-
FOR I LIKE TO FRAME THIS AS-
YOU KNOW THE OLD SAYING IS
DON'T DON'T HATE THE PLAYERS
HIT THE GAME- WE HAVE DESIGNED
A SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA. AROUND
HOUSING THAT IS THE WE CREATED
A SYSTEM AROUND HOUSING
CALIFORNIA. THAT IS DESIGNED TO
FAIL- WE EXPECT I CITIES ODD
TO- ROOF AND BUILD A HOUSING-
BUT WE MAKE IT EXCEPTIONALLY
HARD- TO DO SO WE CREATE A
SYSTEM WHERE- CITY COUNCIL
MEMBERS ARE EXPECTED TO WALK
THE PLANK EVERY WEEK A- GROUP
HOUSING- AND WE DON'T HAVE
THEIR BOXES AS- A LOT OF. A LOT
OF THE ROOF WORK WE'RE DOING AT
THE STATE. ST FIGHTING. WARM OR
IMPACT THE FRANKLY NEEDS TO BE
ABOUT CREATING A STRUCTURE WERE
LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIALS HAVE A
BETTER CHANCE OF ACTUALLY-
SUCCEEDING WHEN IT COMES TO
IMPACT FEES WHILE THERE ARE
SOME CITIES THAT ENGAGE IN
ABUSIVE BEHAVIOR AND JOCK UP
AND FEES IN ORDER TO TANK-
DEVELOPMENT BY FINANCIALLY AND
FEASIBLE THOSE CITIES DO EXIST
THEY ARE A MINORITY- MOST
CITIES ARE SIMPLY TRYING TO-
FIND BASIC INFRASTRUCTURE AND
SERVICE NEEDS BECAUSE IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE MADE IT SO
HARD FOR CITIES TO FIND THESE
BASIC SERVICES AND
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS. WHETHER
IT'S THROUGH- ARE RATHER TO
PROP THIRTEEN OR THE
REQUIREMENT THAT YOU NEED TWO
THIRDS OF YOU'RE GOING TO GET
ANY KIND OF FUN THAT MEASURE
THROUGHOUT THE BUT IT HARD AND
HARDER AD HARDER TO THESE TO
BASIC NEEDS I AM SO. IS OUR
PORCH OUR- WHERE TO GENERATE
THAT REVENUE AND SO I DON'T
BEGRUDGE CITIES YOU KNOW
WANTING TO GENERATE THAT
REVENUE THE PROBLEM IS THAT
BECOMES THE EASIEST PATH TO DO
IT AND SO WE SEE AN INCREASE
INCREASE INCREASE AND IMPACT
FEES AND THAT ENDS UP HARMING
OUR ABILITY TO BUILD MORE
HOUSINGBECAUSE IT MAKES
HOUSING MORE EXPENSIVE TO BUILD
NOT BLAME CRITICIZING CITIES
IT'S ABOUT SAYING HOW CAN WE
ENSURE THAT THESE COMBINED. ALL
THE THINGS THAT THEY NEED TO
FIND AROUND HEALTH AND PUBLIC
SAFETY AND PARKS AND SO FORTH
IN A WAY THAT DOES NOT CONTINUE
TO EXACERBATE HOMELESSNESS
CONTINUE TO RESTRICT THE SUPPLY
OF HOUSING SO THAT TO ME IS
WHAT THIS IS ABOUT I'M VERY
GRATEFUL THAT WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TODAY TO HAVE THIS
DISCUSSION. THE TOO MUCH TO
CHAIR I WOULD LIKE TO BE TURNED
OVER TO THE CHAIR WILL. LOCAL
GOVERNMENT SOME WOMAN
AGUIAR-CURRY GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE THANK YOU FOR TAKING
THE TIME OUT TO JOIN US TODAY
THIS IS AS WE ALL KNOW SUCH AN
IMPORTANT- ISSUE THAT WE- NEED
TO DEAL WITH. AS WE KNOW THE
LEGISLATURE'S TAKEN MANY STEPS.
ADDRESSING THE HOUSING CRISIS
IN RECENT YEARS. INCLUDING
REMOVING BARRIERS FOR ADA.
GIVING THEY DO USE HIS ME
CONSTRUCTION GIVING DIRECTION
TO CITIES AND COUNTIES TO MEET
HOUSING PLANNING GOALS IN
CREATING MORE CERTAINTY IN THE
LOCAL DEVELOPMENT AND LOCAL
DEVELOPMENT PROCESS. ONE ISSUE
WE KEEP HEARING ABOUT THOUGH IS
THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENT FEES FOR
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT ARE TOO
HIGH AND CAN BE A BARRIER TO
NEW DEVELOPMENT. ON THE FLIP
SIDE WE HEAR THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS RELY ON IMPACT FEES
TO FUND NEARBY PARKS
TRANSPORTATION AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND RAISING REVENUE IN
OTHER WAYS THE PROVES TO BE
VERY DIFFICULT. IMPACT FEES ARE
A MAJOR SOURCE FUNDING NEEDED
TO PAY FOR CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE RECALL TO KEEP
PACE WITH THE NEW HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION AND DEVELOPMENT.
THE COMING IN ON THIS ISSUE
MOVES FOR IT WILL BE IMPORTANT
TO BALANCE. LOW BUDGETING
REALITIES AND THE CONSTRAINTS
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FACE WHEN
RAISING REVENUE WITH CALIFORNIA
HOUSING GOALS THE PURPOSE OF
THIS HEARING IS TO EXPLORE AND
BOUNCE THIS. TO BALANCE AND TO
EDUCATE OURSELVES ON THE ISSUES
WHICH WILL INFORM OUR FUTURE
LEGISLATIVE CONVERSATION. I
WOULD LIKE TO ASK- I WOULD LIKE
TO ASK OUR SPEAKERS AND MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO REFRAIN FROM
TALKING ABOUT CURRENT OR
PENDING IMPACT FEES LEGISLATION
BY NAME. TODAY FOR A IS AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING WE WILL
HAVE MANY OPPORTUNITIES
REVIEWS. BILLS DURING OUR
UPCOMING POLICY HEARINGS LATER
THIS YEAR- LOOKING FOR TO THE
HEARING AND THE DISCUSSION AND
I WOULD REALLY LIKE WHAT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUE TO IF NOT
TODAY BUT- YOU TOO. THIS IS A
REALLY IMPORTANT- DISCUSSION
ITEM AND I THINK WE HAVE A LOT
OF WORK TO DO AS WE'VE BEEN
DIRECTED BY THE GOVERNOR AS
WELL SO I THANK YOU ALL FOR.
COMING TODAY. THANK SHARE. IF
IT TO THE CAN WE NOW LIKE TO
TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO THE
CHAIR. FOR ASSEMBLY HOUSING
COMMITTEE. SENATE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND- LET ME FIRST
START BY. THANKING THE FOR
COMMITTEES FOR COMING TOGETHER-
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT TOPIC BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY- WE SHOULD
PROBABLY DO THIS MORE OFTEN
BECAUSE THERE IS SO MUCH WORK
THAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN TO ADDRESS
THE MOST INTENSE CRISES OF THE
DAY. WHEN IT COMES TO HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS. LET ME ALSO
START BY SAYING THAT I HAVE
BEEN IN MOTION SUPPORT OF THE
IDEA OF A DRESS HOUSING CRISIS-
TACKLING TO CALL THREE PIECE-
PRODUCTION PROTECTION AND
SURVEY XIN AND LAST YEAR. I
WANT TO THANKS ANY OF YOU THAT
DID THE WORK AROUND CAPTION WE
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO DO SOME
SIGNIFICANT. AROUND AROUND. BUT
WE- WE'VE GOT TO DO. OF AND I
THINK THIS IS AN IN PART OF THE
PRODUCTION CONVERSATION I'M ONE
HISTORIC NOTE I THINK WE'RE
GONNA HEAR TODAY ABOUT HOW
IMPACT FEES HAVE BEEN
SUBSTANTIAL MANY INSTANCES AND
HOW THEY HAVE GROWN OVER TIME I
THINK IT'S NO IT'S NOT THE
HISTORICAL POINT AND THAT IN
THE WAKE OF PROPTHIRTEEN WITH
THE ELIMINATION OF
REDEVELOPMENT WITH FEDERAL
PROGRAM CUTS. CITIES HAVE HAD
TO RELY MORE AND MORE OFTEN ON
IMPACT FEES TO PAY FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE BUT WHILE IN THE
PAST THE COST OF THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE WAS SPREAD
THROUGHOUT A COMMUNITY TODAY
DEVELOPERS FORMS OF HOUSING
FROM PORTABLE MARKET RATE.
EVERYTHING THAT I MEAN.
EXPECTED TO PAY FOR PART IN
SPACE ROAD TRANSIT SEWERS AND
PIPES. AND CHOP AND MORE. AND
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE DURING THE
WORST HOUSING CRISIS IN OUR
STATE'S HISTORY WHEN YOU OF
HOUSING UNITS IN MY CITY
COSTING UPWARDS OF EIGHT TO
NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS A
DOOR. AND STUDIES THAT SHOW
THAT IMPACT FEES CAN ACCOUNT
FOR UP TO ONE SPEAKS TO THE
COST OF THAT UNIT. YOU HAVE TO
THINK DIFFERENT. I ALSO WANT TO
REITERATE APPOINT THE CENTER
WINNER MADE ABOUT HOW. MANY
CITIES ARE DOING MANY DIFFERENT
THINGS AND I THINK PART OF
TODAY'S HEARING. IS TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND THE SPECTRUM. OF
WHAT IS HAPPENING IN DIFFERENT
CITIES. IN SOME CITIES YOU HAVE
HUGE IMPACT FEES AND OTHERS
THEY'RE NOT- THEY'RE
TRANSPARENCY. AROUND FEES IN
MANY CITIES BUT IT'S NOT
TRANSPARENT THROUGHOUT THE
STATE- IN SOME CITIES FEES ARE
USED TO PRIORITIZE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND BUILDING A TRANSIT.
IN OTHERS THAT IS THE CASE AND
I AM LOOKING. NAY TO REALLY
GONNA DO YOU HAVE AN
UNDERSTANDING HOW THESE
DECISIONS ARE REACHED. HOUSE
AND THE- ON ADDRESS. THIS STATE
AND I'M NOT GONNA ABOUT ANY
BILLS BY. ALL THANK MR GRAYSON
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP. I THINK-
FOLKS KNOW THAT- THERE WAS
ANNOUNCEMENT THE OTHER DAY
ABOUT BILLS THAT WE WILL
DISCUSS IN THE FUTURE. BUT
TODAY- WE ARE HERE TO- TO GET A
BIG PICTURE OF WHERE WE ARE TO
LOOK FOR THAT CONVERSATION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH TO CHAIR IN
AGREED I THINK COMING TOGETHER-
BOTH. THE ASSEMBLY IN THE
SENATE- BOTH RELEVANT
COMMITTEES. IS CRITICAL IN THE
FOR THE WORKING WITH EACH OF
YOU HERE AS WE MOVE FORWARD IN
THE MONTHS TO COME AS THE
SALOON SAID BEFORE THE HEARING.
OPENING STATEMENT TO SOME.
GRAYSON I THINK ON BEHALF OF
EACH OF THE CHAIRS WE WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR- DOG AND
FOCUS ON THIS CRITICAL ISSUE
THE FORRESTER RESEARCH. THANK
YOU CHAIR OF AND ALSO I WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIRS OF THE
ASSEMBLY AND SENATE HOUSING.
LOCAL GOVERNMENT GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE COMMITTEES FOR ALLOWING
ME TO BE ABLE TO WE HAD THIS
MORNING PARTICIPATE. THE
CONNECTION BETWEEN DEVELOPMENT
FEES AND- AFFORDABILITY HAS
BEEN AN INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
ISSUE FOR ME AT MY DESK. EVER
SINCE I ARRIVED IN SACRAMENTO.
LAST NOVEMBER I EMBARKED ON A
STATEWIDE LISTENING TO OR ON
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY. BRINGING
TOGETHER CITY. DEVELOPS PLEASE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ADVOCATES
AND SPECIAL JUST X. TO SHARE
THE CHALLENGE IN OPPORTUNITIES
THE- TRYING. ACROSS THE STATE.
DURING FRESNO ROUND.
PARTICIPANTS SHARED THERE'S CAN.
THATA ONE SIZE FITS ALL POLICY
IT WILL NOT HELP US ACHIEVE OUR
HOUSING GOALS IN SAN DIEGO WE
HEARD THAT THERE IS AN
IMPORTANT ROLE THAT THIS CAN DO
IN HELPING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
PROVIDE CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE.
I READ THIS IN THE FINANCIAL
BURDEN NEW HOUSING IN ALL OF
THIS I HEARD BOTH AFFORDABLE
AND RATE BUILDUPS. THOUGH
IMPACT FEES AT CIGNA PASTA
HOUSING. COMING FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT MYSELF I UNDERSTAND
CHALLENGES THAT LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS SPACE TRYING TO
BALANCE THEIR FINANCES WHILE
WHILE PROGRAMMING OR PROMOTING
DEVELOPMENT. EVER RESIST THERE
IS EVIDENCE THESE ARE. AND
PROJECT INTENSE BY OUR CHRONIC
HOUSING SHORTAGE. FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PARTNERS
LIKE HABITAT FOR HUMANITY WHOSE
FINANCING IS ALREADY STRETCHED
TO THE LIMIT OUT OF CONTROL
FEES CAN PUSH OWNERSHIP OUT OF
REACH FOR A FAMILY THAT IS IN
ME. IT'S CLEAR THAT WE HAVE A
LONG WAY TO GO IN WRITING
HOUSING THAT IS AFFORDABLE AND
ATTAINABLE TO OUR CONSTITUENTS
AND WITH THAT I WOULD SAY THAT
I. AM AND LOW THE PANELIST ARE
HERE TO SPEAK TODAY AND I HOPE
THAT WE CAN COME TOGETHER TO
FIND REAL SOLUTIONS FOR THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA YOU AGAIN.
ALLOWING ME TO BE HERE IN SPACE
THANK YOU SOME ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AIMED TO EACH THE SIMILAR
MEMBERS IN THE SENATORS WERE ON
THE DICE WE GRATEFUL THAT
YOU'RE HERE TO GET A PART IN
THIS POURTANT CONVERSATION.
BEFORE WE GET INTO OUR FIRST
PANEL WE'RE GONNA ASK MISS
MORALIS MISTER DON IF YOU COULD
PLEASE COME FORWARD- IN YOUR
FOR YOUR PRISON TAKES. THE WAY
IT'S GOING TO. FOR EVERYONE
HERE I'LL BE IN NUMBER ONE WILL.
IT OVER FOR THE CHAIR. CHAIRMAN
AND WE ARE. TO BE ABLE TO
MODERATE PANEL TO. WELL THEN
TURN IT OVER TO SENATOR WINNER
FOR PANEL THREE IN THE CHAIR
TOUCH IT CHIU FOR PANEL FOR.
WITHOUT FURTHER WE'D LIKE TO BE
A KICK OFF OUR FIRST PANEL OF
THE DAY. WE HAVE LOWER.
SURROUND US FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
SHE'S GONNA BE FOCUSING ON
CONSTRICTS ON LEGAL. WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENT REP SHE'S A GOING TO
BE TALKING ABOUT THE RESORTS
EACH RESEARCH THAT THE LA- HAS
BEEN FOCUSING ON IN REGARDS TO
THE EFFECTS OF PROP THIRTEEN
AND HOW IT RELATES TO IMPACT
FEES. WITHIN CAN HEAR FROM RYAN.
I REPRESENTS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ON IMPACT FEES AND OTHER LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FINANCING HE'S GONNA
pGOVERN IMPACT FEES VIA- THE
STATE. STATUTE AND STATE AND
FEDERAL CONSTITUTION WITHOUT
FURTHER DO WE'RE GONNA TURN
OVER TO AND MISS MORALIS YOU
HAVE SEVEN MINUTES MA'AM MISTER
DONE YOU A FIVE AND WE'LL GIVE
YOU A THIRTY SECOND HEADS UP.
WE WELCOME YOU THANK YOU FOR
COMING TO COMMITTEE. GOOD
MORNING I'M WITH AS WELL AS
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE- AS A CHAIR MENTIONED
I'VE BEEN ASKED TO PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW OF SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES AND CONSTRAINTS
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE IN
RAISING REVENUES. I'LL BE
SPEAKING FROM. BEFORE JUMPING
INTO A DISCUSSION OF THE VOTER
APPROVAL REQUIREMENTS THAT
CONSTRAIN LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT JUST A FEW
BASICS OF THE FIRST TWO PAGES
OF THE HAND OUT- LAY OUT TO THE
ROLE OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WHICH- ARE TO PROVIDE.
MUNICIPAL SERVICES THESE ARE-
RESPONSIBILITIES OF CITIES
COUNTIES AND SPECIAL DISTRICTS
TEY SHARE THESE IN PROVIDING-
POLICE FIRE PUBLIC WORKS AND
OTHER SERVICES TO THE
CONSTITUENTS IN THEIR-
JURISDICTION. THEY PROVIDE THE
SERVICES THROUGH A COMBINATION
OF REVENUE SOURCES THE FIGURE
ON PAGE ONE OUTLINES HOW- THESE
FORM MAIN REVENUE SOURCES BEING
FEDERAL STATE GRANTS PROPERTY
TAXES. USER CHARGES AND FEES
AND THEN OTHER TAXES ARE TO
COME TOGETHER TO OF THE
AVAILABLE TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO PROVIDE THESE SERVICES THE
THIRTY TWO MAIN TAKEAWAYS HERE
THAT ARE OUTLINED ON THE SECOND
PAGE OF THE HANDOUT. ARE THAT
CITY SPECIAL DISTRICTS REALLY
RELY ON USER CHARGES AND FEES
BY SERVICES WELL COUNTIES RELY
ON FEDERAL AND STATE FUNDS IN
MANY CASES TO PROVIDE. THE KNOW.
ABILITY THANK HEALTH AND UP A
SOCIAL WELFARE. SO I'D LIKE TO
SPEND A MAJORITY OF MY TIME
BEFORE YOU THIS MORNING ON PAGE
THREE OF THE HAND OUT WALKING
YOU THROUGH HOW THE STATE'S
VOTER APPROVAL REQUIREMENTS
HAVE EVOLVED OVER A SERIES OF
DECADES. AND SO WE START HERE
BY NOTING THAT CITIES AND
COUNTIES HAVE TAXATION
AUTHORITY BUT THERE ARE LIMITS
THAT HAVE SOARED CUT- COME INTO
PLACE OVER. A LARGE. WINDOW OF
TIME SO WE KNOW THAT PRIOR TO
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT. LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS- YOU KNOW HAD GREAT
AUTHORITY TO RAISE OR LOWER
TAXES BUT IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT BECAUSE OF PROPOSITION
THIRTEEN NOT ONLY WAS THERE THE
1% CAP ON PROPERTY TAX. IS ALSO
CHANGES TO REQUIREMENTS
ESTABLISHING- ESTABLISHING A
TWO THIRDS VOTE A REQUIREMENT
FOR STATE TAXES. NOTABLY THOUGH
IN PROPOSITION THIRTEEN THERE
IS NO DEFINITION THAT WERE
PROVIDED TO SPECIAL TAXES
THERE'S A VARIATION
INTERPRETATION AMONG LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ON HOW TO IMPLEMENT
THAT- MOVING FORWARD. WE SEE
THAT IN NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO
THERE WAS THE FERAL DECISION
THAT BROUGHT SOME CLARITY TO
THE ISSUE. OF EACH CASE OTHER
SEPTEMBER DISK OF. THE US DEVON
FOR SPECIAL TAXES SPECIFICALLY
SPECIAL TAX BEING- TAXES THAT
WERE USED FORCE CIVIC. SAYS AND
TO THE. IN BY. WHAT IN ON. A
GROUP NEED WITH CISCO THE
ASPECT TAXES ARE FIRST PURPOSES
AND AS AN EXTENSION OF DISC
THERE'S NO VOTER ON TO AT THIS
TIME. OR AT THE TIME OF THE
FAILED THIS EXCUSE ME SO WE SEE
THAT BECAUSE THE PROPOSITION
THIRTEEN NEAR THE CITY THAT HAS
HISTORICALLY RELIED ON PROPERTY
TAXES HAD TO TURN TO SEEK OTHER
REVENUE SOURCES TO ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF THEIR JURISDICTIONS.
THE CD ARE A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT TYPES OF TAX MEASURES
COME FORWARD THESE BEING
CONSIDERED GENERAL TAXES AND
THEREFORE NOT HAVING. ALL OF
THE LOCAL VOTERS AND
IMPLEMENTING THOSE ARE
APPROVING AS EXCUSE ME. INTO
THIS CHANGED IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
SIX THE PROPOSITION SIXTY TWO.
WHICH REQUIRED GENERAL TAXES TO
BE APPROVED BY A SIMPLE
MAJORITY. AT NOTABLY HERE THIS
REQUIREMENT DID NOT APPLY TO
CHARTER CITIES AND IN
PROPOSITION SIXTY TWO KEPT IN
PLACE THE TWO THIRDS
REQUIREMENT FOR SPECIAL TAXES.
THEN IN NINETEEN NINETY TWO WE
HAVE THE KNOX DECISION- HERE
THE SUPREME COURT HELD THAT THE
PROPER PROP THIRTEEN
RESTRICTIONS PARTICULARLY THE
TWO THIRDS VOTER REQUIREMENTS
FOR SPECIAL TAXES DID NOT APPLY
FOR ASSESSMENT ON PROPERTY.
MOVING FORWARD WE HAVE
PROPOSITION TWO EIGHTEEN IN
NINETEEN NINETY SIX THIS
PROPOSITION- MOVED FORWARD A
COLLECTION OF REQUIREMENTS FOR
VOTER APPROVAL BUT NOTABLY HERE
IT'S WAS REALLY SORT OF A
ESTABLISHED THE CONSTITUTION OF
REQUIREMENTS THAT HAD BEEN
BROUGHT FORWARD EITHER THROUGH
CASE LAW OR THE STATUTE. OVER
THE PRECEDING PERIOD AND O WE
SEE THAT PROP TWO EIGHTEEN
REINFORCES PROP SIXTY TWOS
REQUIREMENT FOR A SIMPLE
MAJORITY VOTE FOR GENERAL TAXES
AND THEREFORE EXTEND THAT
REQUIREMENT AS WELL TO CHARTER
CITIES. WE ALSO SEE THAT PROP
TWO EIGHTEEN REAFFIRMED THE
FERAL DECISION REQUIRING THE A
TWO THIRDS VOTE FOR SPECIAL
TAXES AS WELL AS EXPANDED THE
DEFINITION OF A SPECIAL TAXES
TO INCLUDE THOSE LEVY BY
SPECIAL DISTRICTS AND AT SCHOOL
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE. COLLEGES
AS WELL. AND THEN WE ALSO SEE
THAT PROP TWO EIGHTEEN
ESTABLISHED REQUIREMENTS ABOUT
WHEN THESE- THESE INITIATIVES
NEED TO BE PRESENTED BEFORE
VOTERS IN TERMS OF THE TIMING
OF ELECTIONS. AND SO WE KNOW
THAT UP BECAUSE OF THESE
CHANGES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAD
AN EASIER TIME APPROVING YOU
FEES- WHICH COULD BE IMPOSED
THROUGH A MAJORITY VOTE OF
THEIR GOVERNMENT BODY RATHER
THAN VOTER APPROVAL COMPARED TO
TAXES. AND SO THEN WE THEN SEE
PROPOSITION TWENTY SIX- COME
FORWARD INTO IN TWO THOUSAND
TEN EXCUSE ME THAT. FURTHER
EXPANDED THE DEFINITION OF A
TAX SO THAT ADDITIONAL
ACTIVITIES THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE USING TO RAISE
REVENUES WITHIN CAPTURE THE
DEFINITION AND THEREFORE
REQUIRED VOTER APPROVAL AS WELL.
AND THEN MOST RECENTLY WE HAVE
THE UPLAND DECISION THAT CALLED
INT QUESTION WHETHER SPECIAL
TAXES BROUGHT FORWARD BY A
CITIZENS ALSO WERE REQUIRED TO
COMPLY WITH A TWO THIRDS VOTER
REQUIREMENTS. THE SUPREME COURT
DECISION AND UPLAND WAS
NARROWLY FOCUSED TO THE TIMING
OF ELECTIONS BUT BECAUSE THERE
IS A QUESTION ABOUT THE ROLE OF
VOTER INITIATED MEASURES
BECAUSE IT TO QUESTION THIS
BROADER IMPLICATION WE KNOW
THAT THERE'S BEEN A NUMBER OF
TESTS CLAIMS THAT HAVE FROM.
BEEN BROUGHT FORWARD RIGHT BY
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS AND SAN
FRANCISCO IN FRESNO- ARE JUST
OR TWO EXAMPLES WHERE THE
COURTS HAVE HAD TO INDIAN. WHAT
VOTER INISH IT MET THERE'S-
THAT GOT MORE THAN A MAJORITY
BUT LESS THAN TWO THIRDS. STAND
WE STOP NUMBER DISCO THE COURTS
RULED THAT IT DID BUT IN FRESNO
THAT THEY DIDN'T NEED THE TWO
THIRDS REQUIREMENT AND SO THAT
YOU IS STILL AND- FOR. THE
STATE FOR LOW. THAT WOULD BUT
THE IMPLICATIONS OF THIS
EVOLUTION AND VOTER
REQUIREMENTS SO FIRST WE KNOW
THAT THIS IS A IN CREDIBLY
COMPLEX SYSTEM. AND THAT IT
DOES RESTRICT LOCAL GOVERNMENT
ACTIONS- THERE'S THE
RESTRICTIONS OR PROP THIRTEEN
THE LIMIT PROPERTY TAXES BUT
THEN ALSO THIS REQUIREMENT FOR
VOTER APPROVAL FOR OTHER TYPE
OF REVENUE RAISING MEASURES
CREATES A LOT OF AND DO FOR
LOCAL GOV THE THIRD AND ON OF
ACTION AND IT. IS A NOT ACTORS
THAT WHAT WHETHER BUT
ULTIMATELY APPROVED MEASURES
UNDER THEIR CONSIDERATION. IT'S
ABOUT THIRTY. YEAH AND ON THE
FINAL PAGE OF THE HANDOUT- IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN WE DID AN
ANALYSIS ABOUT THE IMPACT OF
PROPOSITION THIRTEEN ON
DEVELOPER FEES AND HERE WE DID
FIND THAT THERE HAS BEEN AN
INCREASING IMPACT FEES.
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT TO COVER
THE COSTS OF YOU DEVELOPMENT AS
A RESULT OF PROP THIRTEEN AND
HERE WE SEE THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE SEEKING
ALTERNATIVES AND FEES PROVIDE.
FLEXIBILITY BECAUSE THEY DON'T
REQUIRE THE ROLE OF THE VOTERS.
WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
pQUESTIONS. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISS ROUNDS WERE GREATLY HE
WILL HOLD QUESTIONS WORKS FOR
THE COMMITTEES AND- I'M
ATTACHES IN HIS STATEMENT AND
WE WELCOME YOU TO COMMITTEE SIR
YEAH FIVE MINUTES WILL GIVE YOU
THIRTY SECOND PROMPTING
KEEPING. GREAT THANK YOU MY
NAME IS BRIAN AND I AM THE TERM
LAW FIRM COLLEGES. THE WHAT. TO
DENY. AND I'M HERE TO. STAY I
KNOW THE LETTER STAFFERS PLEASE
A- YOU IN LEGAL BACK HERE I
JUST WANT TO HIT SOME OF THE
HYPE. SISTER OF REITERATE SOME
OF THE POINTS THAT ARE IN THAT-
DOCUMENT BECAUSE IF WE STARTED
TALKING ABOUT MITIGATION FEE
LEGISLATION AND LITIGATION WE-
REALLY BE HERE ALL DAY. BUT I
TALK ABOUT MITIGATION FEES THAT
IS THIS REALLY A SUBSET OF THE
FEES THAT MIGHT BE LEVIED ON
NEW DEVELOPMENTS- ASIDE FROM
THE MITIGATION FEES THAT ARE
COVERED IN THE MITIGATION FEE
ACT WHICH IS A SPECIFIC. ST
OF. STATUTES IN THE GOVERNMENT
CO THERE ARE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IN LIEU FEES. THERE ARE
DEVELOPMENT AGREEMENT FEES
WHICH ARE REALLY SEPARATE THERE
BUT THEY'RE A MATTER OF CON.
LAW MORE SO THAN STE. WHEN YOU
HAVE ELEMENT IN. AGREEMENT WITH
THE DEVELOPER THE CITY AND THE
DEVELOPER CAN ENTRENCHED REALLY
ANY KIND OF FINANCIAL MISCHIEF
YOU WANT. WHICH IS OUTSIDE OF
THE MITIGATION FIAT CONTEXT.
YOU HAVE SUBDIVISION MAP ACT IN
LIEU FEES WHICH- CLEARLY
SEPARATE AGAIN FROM MANY IN
FEET. WE HAVE C<c.cyan> CáC PARK</c>
FEES. AND YOU HAVE UTILITY
CONNECTING FEES AND OTHER TYPES
THESE THAT ARE NOT SUBJECT TO
MITIGATE. THE ACT. SO TALK
ABOUT. ENDING TWO FEET ACTOR
HELLO. OF FURTHER. UNDER THE
MEDICATION FEE ACT. EXCUSE ME
HAVE TO CONSIDER ALL THE OTHER
FEE AND ALL THE OTHER WAYS TO
HAVE DEVELOPERS PAY FOR THE
IMPACTS OF THE DEVELOPMENTS
BECAUSE- IF YOU JUST START
FOCUSING ON MITIGATION FEES YOU
CAN REALLY LOSE SIGHT OF THE
UTILITY CONNECTION FEES AND
SCHOOLS AND OTHER FEES THAT MAY
DROP OFF THAT THE PRACTICE OF
HOUSING. AND JUST TO BACK THAT
ORDER SAID IN A STORE ACCOUNT
YEAR THERE HAS BEEN A
REASONABLE RELATIONSHIP QUOTE
UNQUOTE TEST FOR MITIGATION IN
OTHER CITIES IN THE STATE SINCE
NINETEEN FORTY NINE AND THAT
WAS EIGHT YEARS FIRST VIDEO.
SURGEON THAT WE A STANDARD FOR
A WHILE THERE WAS ANOTHER CASE
THAT CAME DOWN A FEW I THINK A
COUPLE DECADES LATER THAT
EXPANDED THAT. TO NOT ONLY THE
DIRECT. IMPACT OF DEVELOPMENT
BUT ALSO INDIRECT IMPACTS SO IF
A NEW DEVELOPMENT IS GOING TO
CAUSE. THE CITY OR THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT TO BUILD NEW SCHOOLS
YOU CAN GET CENTER THAT PART OF
THE IMPACTS OF THE END OF THE
NEW DEVELOPMENT AND IN CHARGE
FEES FOR THAT- FLOORS MENTIONED
I THINK IS THE OVER ARCHING.
THEME HERE PROPOSITION THIRTEEN
PASSED. OVER FORTY YEARS AGO
REALLY IMPACTED THE WAYS THAT
OUR PUBLIC ENTITIES COULD RAISE
FUNDS. AND SHIFT FOCUS AWAY FOR
PROPERTY TAXES AND MORE TOWARDS
ME IF YOU WAYS. TO HIS CAR. AB
SIXTEEN HUNDRED WAS ENACTED IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN WHICH
REALLY REREAD REITERATED THE
HEIRS TEST FROM NINETEEN FORTY
NINE AND CREATED THE MITIGATION
FEE ACT AND ALL THE
REQUIREMENTS THERE. AND THEN
THE OTHER OVER ARCHING. RUBRIC
HERE THAT- IMPACTS A LOT OF
THESE DISCUSSIONS ARE THE TWO
U. S. SUPREME COURT DECISIONS
OF NOLAN AND NOLAN. AND NOLAN
THE FIRST CASE WAS DECIDED IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN AND IN
THAT CASE THE IT WAS ACTUALLY A
CALIFORNIA CASE THE COASTAL
COMMISSION DEMANDED OF A
HOMEOWNER IN VENTURA COUNTY.
THAT IS A CONDITION OF
REBUILDING A FIVE HUNDRED
SQUARE FOOT BUNGALOW ON THE
BEACH THAT LANDOWNER HAD TO
ALSO GIVE AN EASEMENT TO THE
PUBLIC TO PASS IN FRONT OF HER
PROPERTY. AND SHE CHALLENGE
THAT ANYONE ALL THE WAY TO THE
SUPREME AND JUST TO SCHOOL
YESTERDAY. ALL THE ISSUE OF THE
BUILDING HOUSE WHICH IS GIVING
THE EASEMENT TO PASS IN FRONT
OF YOU AT HOME OWNERS BEACH WAS
NO CONSISTENT WITH. THIS THE
PERMISSION TRYING TO GET WITH
THE REBUILD HER HOME BE SO
THERE NEEDS TO BE A MATCH
BETWEEN THE CONDITION THAT THE
PUBLIC ENTITY REQUIRES. AND THE
PERSON WHO OWNS THE FORMER IS
TO BUILD A HOME NEEDS TO GIVE
UP. AND A SECOND DON'T ADDED ON
IT. NO ONE EIGHT SEVEN YEARS.
WHERE'D NOT ALL THE THINK
BETWEEN. FOR THE MISSION.
REASON THE PERMIT BUT- ALSO
REQUIRED A QUOTE ROUGH NOW
BETWEEN THE AMOUNT OF THE FEE
OR THE EXACTION AND THE IMPACT
OF THE PROJECT IN THAT CASE
THIS IS A CASE FROM OREGON AND
A SHOP OWNER IN OREGON APPLIED
TO EXPAND HER STORED TO REALLY
DOUBLE IN SIZE AND TO PAY FOR
PARKING LOT AND THE CITY AS A
CONDITION OF THOSE THINGS
REQUIRE TWO THINGS. TO REQUIRE
HER TO- GIVE UP LAND FOR A
PUBLIC GREEN WAY WHICH THE CITY
CLAIMED WOULD HELP WITH
FLOODING CONTROL AND ALSO TO
PROVE- PROVIDE LAND FOR A
PEDESTRIAN PATH THERE IN AGAIN
THE SUPREME COURT. DECISIONS
AND SAY WELL THERE IS A LINK
HERE BETWEEN EXPAND STORE AND
TING FLOODING IN AND HELPING
PEDESTRIANS CIRCULAR ON THE
AIR. BUT NO REPORT OF THE
BETWEEN FULL ACTIVE X. THE ONE
READ STORE AND REQUIRING THAT
RETAIL STORE TO REPEAT TAKE ON
THE BURDEN OF EXPANDING THIS
FLOODING AREA AND THE PASSING
THROUGH THE AIR. SO BECAUSE
THERE NO ROUGH THE POOR.
BETWEEN THE DEMANDS THAT THE
PUBLIC AND HE HAD AND WHAT THE
APPLICANT WAS TRYING TO
ACHIEVE. THAT WAS STRUCK DOWN
AS UNCONSTITUTIONAL. THIRTY
SECONDS ARE GREAT AND JUST TO.
AT THE CALIFORNIA LATER ON THAT
TWO YEARS LATER IN EARLY VERSUS
THE CITY OF CULVER CITY. THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT LOOKED
AT DOLE AND DOLE AND SAID YES
THOSE OF THOSE- REQUIREMENTS
APPLY HERE AND THEY TOOK A LOOK
AT A TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
THOUSAND DOLLAR RECREATION FEES
THE C. CULVER CITY. WANTED TO.
CHARGE A DEVELOPER WHO WANTED
TO TRANSFORM HIS TENNIS CLUB
INTO OUR DEVELOPMENT SO IT
FOUND THAT THERE WAS A LINK THE
NO LOOKING PIECE OF THIS WAS
FOUND BUT THE DOLAN PIECE OF
ROUGH PORTION AUDI WAS NOT
SUPPORTED BY IN THE RECORD SO.
THAT CASE WAS REMANDED FOR
FURTHER FAX AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT I
MIGHT BE ABLE TO. ANSWER THANK
YOU SO MUCH AT GRATEFUL TO BOTH
YOU WITH ACTIVITIES DUE TO
CHAIRSEVENTY QUESTIONS AND
THEN WE'LL GO TO VICE CHAIR
MORE. THE CHAIRS HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS AT THIS
TIME. CHAU ASK QUESTIONS-
CONSIDERING THE EXISTING FISCAL
RESTRAINT THE WRIST CONSTRAINTS
ON LOCAL AGENCIES WHAT YOU
CONSIDER TO BE A REASONABLE
CHANGES IN STATE LAW. OR THE
CONSTITUTION TO ENCOURAGE LOCAL
AGENCIES TO REDUCE OR ELIMINATE
IMPACT FEES. THAT'S MORE OF A
POLICY QUESTION IT I TRY TO
STAY AWAY FROM AS SOMEBODY.
WITH BAEZ'S. PUBLIC AGENCIES
BUT- BUT UNDER THE DAY THAT WE
CAN TAKE SOME REAL. UNDER THE
MITIGATION FEE ACT THE- S. AS
THE TURNER CENTERS REPORT
MENTIONS THE NEXUS STUDIES THAT
A LOT OF PUBLIC AGENCIES CREATE
TO JUSTIFY FEES ARE OFTEN TEN
TWENTY THIRTY YEARS OLD AND
THEY'RE THE INDIVIDUALIZED
DETERMINATION BETWEEN THE
IMPACTS OF A NEW DEVELOPMENT
AND- THE EFFECTS OF THAT
DEVELOPMENTS ARE NOT ALWAYS
LINKED AS CLOSELY AS A THIRTY
YEAR OLD PORT SUGGEST SO-
PERHAPS DATING REQUIRE OR- ONE
DOES NOT SUPPOSED TO ABOUT
SPECIFICS BUT ONE OF THE BILLS
IS SUGGESTING A MORE INDIVIDUAL.
THE TERM. I THAT MY WAY TO GO.
MISTER CHAIR. JUST A COUPLE
QUICK TO THE LA- USE AT THE END
OF YOUR REPORT THE CALIFORNIA
IMPACT FEES ARE HIGHER THAN
MANY STATES AN IMPACT FEES HAVE
INCREASED IN RECENT YEARS DO
YOU HAVE MORE ANY OTHER DATA
ABOUT THAT THAT WE COULD
RECEIVE. ALL WE- HAD TO SOME
DATA AND A PUBLICATION THAT WE
PUBLISH THE TIME SO WE CAN GET
THAT TO YOUR STAFF THE GREAT
THANK YOU. IT IS CHECK. COULD
YOU OF ICE YOU'RE MORE LIKE IN
OF THE SENIOR MEMBERS MISTER
VICE CHAIR THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I. ACTIONS HAVE
CONSEQUENCES AND SO WE WERE
ALREADY HAD SOME REACTIONS TO
IMPACT FEES. I DIDN'T HEAR
EASIER IF YOU MENTION MILLER IS
DISTRICTS WOULD YOU PLEASE
COMMENT. WELL THOSE ARE ANOTHER
SUBSET OF FEES THAT I KNOW SOME
OF THE PROPOSED LEGISLATION
WOULD INCLUDE IN THE CHANGES
THAT ARE BEING PROPOSED TO
LIMIT MITIGATION FEES BUT
MILLER RISKY THERE ARE JUST A
NEWER- I GUES SUBSET OF
RAISING. REVENUES TO FUND
SERVICES IN NEW AREAS SO IT'S
REALLY KIND OF ANOTHER LAYER ON
THIS ANOTHER SUBSET OF THESE
MITIGATION FEES THAT I
UNDERSTAND- ALL- COVERED BY THE
DILLON DILLON REQUIREMENTS IN
AN EARLY THINGS OF THAT NATURE.
BUT ONE DAY. IN A MINUTE AS IT
WOULD ALLOW DEVELOPERS TO HAVE
LOWER IMPACT FEES. I AM THE
BUYER OF THE HOME WOULD HAVE TO
PAY FOR THE INSTRUCTOR
INFRASTRUCTURE THROUGH THEIR
MILLER'S ASSESSMENT WHICH COULD
BE RATHER SUBSTANTIAL THAT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING I KNOW OF THE
EFFECTS OF THAT PRACTICALLY BUT
UNDERSTAND THAT WAS INTENT OF
THE BELARUS ACT SO THAT WAS OUR
OUR- WAY TO ADDRESS. I'M JUST
WAS JUST WHY THAT WOULDN'T BE
INCLUDED IN THE NARRATIVE SO
SUBSEQUENT TO PROP THIRTEEN IN
THE VOTER CARMEN'S WE DID SEE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WERE LOOKING
FOR ALTERNATIVES TO FIND THE
YOU KNOW SERVICES NECESSARY
NECESSITATED BY NEW
DEVELOPMENTS AND SO. EITHER ONE
MILLER AND OTHER IN THE
PUBLICATION THAT I MENTIONED WE
DID COMMENT AS WELL AND ALL THE
MILLER REASON DID SEE THAT
THERE HAS BEEN AN INCREASE- IN
MORE RECENT YEARS AND ALSO GET
THE DETAILS. TO YOU. IS WE- IS
SURE BROTHER PROBABLY FULLY OUT.
AND THERE'S A QUESTION AS TO
WHY CHARGE IMPACT THESE AS MOST
OF THE INFRASTRUCTURES IN PLACE
COMPARED TO CITIES THAT ARE
GROWING STILL HAVE REAL ESTATE-
JUST WONDER IF YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTS IN THAT REGARD. Y. NOS
AND- WHEN WE THINK WHAT IMPACT
FEES IT'S NOT JUST BUILDING NEW
ROADS AND SCHOOLS IS OFTEN I'M
SUPPORTING POLICE SERVICES
SUPPORTING FIRE SERVICES
SUPPORTING LIBRARY SERVICES SO
WHEN YOU CREATE A DENSER CITY.
DO NOT NECESSARILY BUILDING NEW
ROADS ARE EXPANDING SEWERS YOUR
OFTEN PUTTING MORE STRAIN ON
LIBRARIES AND OTHER PUBLIC
SERVICES SO- IS THERE MAY NOT
BE THE LEVEL. OR THE TYPE OF
IMPACT FEES YOU FIND IN LETTER
BUILT OUT CITIES. WHEN YOU
BUILD AN INFILL SITES IN BIGGER
CITIES THERE ALREADY BUILT OUT
BUT IT THE TYPES OF IMPACTS
CHANGE. IN THESE OLDER CITIES.
YEAH BUT THERE ARE ALSO SOME
IMPACT THAT OUR TRAILER FEET.
I'LL GIVEN. THE ROAD SOUTH
COUNTY. AND ANYBODY THAT DOES
IT KIND OF A MENTOR CHECKED
ANYWHERE WITHIN THE VICINITY OF
A SUDDEN FINDS A BILL IN THE
MAIL- THAT IS TO PAY FOR
SOMETHING THAT'S ALREADY BEEN
DEALT. GENERAL SO JUST
INTERESTING SOMEBODY'S WERE AS
A CANCER YOUR WHEN WE EXPANDED
JOHN WAYNE AIRPORT ALL THE
SUDDEN CARL'S JUNIOR WHICH IS A
TEN IT GETS THIS MASSIVE BILL
FOR THE TOLL ROADS WHICH HAD NO
RELATION SO THERE'S LOTS OF
ROOM FOR IMPROVEMENT MAYBE EVEN
AN OLDER. AGREED THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER BRAZIER CHARMING. THANK
YOU YOU KNOW I JUST THINK THIS-
AND ESPECIALLY THE EXAMPLE THAT
YOU GAVE OUT WITH THE CASE THAT
WENT TO THE SUPREME COURT. AT
AND CENTER MORE LIKES COMMENTS
ANY REYES IS ACTUALLY. ONE OF
THE FUNDAMENTAL ISSUES HERE
WITH HIM IMPACT FEES ARE
EXACTIONS OR WHATEVER WHEN I'VE
CALLED OUT. THAT WE ARE
EFFECTIVELY. IT'S ONE THING
WHERE YOU HAVE SOMEVERY L<c.cyan>G</c>
THAT THIS PARTICULAR PROJECT IS
GOING TO CAUSE A NEED FOR MORE
SIDEWALKS. YOU KNOW LINK TO IT
THE THAT THAT'S- I GET THAT
MORE ONE OF THE CHALLENGES OF
IMPACT FEES AND EXACTIONS IN
GENERAL. IS THAT YOU END UP
PAYING FOR GENERAL SERVICES THE
BENEFIT EVERYONE AND EVERYONE
IS. PUTTING A STRAIN ON A
SYSTEM WHETHER YOU LIVE THERE
FOR FIFTY YEARS OR OR YOU'RE A
NEW RESIDENT. IT'S BASICALLY
SAYING THAT NEW RESIDENTS HAVE
TO PAY FOR SERVICES. WHEREAS
THE EXISTING RESIDENTS DON'T
HAVE TO PAY FOR IT WE'RE GONNA
MAKE HOUSING MORE EXPENSIVE FOR
THE NEW RESIDENTS. TO PAY FOR-
OR PART. EMPLOYEES SERVICE TO
EVERYONE. IS BETTER FROM AND IT
CREATES A DISTORTION IN THE
SYSTEM. IN ADDITION ON IMPACT
FEES IN MY VIEW SHOULD. ONLY BE
USED FOR ONE TIME- COSTS
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS
RELATED SPECIFICALLY. TO THAT
PROJECT THE THING WHEN YOU
START EXPAND IT BEYOND THAT.
AND CITIES BECOME RELIANT ON
IMPACT IT'S FOR A LIKE.
SERVICES OUR LIBRARY SERVICES.
IT IS. TIME PAYMENT IT'S NOT
COMING IN EVERY YEAR THE WAY
THE TAX REVENUES FROM ALL
RESIDENTS COMMENT AND IT'S
GONNA GO OFF A CLIFF IF THE
ECONOMY GOES INTO A DOWNTURN
MUCH MORE SO THAN OTHER TAXES
BECAUSE DEVELOPMENT TENDS TO BE
ONE OF THE FIRST THINGS TO DRY
OUT.SO IT'S A VERY VERY
SUSTAINABLE A OF FUNDING TO THE
SERVICES- AND IT AND IT CAN BE
EXCEPTIONALLY UNFAIR AND
INEQUITABLE BY FORCING BY
SAYING WELL BECAUSE YOU'RE A
NEW RESIDENT YOU GOT TO PAY
MORE. PEOPLE WANT TO WHICH I
THINK YOU KNOW WE DO THAT WITH
PROP THIRTEEN AND WE IT'S VERY
UNFAIR. AND RECOGNIZE THE
PEOPLE MOVE AROUND THAT PEOPLE
SHOULD BE PENALIZED FOR MOVING
INTO A CITY SO IT'S A
FUNDAMENTAL ISSUE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH THE CHAIR WOULD LIKE TO
SEE IF THERE AE ANY MEMBERS
WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE A COMMON
TO OR HAVE QUESTIONS WITH THIS
PANEL AYE BORN CLOSE IN THE
ENTRANCE AND THE WOMAN. JUST A
COMMENT FOR THE RECORD HAVING
BEYOND OUT. YOU KNOW OF LET'S
SAY A VICTIM OF PRE PROP
THIRTEEN PROPERTY TAXES ARE WE
HAD JUST PURCHASED A HOME AND
COULDN'T EVEN AFFORD. OUR
PROPERTY TAXES AT THAT TIME
THAT WE NINETEEN NOT. EQUAL
SIXTY EARLY SO PROP THIRTEEN
KING IN BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE
LOSING THEIR HOMES BECAUSE
PROPERTY TAXES WERE INCREASING
SIGNIFICANTLY. SO I THINK WE
NEED A KING AND A BALANCED OF
MITIGATION FEE. INCREASED THE
COST WELCOME TO KNOW CAN ON FOR
TO. OVER THE COURSE OF THE
YEARS WE'VE HAD PROP THIRTEEN I
THINK THAT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
COMPONENT IN THIS DISCUSSION
BECAUSE- IT WAS A SENIOR
COMMUNITIES THAT WERE REALLY
HIT AND I KNOW THAT. PERSONALLY
WELL MY FATHER WAS A BANKER AT
THE TIME AND THE ONLY WAY WE
WERE ABLE TO SAVE OUR HOME. IS
BECAUSE HE GAVE US ALONE WHEN
OUR INCOME WHO IS. PROBABLY LOW
LOW LOW INCOME AT THAT TIME AS
MY HUSBAND WAS A STUDENT AND I
HAD JUST STARTED IN A JOB. IN
MY MONTHLY INCOME WAS FOUR
HUNDRED SEVENTEEN DOLLARS. IN
OUR PRICE TAG IS OR SOMETHING
LIKE TO STOP IN AT THAT TIME.
SO WE NEED TO THE- I WOULD
ASSUME LEO AND SOME DO THE-
FISCAL ANALYSIS. WE GO DOWN
THERE ROAD GIVE US COMPARE OF
WHERE WE WOULD BE. IF WE DIDN'T
HAVE- MITIGATION BELARUS WAS
HUGE IN SOUTH ORANGE COUNTY WOW
THAT'S HOW WE WERE ABLE TO
BUILD THE COMMUNITIES THAT WE
HAVE. WE HAVE PEOPLE WHO
BASICALLY LOOK NOW FOR
PROPERTIES THAT DON'T HAVE MEL
REDUCE ARE ALREADY PAID THEM
OUT. AS AN INTERN MORE LUCK
MENTION BECAUSE WE ARE ON THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AT THAT
TIME PEOPLE IN THE NEW
DEVELOPMENTS ON WE HERE AT THE
200-082-0009 RECESSION. OR LOSE
THEIR HOMES NOT BECAUSE OF
THEIR PROPERTY TAXES BECAUSE OF
THEIR MIL ROUTE. WHICH WAS
USED. AS ANOTHER WAY TO BUILD
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WE'RE NOT
ABOUT PEOPLE. I'M HAVING MORE.
SERVICE HE WAS. THERE WAS NO
THE STATION IN THE RURAL AREAS
THE THREE. TO SOURCE ON FIRE.
SO THE LOWERS OR TO. PO SAFETY
AT THAT TIME SO WE NEED TO LOOK
AT THE COMPONENTS OF WHAT WE'VE
GOT HERE. AND MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE A BALLOT AND NOT.
DEMONIZING ONE AGAINST THE
OTHER BECAUSE WE GOING FORWARD
THERE'S A SOLUTION I THINK WE
ALL BELIEVE THAT OR WE WOULDN'T
BE IN THIS ROOM. BUT WE NEED TO
LOOK AT HOW WE GOT HERE BUT
WHAT IF WE WEREN'T HERE WITH
MEDICATION VIEWS WERE. PROPERTY
TAXES FOR EXAMPLE WOULD WE HAVE
AFFORDABLE. IN BASED ON MY
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE ALL THOSE
YEARS AGO NO WE WOULDN'T
BECAUSE WE DIDN'T DOWN. SO I
JUST ADD THAT TO OUR DISCUSSION
AND I LOOK TO OUR EXPERTS TO.
DEAL WITH SOME OF THAT SO WE
BRING SOME BACK. TO OUR- OUR
OUR FINAL- AGAIN WE WOULD HAVE
OUR RECOMMENDATIONS THAT COME
OUT OF OUR HEARINGS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR. LAYS
ENGINE THE COMMITTEES WE'RE
GONNA GO TO CENTER CUT HERE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY HERE TODAY THAT THE
TOPIC IS HOW DID WE GET HERE
AND I THINK. AS A FOOTNOTE TO
HOW WE GOT HERE IS THAT IS THAT
IN. THE REAL. CLEAR EXAMPLE OF.
HOW ONE SIZE DOESN'T FIT ALL-
IN RURAL CALIFORNIA. MANY AT
THE COMMUNITIES ARE BLUE COLLAR
COMMUNITIES. THAT NEVER HAD
ENOUGH REVENUE TO DO- THINGS
THAT. EXPECTS CITIES. GOOD
LIBRARY SERVICE PARK SERVICES
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS. AND IN
MANY COMMUNITIES. THE CITY
JURISDICTION GREW. AND INCLUDED
COUNTY AND INCORPORATED
NEIGHBORS THAT HAD NO CURBS
GUTTERS SIDEWALKS SEWERS AND
WATER SERVICE THEY WERE ON
WELLS AND- YET WHEN THE
ANNEXATION OCCURRED. THOSE
IMPROVEMENTS WEREN'T OFFERED TO
THE RESIDENCE. MOSTLY BECAUSE
THEY DIDN'T HAVE ANY MONEY TO
PAY FOR THE INFRASTRUCTURE AND
THE- CITY THAT WAS GROWING
DIDN'T HAVE THE MONEY- WE'VE
SOLVED THAT PROBLEM NOW IN
REQUIRE ANNEXATION BUT- I HAVE
A NUMBER OF COMMUNITIES IN IN
MY DISTRICT. THAT HAVE COUNTY
AND INCORPORATE IT INSIDE CITY
LIMITS AND THAT ARE IN
ATROCIOUS SHAPE AND SO WHEN WE
START LOOKING AT FEES AND- AND-
I'M- I KNEW. IT'S PART OF THE
WAY THAT YOU GET THE CAPITAL TO
BE ABLE TO ADD PARK SERVICES TO
ADD- LIBRARY SERVICES AND- IN
IN MY COMMUNITY I RAN THIRTY
YEARS AGO AS A CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER TO EXPAND OUR LIBRARY
AND IT'S ONLY THROUGH IMPACT
FEES THAT WE WERE ABLE TO DO
BUT IT TOOK THIRTY YEARS SO- SO
THE CHALLENGES I THINK WE IS
THAT- MEAN THERE REALLY ARE IN
WHEN HE'S IN MUNICH IS IN PART
OF WITH COUNCILS AND THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS. MAYBE TRYING
ROUTE HOW CAN THE STANDARD UP
FOR EVERYONE. AND I WOULD AGREE
WITH MY COLLEAGUE THAT IT
SHOULD BE- CAPITAL IMPROVEMENTS
NOT ONGOING SERVICES BECAUSE
THAT I THINK THAT'S PROBLEMATIC
FOR THE REST OF THE RESIDENTS
BUT AYE AYE THIS IS AN
INTERESTING- DISCUSSION I
EXPECT WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO HAVE MORE- DISCUSSIONS ON
THIS IS WE SEE SOME OF THE
BILLS COME AROUND BUT- BUT I'VE
BEEN SPENT FIFTEEN YEARS IN
LOCAL COVER. AND PROTECT THE
ABILITY ABLE TO MAKE DECISIONS
FOR THE INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS OF
YOUR LOCAL COMMUNITY. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I AM SENATOR AT LAST. QUESTION
FOR MR DONE. LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TALK TO US ABOUT SOFT COSTS
VERSUS HEART COSTS. AND THEY
GIVE US EXAMPLE OF THAT. 6270%
OF THE HOMES COST IS GOING TO
BE MATERIALS AND LABOR. AND YOU
BREAK DOWN THE SOFT COSTS COULD
BE 2230% IF POTENTIALLY 5% OF
THAT TWENTY TO THIRTY PERCENT-
IT IS. FEES TALK ABOUT THAT A
LITTLE BIT BECAUSE I THINK
THAT'S AN ISSUE THAT. WE NEED
TO RAISE TODAY- AND KNOW THAT
THERE'S ONGOING PRESSURE ON
THIS AND OBVIOUSLY THIS IS A
CRITICAL ISSUE WHEN. HOUSING
SHORTAGE BUT THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE HEAR FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND IF YOU WANT TO
COMMENT ON THAT SINCE YOU
REPRESENT THEM WELL. AGAIN I
THINK IT'S DOWN TO THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN INFILL
DEVELOPMENT VERSUS. ONE ANGLER
HERE. OUR THE IMPACT INFILL
DEVELOPMENT WHERE YOU DON'T
NEED TO EXTEND SEWER PROBABLY
WE DON'T NEED TO EXTEND ROADS
ARE REALLY KIND OF A- THAT IT'S
HARD TO TALK ABOUT IMPACT FEES
IN IN NUMBERS LIKE RUN NUMBERS
LIKE 5% WHEN YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT DIFFERENT TYPES OF
DEVELOPMENT WHEN YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT A SUBDIVISION- ROSEVILLE
VERSUS AN INFILL DEVELOPMENT A
LOS ANGELES THOSE ARE TWO
DIFFERENT THINGS AND- PROBABLY.
OF THREE DIFFERENT CONSULT
THESE IMPACTS AND HAVING THREE
DIFFERENT RESULTS AT WHAT THE
IMPACTS REALLY ARE SO WHEN YOU
START TALKING ABOUT FEES AND
WHO SHOULD BE PAYING THEM AND
IN ONE WHAT TYPE TO DELIVER THE
SHOULD BE READ ONLINE IT'S
DIFFICULT TO HAVE A ONE SIZE
FITS ALL IT'S ALL SOLUTION AS
AS THE MEMBER MENTIONED JUST
NOW. THERE ARE THE ONES REQUIRE
DIFFERENT LEVELS OF SERVICES
ARE DIFFERENT IS. DIFFICULT TO
SET FIRM I GUESS FLOORS OR
CEILINGS HERE AS FAR AS LEVELS
OF SERVICE ARE FEES ARE
PERCENTAGES IN SOME RESPECTS
BECAUSE THE- ALBUMS THAT WE
HAVE WITH. EATING TO DEVELOP
THEM EVERYWHERE IN THE GREEN
FIELDS ARE NOT JUST AN INFILL
SITES IT'S HARD TO HAVE A ONE
SIZE FITS ALL SOLUTION THAT
WOULD- APPLY EVERYWHERE SO I
RESPECT I RESPECT THAT THAT.
FEES ARE ARE LARGE ON AVERAGE-
BUT I THINK IT'S DIFFICULT TO
REALLY TACKLE THE PROBLEM
WITHOUT RECOGNIZING THE
DIFFERENCE IS THAT THERE ARE NO
I APPRECIATE HIM STUNT WILL ASK
THAT PERSON RUNNING COME UP
HERE AS WELL. THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU CAN. EXCUSE ME THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY WE APPRECIATE
IT WILL MOVE ON THE HIGHER NEXT
PANEL I WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME
UP- FOR ARE GETTING WHAT YOU
PAY FOR HOW ARE HIM IMPACT FEES.
JOSH ABRAHAMS FROM THE
PRINCIPAL FROM BEARD AND
DRISKELL. VINCE WELLS PRESIDENT
THE CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
FIREFIGHTERS LOCAL TWELVE
THIRTY. STEPH SANDERS LANDSCAPE
ARCHITECT IMPART PLANNER FOR
THE FROM THE NORTH OF THE RED
RIVER RECEATION PARK DISTRICT
WITH HIS MOUTH. A GENERAL HALLS
FOR FROM THE SOPRANO COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY. AS
WELL AS CHERYL CLARY EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF FINANCE AND
ADMINISTRATION FROM THE IRVINE
RANCH WATER DISTRICT- WE CAN
MAKE SURE WE HAVE ENOUGH SEATS
UP THERE. WELCOME OF JOSH IF
YOU'D LIKE TO START. THANK YOU
MY NAME'S JOSH ABRAHAMS I AM A
CITY PLANNER AND I HELP CITIES
PLAN FOR HOUSING BOTH
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND MARKET
RATE HOUSING THEY JUST WANNA
START BY SAYING THAT I KNOW
FEES GET A LOT OF ATTENTION IN
EVERYONE HATES THEM THEY'RE
EASY TO HATE. BUT FOR THE MOST
IN MOST CASES THEY'RE NOT THAT
THE BIGGEST PROBLEM THERE ARE
EXCEPTIONS BUT STE IN FEES
RANGE IN THE THREE OR 4% OF
TOTAL DEVELOPMENT COSTS. AND UP
A BIG WORD OF CAUTION THAT THE
CITIES THAT ARE GROWING UP FAST
ARE THE ONES THAT TEND TO HAVE
THE HIGHEST IMPACT FEES AND
THEY USE THAT. FUN BEING TO PAY
FOR THE CRITICAL OFFICER TO
ALLOW EXPANSION AND THERE'S A
POTENTIAL LIMITING THAT THE HE
IS THE LIMIT THE FAST SAID THIS.
WITH THAT SAID I WILL ORGANIZE
A MY IS STILL. COMMENTS ARE
THREE POINT THE FIRST IS. OF
AFFORDABLE I IMPACT FEES ARE
ESSENTIAL FOR TO GET NEW
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. BEFORE I GO
INTO THAT IT JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE WE'RE ALL ON THE SAME PAGE
ABOUT HOW. HOW THEY WORK. SO
WHEN THE CITY HAS A NEW MARKET
REDEVELOPMENT WILL PAY. A FEE
TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING TRUST
FUND. THE CITIES WILL COLLECT
THAT MONEY AND RELEASE A
REQUEST FOR PROPOSALS.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
WILL SEND IN THEIR PROPOSALS
THE CITY WILL SELECT ONE OF
THEM AND SEND THE MONEY TO THAT
TO THAT OF. A HOUSING
DEVELOPER. THE OTHER ELEMENTS
WILL WILL NOT MOVE FORWARD
BECAUSE THEY NEED THAT MONEY.
THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOP-
THAT LOCAL MONEY WITH- BUT WITH
PHILANTHROPIC OR FEDERAL TAX
FUND DOLLARS. GETS MULTIPLE
MULTIPLE. I'VE MANY TIMES IN
THE ELEMENT MOVES FORWARD. THIS
SITE. THE LOW MONEY IF ONE KEEP
POINT IS THAT LOCAL MY IS A
SENSE FOR ADDITIONAL MONEY THE
FOUNDATION OF ALMOST EVERY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECT IS
FEDERAL TAX CREDIT DOLLARS AND
THE WORK AS A MATCH AND VOTE
MUCH LIKE YOUR YOUR RETIREMENT
PLAN EXCEPT IT'S NOT A ONE TO
ONE MATCH USUALLY AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPER WILL GET
MULTIPLE DOLLARS THREE OR MORE
FOR EACH DOLLAR THAT THEY BUILT
FREE LOCAL DOLLAR THEY PRETTY
WHICH EVEN MORE WITH BACK TO
ANOTHER OF COURSE ISN'T.
THEY'RE SORT. I WILL NEVER PAY
THE FULL SOURCE OF UP A FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND THEY
NEED THE PROJECTS ONLY PENCIL
IF THAT IF THE CITY CONTRIBUTES
AS WELL AND IN ONE OF THE
REALLY IMPORTANT POINT WITH
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DOLLARS IS
THAT LOCAL MONEY IS ONLY IT'LL
PAY FOR PRE DEVELOPMENT- OR
EARLY CALL FEASIBILITY THE
GOVERNMENT WILL PAY FOR IT AND
BACK. PAY FOR IT YOU NEED THAT
WOULD NEED TO LOCAL THE MONEY
TO LAY THE GROUNDWORK. SO MY
SECOND POINT IS GENERALLY
IMPACT FEES PUSH DOWN THE PRICE
OF DEVELOP A LAND THAT'S THEIR
MEAN A FACT. REAL ESTATE
ECONOMICS IS COMPLICATED BUT IT
REALLY BOILS DOWN TO SALES
PRICE CONSTRUCTION COSTS
PROFITS AND LAND CROSS.
STARTING AT THE END THE SALES
PRICE IS SET BY THE MARKET THE
DEVELOPER REALLY HAS VERY
LITTLE CONTROL OVER IT TO THE-
IT'S DETERMINED BY EVERYONE
LOOKING FOR HOUSES AND THERE'S
ENOUGH HOUSES ON THE MARKET
THAT IF. IF THE PRICE IS TO THE
BUYER WILL JUST GO ELSEWHERE
YOU CAN'T PAY MORE YOU CAN
EXPECT PEOPLE TO PAY MORE AND
GET LESS SOMETIMES IT WORKS FOR
THE DEVELOPERS ADVANTAGES
PRICES INCREASED WHILE THEY'RE
DOING CONSTRUCTION THEY'LL
INCREASE THEIR PRICES. AND
SOMETIMES IF THEY'RE COSTS
INCREASE IT THEY DON'T THAT
THEY'D SO THEY SUFFER. SIMILAR
DEVELOPERS HAVE VERY LITTLE
CONTROL OVER CONSTRUCTION COSTS
THERE'S NO ONE NOTHING THEY CAN
SAY TO A CONSTRUCTION COMPANY
TO GET THEM TO GIVE THEM A
LOWER BID THOSE COSTS FROM THE
DEVELOPER'S PERSPECTIVE OUR
FIX. HAS ARE THE PROFITS
DEVELOPERS HAVE THEIR TARGETS
AND WHEREVER THEY'RE GETTING
THEIR MONEY FROM THE PENSION
FUND OUR BANK OR WHEREVER. THEY
ALL HAVE THOSE THRESHOLD SO FOR
DEVELOPER CAN'T MAKE THAT
PROFIT THRESHOLD THEY JUST
WON'T BE ABLE TO DO THE
DEVELOPMENT. THE ONLY THING THE
ONLY. THERE'S A YOU ROOM IN
QUESTION IS PLAN PRICES WHEN
PRICES ARE A DIRECT DIRECT
REFLECTION OF HOW MUCH
DEVELOPMENT IS POSSIBLE. SO IF
CITY THESE OPENS IN DOUBLES THE
NUMBER OF UNITS THERE ALLOWED.
OR HOUSING PRICES. THE AND PUSH
THE PRESS THE PRICE. IF THERE'S
ADDITIONAL CONSTRUCTION COSTS
ARE IMPACT FEES DEVELOPERS WILL
DOES NOT BE ABLE TO PAY AS MUCH
FOR PRICE FOR LAND AND OVER
TIME THE PRICE OF LAND WILL GO
DOWN. YOU CAN SEE IT FINAL
SALES PRICE YOU START WITH THAT
YOU REMOVE CONSTRUCTION COST IN
THE PROFITS IN IN THE TOP
EXAMPLES FIFTY DOLLARS I AM
VERY SIMPLE NUMBERS IN THE
BOTTOM EXAMPLE WE ADDED ON FIVE
DOLLARS A FIVE POINT YOU'VE GOT
ON FIVE DOLLARS TO THE
CONSTRUCTION COSTS IN THE NET
EFFECT IS NOT ON FOR ONE BUT
PRETTY CLOSE THE- UC THE PRICES
THE PRICE FOR LAND DOWN. WHICH
BRINGS UP TO TWENTY THIRD POINT
WHICH TO FOCUS ON THE BAD
ACTORS BECAUSE WHAT'LL HAPPEN
SOME TIMES IS IT FEES ARE SO
HIGH THIS LAND PRICE. THE
DEVELOPERS PLAN ISN'T ENOUGH TO
ACTUALLY BUY THE LAND IT'S MORE
IN THE PROPERTY OWNERS INTEREST
TO KENYA WHATEVER YOU'RE DOING
A USED CAR LOT OR A MCDONALD'S
AND THEY WON'T SELL DEVELOPERS.
THAT WHAT'S SO WE A- FEES
PLEASE BE BEFORE AT. THE IMPACT
FEES TO MAKE THAT YOUR KNOCKING
THAT PREVENT NEW DEVELOPMENT
FROM HAPPENING. SO THERE ARE
THERE ARE EXCEPTIONS THERE ARE
SOME CITIES THAT ARE USING
THEIR FEES TO PREVENT NEW
DEVELOPMENT FOR THE MOST PART
IT'S AN ESSENTIAL PART OF
PROVIDING INFRASTRUCTURE AND
ALLOWING YOU DEVELOP ACTUALLY
HAPPEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND WELCOME VINCE
WELLS FROM THE CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY FIREFIGHTERS LOCAL
TWELVE THIRTY THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING TO THE COMMITTEE WHEN
HE WAS VINCE WELLS I'M A FIRE
CAPTAIN PARAMEDIC WITH TWENTY
FOUR YEARS X. SPIRITS AND I
WORK FOR CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
FIRE PROTECTION DISTRICT ALSO
SERVICE THE PRESIDENT OF-
CONTRA COSTA FIREFIGHTERS LOCAL
TWELVE THIRTY AND I REPRESENT
FOR SPECIAL DISTRICTS AND- TO
CITY FIRE DEPARTMENTS OF OVER
FOUR GIN SIXTY FIREFIGHTERS.
AND THERE'S ONE PLACE WHERE THE
PRICES OF ELATION IS VERY STEEP
IT'S IN THE AREA OF FIRE
PROTECTION. AS FIREFIGHTERS
WERE RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE OF TWO
TRENDS THAT ARE COMPETING WITH
EACH OTHER. ON ONE HAND IT'S
GROWING THREAT POSED BY DROUGHT
AND WILDFIRE. AND THAT'S THE
WRITTEN IN OUR URBAN AND
SUBURBAN COMMUNITIES AND THAT'S
WHAT WE CALL THE WILDLAND URBAN
INTERFACE AT THE SAME TIME THE
NEED FOR HOUSING CONTINUES TO
PUSH DEVELOPMENT FURTHER AND
FURTHER INTO THESE HIGHLY RISKY
AREAS. SAYS WE ARE DEVELOPING
OUT WE ARE ALSO DEVELOPING UP
MORE MORE HIGH DENSITY HOUSING
TALLER AND TALLER STRUCTURES SO
MORE PEOPLE MORE STRUCTURED AND
MORE TERRITORY TO COVER. ALL
THAT TRANSLATES TO GREAT- RISA
TO LIVES AND PROPERTY AND
SPECIAL FAR DISTRICTS LIKE THE
ONE I WORK FOR AND THE ONES I
REPRESENT MEETING THIS
CHALLENGE IS EVEN HARDER.
SINGLE PURPOSE FIRE DISTRICT
ESSENTIALLY ARE RUNNING ON A
FIXED INCOME AND THAT'S JUST
PROPERTY TAXES. I LIKE CITIES
AND COUNTIES BAR DISTRICTS
CAN'T GO OUT AND RAISE SALES
TAXES- TO PAY FOR EVER
EXPANDING DEVELOPMENT. AND EVEN
WORSE MANY SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ARE STUCK WITH OUTDATED
DISTRIBUTION FORMULAS ESTABLISH
BY PROP THIRTEEN. EVEN WHEN THE
NEW DEVELOPMENT OCCURS THERE'S
NO GUARANTEE ANY ADDITIONAL
REVENUE WILL GO TO THE SPECIAL
DISTRICTS. AND A LOT OF THAT
NEW DEVELOPMENT THE TAX RATE.
IS ALREADY ESTABLISHED- BY PROP
THIRTEEN SO AN AREA. THAT'S NOT
EVEN DEVELOP WERE ALREADY
HABITS TAX RATE ESTABLISH AN
AND SO DEPENDING ON THE SIZE OF
THAT DEVELOPMENT. YOU KNOW THAT
WOULD HAVE AN IMPACT. SO AS A
STANDS RIGHT NOW IMPACT FEES
ARE THE- THE ONLY WAY WE CAN
BEGIN TO CLOSE THE GAP BETWEEN
THE SERVICES WE PROVIDE. THE
NEEDS WE FACE. FIRE DISTRICTS
IMPACT FEES ARE USED TO BUILD
NEW FIRE STATIONS. PURCHASED
NEW APPARATUS AND EQUIPMENT.
AND SO TO GIVE AND I ARE YOU
ALSO FIRE ENGINE IS AROUND
SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
TO A MILLION DOLLARS. AND THEY
RECOMMENDED THAT THEIR REPLACED
EVERY TEN YEARS OR EVERY
HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND MILES.
SO FOR FIRE STATIONS THERE'S A
COST OF THE LAND IN THE
CONSTRUCTION IN THESE. AREAS
FACE AND MORE AND MORE
DEVELOPMENT. AND ONCE AGAIN
THEIR ESTABLISHED OF TAX RATES
ARE ALREADY ESTABLISHED SO YOU
CAN ADJUST. TO WHAT THAT
COMMUNITIES GONNA LOOK LIKE.
AND THERE'S SIMPLY NO WAY THESE
ESSENTIAL PURCHASES CAN BE MADE
WITH ARE RESTRICTED OPERATING
BUDGETS. JUST GIVE ME AN
EXAMPLE OF ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT WE HAVE A COUPLE
MAJOR EXPANSION PROJECTS IN
GOING ON A CONTRA COSTA COUNTY-
WHICH IS SIMILAR GRAYSON AWARE
OF WE HAVE A- CONCORD OF NAVAL
WEAPONS- THAT'S SCHEDULED TO BE
REDEVELOPED. AS WELL AS
NORTHERN WATER CURRENT. IN A
LOT OF THOSE AREAS ARE TO BE
COVERED BY. FIRE FIRE
DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE FIRE
DISTRICTS- LIKE I SAID THERE'S
A BIG DIFFERENCE ABOUT
REPRESENTING TO CITY
DEPARTMENTS. AS WELL LIKE
THERE'S A BIG DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN HOW YOU CAN MANAGE OF
GROWTH AND DEVELOPMENT- SO AS A
WHOLE RANGE DEVELOPMENT
PROJECTS. THAT LET ME MOVE ON.
SO WITHOUT IMPACT FEES IT WOULD
BE TOUGH TO PUT FIRE AND
MEDICAL PROTECTION CLOSE. TO
WHERE WOULD BE NEEDED. FOR US
HOWEVER IMPACT FEES IS THE ONLY
WAY IS THE ONLY PART OF THE
CRITICAL FUNDED EQUATION. SINCE
THESE BABIES CAN ONLY BE USED
FOR CAPITAL CAPITAL EXPENSES
THAT STILL LEAVES THE QUESTION
OF STAFFING THESE GROWING
DEMANDS. ALL THE FIRE ENGINES
IN A ROW CAN'T SAVE A LIFE IF
THERE'S NOBODY THERE STEP. SO
THE LIMIT TEMPO BY PROP
THIRTEEN ALLOCATIONS AND
SPECIAL DISTRICTS HAS CREATED
AN IMPOSSIBLE IMPOSSIBLE
CHOICES FOR THOSE OF US ON THE
FRONT LINES. RECENTLY IN
ELDORADO COUNTY OF A FIRE CHIEF
ACTUALLY. QUIT TO SAVE THE OF
FIREFIGHTERS JOB AFTER A
MEASURE. OF FAILED OUT THERE.
THIS YEAR THE LEGISLATURE IS.
AGAIN CONSIDERING ACA ONE
UNKNOWN- AND IF APPROVED BY
LEGISLATION VOTERS IT WOULD.
GIVE VOTERS AN OPTION TO
FINANCE AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
INFRASTRUCTURE LIKE FIRE
STATIONS. BUT WITHOUT A TOOL
LIKE THIS WE ARE LEFT MOSTLY
WITH IMPACT FEE. SO EVEN WITH
THE IMPACT FEES WE STILL FACE A
CRITICAL CHALLENGE. THAT WILL
GROW AS DEVELOPMENT WIDENS IN
THE FIRE DANGER INCREASES. BUT
WITHOUT IMPACT FEES WE HAVE NO
CHANCE OF MEETING THAT
CHALLENGE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- MISTER WELLS WILL
MOVE ON TO STEPS SANDERS
LANDSCAPE ARCHITECT OR PLANNER
FROM THE NORTH OF THE RIVER
RECREATION AND PARK DISTRICT
SOME AWFUL SORRY YES IT IS
THANK YOU AND GOOD MORNING- MY
I REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
LISTENING TO WHAT WE HAVE TO
SAY TODAY MY NAME IS STAFF
SANDERS I AM THE LANDSCAPE
ARCHITECT IN PARK PLANNER FOR
NORTH OF THE RIVER RECREATION
AND PARK DISTRICT. OVER LAND
ACT XIN PLANNING CONSTRUCTION
MAINTENANCE AND SAFETY FOR OUR
FOR OUR DISTRICT. NORTH OF THE
RIVER RECREATION PARK DISTRICT
IS- WITH A SPECIAL DISTRICT
THAT OVERSEES TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN SQUARE MILESOF
RECREATION AND PARKS SERVICES.
WE ARE A THIRD DEVELOPED OUT
WITH ABOUT A HUNDRED AND FORTY
THOUSAND RESIDENTS TWO THIRDS
OF OUR DISTRICT IS STILL
FARMLAND. WE ARE UNDER THE
JURISDICTION OF THREE LAND USE
AUTHORITIES WTHIN KERN COUNTY.
THEY OVERSEE THE ZONING AN
ORDINANCE WITHIN THE DISTRICT
WE DO NOT HAVE THAT POWER. THE
MODEL FOR THE DISTRICT IS JOIN
THE FUN AND LET ME TELL YOU
EVERY DAY IS REALLY FUN. I WANT
YOU TO THINK ABOUT YOUR
FAVORITE CHILDHOOD THREE A LOT
OF YOUR MEMORIES WILL PROBABLY
BE OUTDOORS LET ME TELL YOU
MINE. I GREW UP IN SOUTH
CENTRAL MINNESOTA I WAS BORN
AND RAISED THERE MY FAVORITE
CHILDHOOD MEMORY IS WHEN MY DAD
WHO IS ON THE VOLUNTEER FIRE
DEPARTMENT THANK YOU MISTER
WELLS FOR YOUR SERVICE. OF THEY
WOULD TAKE THE FIRE INS FLOOD
THE BASKETBALL COURT EVERY
SINGLE YEAR ONCE A WEEK AND WE
WOULD GO ICE SKATING ON IT IN
OUR LOCAL PARK. THAT IS WHAT I
REMEMBER DOING FOR MOST OF MY
LIFE. I WANT MY CHILDREN TO
HAVE WHAT I HAVE WHAT WE'VE ALL
HAD WITH THOSE MEMORIES ARE. SO
WHAT DO WE DO WITH OUR FEES WE
BUILD MEMORIES. BIRTHDAY
PARTIES BABY SHOWERS WE PROMOTE
HEALTH WELL BEING FAMILIES AND
BEING OUTDOORS PARKS TRULY DO
MAKE LIFE'S BACK. SOME FAMILIES
CANNOT AFFORD TO GO TO
DISNEYLAND BUT CAN'T GO TO A
PUBLIC PARK FOR LITTLE TO NO
COST. THAT'S OUR OUR
COMMUNITIES WE ARE CRITICAL P.
UP FOR INFRASTRUCTURE FOR A
RESIDENT. AND TELL. WE ARE
UNDER THE JURISDICTION OF THREE
LAND USE AUTHORITY SO I'M GOING
TO FOCUS ON KERN COUNTY IN
ITSELF. THE CURRENT RATE OF-
UNDER THE OR CURRENT ORDINANCE
WE ARE ALLOWED TO POINT FIVE
ACRES PER THOUSAND THAT IS
CURRENTLY UNDER IN WITHIN THE
QUEEN BEE ACT THE THREE TO FIVE
ACRES PER THOUSAND. SO WHEN WE
DO THAT AND WE ACT WE SET ASIDE
LAND A LOT OF IT IS- I IT IT'S-
HEATED. AND THEN WE GO INTO-
PURCHASE WHEN WE CAN AFFORD IT.
SO ON AN IMPACT FEE BASIS
CURRENT COUNTIES IS CURRENTLY
ONE THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY PER RESIDENTIAL UNIT.
THAT FEE HASN'T BEEN CHANGED
FOR OVER TEN YEARS IF YOU
COMPOUND THAT FEE WE GET
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED TWENTY
PERMITS PULLED WITHIN COUNTY
JURISDICTION EVERY SINGLE YEAR-
TOTALING ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY THOUSAND A TPICAL PARK
SAY BETWEEN TWELVE AND TWENTY
ACRES- WITH YOUR BASIC
PLAYGROUNDS- OPEN SPACES.
FIELDS IN WHICH COST ABOUT YES
NO DOLLARS WITH PREVAILING WAGE
RATES WHICH WE HAVE TO BE. THAT
PARK TO BUILD THAT PARK WOULD
TAKE APPROXIMATELY TWENTY SEVEN
AND A HALF YEARS TO ACQUIRE THE
FEES- TO BUILD THAT THAT'S TWO
LIFETIMES TO CHILDHOOD'S
LIFETIMES LOST OVER THAT. THAT
PERIOD OF TIME WE HAVE A
PARTICULAR PARK SITE THAT WAS
DEDICATED IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
FOUR THAT THE DISTRICT ACQUIRED
IN THAT LATE NINETEEN NINETIES.
IT IS- IT WAS A TOTAL OF THIRTY
ACRES ONLY ABOUT EIGHT ACRES OF
IT HAS BEEN DEVELOPED. IN THE
TWENTY ACRES STILL. WAITING TO
BE DEVELOPED WE DO HAVE
FINANCING TO BE ABLE TO ARE THE
FEES TO BE ABLE TO BE THAT YET
COMING. AT YOU WRAPPING IT SO.
TOOK A MILLION ANNUALLY THAT WE
COULD PUT INTO OUR PARKS ALL OF
THE PARKS THAT WE CURRENTLY
HAVE WHICH THEY ARE TWENTY
FOUR. ARE HAVE BEEN BUILT BY IN
A WAR WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
DEVELOPER BUILT PARKS. ARE
DISTRICT HAS ALSO NEVER
REQUIRED REQUESTED A BOND. SO
THESE IMPACT FEES QUIMBY FEES
THE PARK DEVELOPMENT FEES AND
GRANTS ARE THE ONLY REVENUE
THAT WE HAVE USED TO BUILD A-
STRUCTURE SINCE NINETEEN SIXTY
FIVE. WE GO TO BUILD A PART WE
HAVE TO PAY PREVAILING WAGE
RATES INCLUDING THE PERMITS AND
FEES WATER SEWER TRAFFIC ALL
THAT THAT THE NORMAL
CONSTRUCTION WOULD NORMALLY
COST. IN IN CLOSING OF ALL OF
THAT. I LOVE WHAT I DO OF I
CAN'T I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW MUCH
IT MEANS TO ME TO TAKE MY KIDS
TO ONE OF THE PARK SITES THAT I
HAVE HELPED DESIGN THAT I HAVE
HELPED BUILD IT IT THRILLS ME
TO HAVE MY SON ASKED ME MOM
WHEN ARE WE GOING TO GET A NEW
PARK SITE. CAN WE GO TEST NEW
PLAYGROUNDS THAT'S WHAT WE DO
WE ARE AN INTEGRAL PART OF WHAT
IS PART OF OUR COMMUNITIES AND
MOVING FROM MINNESOTA TO HEAR
THE BEST PLACE I FOUND IS IN
THE VALLEY BECAUSE OF THE
COMMITTEE. PEOPLE HOW MUCH CARE.
NINE RANCH WATER DISTRICT
WELCOME GOOD MORNING THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR HAVING ME HERE ON
THIS VERY VERY IMPORTANT TOPIC-
YES MY NAME IS TERRY I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
IRVINE RANCH WATER DISTRICT
WHICH I WILL REFER TO AS I ARE
W. D. MOVIE FOR IN ESSENCE THE
CFO- LITTLE BIT ABOUT MY W. E.
WE ARE AN INDEPENDENT SPECIAL.
SERVING CENTRAL. SIR HIGH
QUALITY CAN WATER. WASTEWATER
COLLECTION AND TREATMENT WE
HAVE GROUND BREAKING BREAKING
RECYCLED WATER PROGRAMS AND
ENVIRONMENTALLY SOUND URBAN
URBAN RUNOFF PROGRAMS. AND WE
DELIVER THOSE SERVICES TO
APPROXIMATELY FOUR HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THOUSAND RESIDENTS.
EVERYTHING WE CHARGE BOTH
CONNECTION FEES AND RATES ARE
BASED ON COST OF SERVICE THEY
HAVE TO BE BASED ON COST
SERVICE IN MY ROLE I OVERSEE
THE SETTING OF RATES AND
CHARGES INCLUDING CONNECTION
FEES. SO LET'S TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN IMPACT FEES AARON
CONNECTION FEES. WATER AND
WASTE WATER AGENCIES CHARGE
CONNECTION FEES THESE ARE VERY
DIFFERENT FROM IMPACT FEES.
IMPACT FEES ARE GENERALLY PAID
TO MITIGATE THE IMPACT OF
DEVELOPMENT THINGS SUCH AS
TRANSPORTATION COST. A
CONNECTION BE AS DIFFERENT AS I
SAT. CONNECTION FEE IS CHARGED
TO COVER THE COST DIRECTLY
ASSOCIATED WITH CONNECTING A
PARCEL PLAN. OF A DEVELOPMENT.
WATER AND WASTEWATER SYSTEM. IT
IS BASED ON THE COST OF CAPITAL
THE EXACT COST OF CAPITAL. EACH
PROPERTY PAYS FOR THE CAPITAL
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH BUILDING
THE WATER AND SEWER
INFRASTRUCTURE AS NEEDED TO
SERVE THAT PROPERTY AND THEY
ARE CHARGED A CONNECTION B. AS
THE TERM SCRIBES. WHEN THE
CONNECT TO THE SYSTEM NOT
BEFORE. AND I ARE W. D. THE
COST OF FUTURE INFRASTRUCTURE
IS SHARED EQUALLY BETWEEN THE
DEVELOPERS WHO PAYS FOR
CONNECTION FEES THAT'S HOW THEY
PAY FOR IT. AND THE PROPERTY
OWNER WHO PAYS FOR THROUGH
PROPERTY TAXES IT SPLIT FIFTY
FIFTY. COST THE CORRESPONDENCE
CORRESPOND WITH THE DEMANDED
INTENSITY BASED ON THE USE OF
THE PROPERTY SO FOR EXAMPLE
SINGLE FAMILY RESIDENCES WILL
PAY FOR THEIR EXPECTED DEMANDS
IT'S ALL BASED ON DEMANDS OF
THE SYSTEM. AND A COMMERCIAL
BUILDING EQUALLY WILL PAY BASED
ON BASED UPON THEIR EXPECTED
DEMANDS OF THE SYSTEM. SO LET'S
TALK ABOUT THE FACT THAT OUR
CONNECTION FEES ARE COST BASE
BECAUSE I'VE MENTIONED THAT
BEFORE. AND I ARE W. D. WE SAID
OKAY IN FEES TO ENSURE THE NEW
DEVELOPMENT PAYS FOR ITS FOR A
FAIR SHARE IT'S ALL ABOUT
EVERYBODY PAYING FOR THEIR FAIR
SHARE. THE I AM AND IT'S BASED
ON THE FAIR SHARE OF CAPITAL
NEEDED TO PROVIDE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BOTH WATER AND
WASTEWATER SERVICE JUST AS
PREVIOUS DEVELOPMENTS HAVE PAID
FOR THEIR FAIR SHARE WELL NOT
SUBSIDIZING. THE FUTURE
DEVELOPMENTS AND THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT. THE GOAL. IS THAT
ONE PROPERTY NOT SUBSIDIZING
ANOTHER SHARE OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE. NEEDED TO SERVE
THE COMMUNITY. EVERYONE PAYS
FOR WHAT THEY'RE DEVELOPMENT
PROPERTY NEEDS ARE AGAIN
EVERYONE IS PAID FOR THEIR FAIR
SHARE. WE LOOK AT CAPITAL COST
FOR BOTH LOCAL AND REGIONAL
FACILITIES NEEDED TO SERVE NEW
DEVELOPMENTS AND ALLOCATE COST
ACCORDINGLY BASED ON THE
RESPECTIVE SHARE. SO EXAMPLE
FOR A LOCAL LOW COST THOSE ARE
BASED ON THE LOCAL
INFRASTRUCTURE THERE. THIRTEEN
PARTICULAR TO THAT DEVELOPMENT
ORIGINAL COST WOULD BE A SEWER
TREATMENT PLANT A WATER
TREATMENT PLANT EVERYONE PAYS
FOR PROPORTIONAL SHARE OF THAT
NOT JUST THE LOCAL DEVELOPMENT.
I'M AT A HIGH LEVEL HERE SOME
OF THE EXAMPLES OF
INFRASTRUCTURE PAID FOR BY BY
CONNECTION FEES THINGS SUCH AS
WATER PIPES AND SEWER LINES
STORAGE TANKS PUMPING. PATIENTS
AM I AS I SAID REGIONAL COST
LIKE WATER TREATMENT SEWER
PLANTS SO LET'S ASSUME FOR A
SECOND THE CONNECTION FEES ARE
CAPPED A RESTRICTED IN SOME
SENSE WE SHOULD ONLY A COUPLE
RECOVER COST NO MORE NO LESS NO
WAY OUT AGAIN IT'S BASED ON
COST AND WE'RE INVESTOR OWNED
SERVICE YEAH WE'RE NOT INVESTOR
OWNED COMPANY YOU'RE NOT IN IT
TO MAKE PROFIT THIS THAT OUR
EXIT CUSTOMERS WOULD HAVE TO
MAKE UP FOR THE UN CAUGHT THE
AND COSTA DEL. AND THAT'S- MY
STEP. OUT BY AN- ON THAT'S
OFTEN USED AND I TALK ABOUT THE
FACT THAT EVERY PROPERTY PAYS
FOR NO MORE AND NO LESS THAN
THEIR FAIR SHARE OF
INFRASTRUCTURE SO WHAT IS BY IN
SO BY AN METHODOLOGY ALLOWS
AGENCIES TO PLAN FOR THE
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDED WITHIN
THE COMMUNITY AND COLLECT FROM
THE PREVIOUSLY UNPLANNED
DEVELOPMENT COST ATTRIBUTABLE
TO THE DEMANDS OF A PROJECTED
DEVELOPMENT WHEN THE WHEN THE
DEVELOPMENT TAKES PLACE. AND
THAT'S- WE BUY IN LAND
COMMUNITY DOES NOT PAY FOR
THEIR RESPECTIVE CHAIR OF THE
FACILITIES BY IN METHODOLOGY IS
UNIVERSALLY ACCEPTED WITHIN THE
WATER AND WASTEWATER INDUSTRIES
BECAUSE IT ALLOWS THE BEST
OPTION FOR BUILDING THE NEEDED
INFRASTRUCTURE OF ALLOCATING
THE COST ONLY WHEN THE PARCELS
CONNECT TO THE SYSTEM. WELL BY
IN THIS IMPORTANT CONNECTION
FEES MAY INCREASE OVER TIME
BECAUSE IT'S REGULATORY
COMPLIANCE FOR WATER AND
WASTEWATER INCREASES WE ON A
REGULATIONS CONTINUE COSTS
CONTINUE TO INCREASE. SO DOES
THE COST OF INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDED TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE
MEETING THOSE NEEDED
REQUIREMENTS AND I ARE W. D.
THE COST OF EXISTING
DEVELOPMENTS BORNE BY THOSE
CUSTOMERS. YOUR PROPERTY TAXES
AND THE COST OF THE NEW THE
CONNECTING PROP IS ARE BORN BY
THIS PROP THROUGH CONNECTION
FEES. I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND LIKE THE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK VERY MUCH MISS PERRY.
WILL MOVE ON TO MY GOOD FRIEND
MR DARYL HALL OF ALL SIX OF
DIRECTOR OF SOLANO COUNTY
TRADITION YOU FOR JOINING US.
ALSO DOCTOR SERGEANT FEET UNTIL.
I'M ACTUALLY TO TALK ABOUT
TRANSPORT. BT ALSO GIVE YOU A
LITTLE SMALL STORY ABOUT A
SUBURBAN KIND OF THIS GROWING.
ALSO WANTED TO KNOW SOMEONE
WILL GRAYSON OR THE MEMBER
COULD SEE BOTH OF YOU IN THE
REST THE REST COMMITTEE. AGAIN
I WANT TO THAT THE PANELS GOD
THINGS THE INVITATIONS FOR
IMPORTANT TOPIC. WELL THIS IS
ACTUALLY THREE PORTS STORAGE
FOR STORY FORCES A TALK ABOUT.
OUR COUNTY GROWS- AND HOW THEY
PROTECT OPENS THIS INSTANCE ON.
A GIVEN YOU A COPY THIS POST
COPULAR AND REPORT. OF CLARK
COUNTY. OF AN ORDER GROWTH
INITIATIVES THE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES TO HAVE URBAN
DEVELOPMENT CITIES AND JOBS IN
SAID THE SEVEN CITIES. OF THE
VOTERS AGREED WITHOUT THE
NINETEEN NINETY ONE WITHOUT AND
WE TO THE TO MAKE. SUCH REAL
THAT ARE LIKE IS MAKE SURE WE
PUT ARE OPEN SPACE FOR. X. A WE
TRY TO FOR HARD OR DEVELOP
INNER CITY. WHICH RESULTED AN
IT 6% OF OUR LAND BEING
AGRICULTURE OPEN SPACE WATER IS
ONLY 40% CITIES. 90%OF OUR
POPULATIONS AS ACTUAL SEVEN
CITIES SUCH. THING IS GOOD LET
PLAN PARK. ON OF WHICH GETS
THIS PART. OF WHICH IS WHAT'S
CALLED US OPEN FACILITY. SO IN
ORDER DO AS A COUNTY. SLOW CAN
WHICH WAS COUNTIES GROWING THEY
HAD A PER. COUNTY AND SERVICES
TO SOME THE CITY OF. EVER
GROWING. AND SO THE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS BACK
NINETEEN NINETY IDENTIFIED
CONCERNS A LOOK. WE CAN'T KEEP
UP WITH GROWTH IF HE CAN'T
PLANNER COUNTY FACILITIES
SUPPORT YOUR SERVICES. AND
DEVELOPMENT. AND SO. RESPONSE
THE CITY'S AGREED TO. COLLECT
FEES TO ALSO SUPPORT. THE CAT
THANKS TO A PUBLIC FACILITY FEE
PROCESS. WHICH STARTED ABOUT
NINETEEN NINETY TWO. AND
WITHOUT THE FUNDING SOURCE THE
COUNTY WOULD NOTBEEN ABLE TO
DO THAT TO THE FACILITIES. SO
THAT START IN NINETEEN NINETY
TWO IT'S BEEN UPDATED BUT EVERY
FIVE OR SIX YEARS ALL THE WAY
UP TO TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. OF
THE NEXT SLIDE SHOWS YOU SOME
FACILITIES IN A FEW MINUTES ON
A COUNTY. THE VERY GOOD LIBRARY
SYSTEM. GOOD COURT FACILITIES
JAIL FACILITIES. THAT'S BECAUSE
DIRECTLY THE PUBLIC FACILITY
FREE. I'M SORRY PAID FOR. I'M
TO CLICK THE BUTTON THIRTY OF.
THEY'RE YOUNG. HAVE TO WORRY
HERE THESE ARE ALL OF THE
COUNTIES BUT EFFECTIVELY BE
ABLE TO THE LAST TWENTY FIVE
YEARS IS THESE FLOWS ALL
EXISTING BEEN COULD KEPT UP
WITH GROWTH. THE PUBLIC
FACILITY FEE. HOW MUCH WOULD
TWO THINGS AT ONCE OF
COMPOUNDED SO. WHAT ALSO CURTIS
COURSE WITH TRANSPORTATION I
WANT TO KNOW SENATOR BILL IN
HIS LEADERSHIP AND SB ONE- WE
ALL SEE THE BENEFIT OF THAT BUT
WE ALSO HAVE GROWTH IMPACTS AND
TRANSPORTATION. SO IN NINE AND-
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN MY BOARD
OF DIRECTORS WHICH IS SEVEN
MERS APPROACH THE COUNTY ABOUT
INCLUDING TRANSPORTATION ABOUT
FACILITY BECAUSE WE HAD GROWTH
IMPACTS OF TRANSPORTATION- WE
UNFORTUNATELY ARE NOT A SELF OF
COUNTY WE'VE TRIED THREE TIMES.
THIS IS 6% NOT. TWO THIRDS. AND
SO WE HAVE CHALLENGES THAT SOME
OF THE SMALLER COUNTIES HAVE IS
HOW DO YOU STILL PROVIDE
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND SO
FORTUNATELY- THE COUNTY WAS
WILLING TO LISTEN TO OUR BOARD.
INCLUDE TRANSPORTATION INFANTS
AND SUBSEQUENT FOLLOW UP WHICH
WE CALL THE RITUAL TRANSFERS
IMPACT FEE. IT'S BASICALLY A
SUBSET OF THE PUB FACILITY IS
NOT A NEW FEE. A WE WERE
COGNIZANT THE DEVELOPMENT
COMMUNITY MET WITH THEM WE
TALKED ABOUT HIS FEET. THEY
WANT TO SEE THE FEW GROW BUT HE
SAID TRANSPORTATION'S IMPORTANT
THAT THE DEVELOPERS ACTUALLY
WANT TRANSPORTATION AT IT. MAKE
A PART OF FACILITY FEE. SO WILL
WE DID IS WE TOOK A SUBSET- AT
THE POLITICALLY FEES IS
BASICALLY ABOUT. A TEN THOUSAND
DRAWING EQUIPMENT FEES WHAT THE
CHARGES. IN THE TYPE OF
DEVELOP. A SUBSET IS FIFTEEN
HUNDRED. SHE'S FOR PETITIONS.
BACK TEEN. SO IF HE'S- BY THE
SEVEN CITIES AND GIVEN TO THE
COUNT. PERCENT GOES TO ASK.
WORK THE WAY IT WORKS IS IT'S
COOL PROCESS ALSO CITIES ARE
PART OF IT COUNT AS PART OF IT.
A 90% COMES BACK TO THE CITY
JURISDICTIONS BY WORKING GROUP
AREAS BE SOMEWHERE THE FEES
COLLECTED WITH DEVELOPING A
CURSE. SO WE DO HAVE AREAS
WHERE THERE'S MORE DEVELOPMENT
TO GET. A PERCENTAGE OF THE FEE
FOR THE RIVER ABOUT STRONG
RETURNS SOURCE. 5% ACTUALLY
GOES TO RESERVE BROWN'S IT'S
THIS IS BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN WE HAVE A LOT OF
REGION CHAT FACILITIES WANT TO
MAKE SURE TO SUPPORT THOSE
THAT'S PART OF OUR-
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND 5% GO TO THE COUNTY THIS
WAS ACTUALLY A CITY PROPOSAL.
RECOGNISING THE SOME OF THE
COUNTY ROADS ARE OUTSIDE THE
CITY. THE IMPACT BY THE
DEVELOPMENT OCCURS WITHIN CITY
SO. NINETY S. GEOGRAPHICAL 5%
TO TRANSIT. 5% COUNTY ROADS.
THESE ARE JUST ARE EXPECTED TO
KNOW THESE DISTRICTS OF THE
SHOW YOU THAT SOME OF THEM HAVE
BIGGER GROWTH AREAS LIKE THE
JOBS AND PARK WHERE THIS IS
WHERE. A LOT OF OUR HOUSING IS
OCCURRING WE GOT THOUSNDS OF
HOUSING. THAT'S OCCURRING
LONGER COMPLETE TREE CORTICAL
JOB SOME PARKWAY. THE FEARFUL
BACK LATER YOU CAN SEE ALMOST
HALF THE FEET. TO BE COLLECTED
THERE BECAUSE REDEVELOPMENT
CURSED. GOING BACK. FOR THE
QUARTER. FOR THE FOR THE- PICKS
UP WITH. SHOOTING AT WHICH TO
INVEST BUT IF YOU WILL. OTHER
AREAS ON A LITTLE BIT SLOWER SO
THEY OBVIOUSLY GET LESS FUNDING
BACK. IN TERMS OF SUCCESS OF
READY MADE. THE PO. FACILITIES
SUCCESS FROM THE CAL. PRISON OF
IN TERMS OF OUR IT DOESN'T
GENERATE A TON OF MONEY. BUT
IT'S LIKE A LOCAL MEASURE IT
GENERATES GENERATES MONEY THAT
STRATEGIC YOU CAN USE IT TO
START A PROJECT. FINISH A
PROJECT. LEVERAGE PROJECT. AND
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO DO THAT
WE'VE ACTUALLY COMPLETED IN SIX
YEARS SEVEN PROJECT PHASES
PRODUCTS. THE PRODUCTS ARE
REALLY UNDER WAY AND WE
LEVERAGE THIRTEEN. DOLLARS
WITHOUT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
IN OUR TO FUND SWITCHED ITS
SERVE THE PURPOSE OF.
LEVERAGING OTHER DOLLAR TO DO
TO INCREASE. THE INVESTMENT.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE
COUNTY UPDATED THE FEE. AT THE
END THERE WAS ALL REALLY STRONG
PUSH FOR THE ACTION CREASES
PERCENTAGE GOING TO
TRANSPORTATION TOWARDS. STILL A
TEN THOUSAND DRAWING AND
EQUIVALENT BUT NOW OF THE
FOURTH OF IT IS NOT. GOOD
TRANSPORTATION STARTING THIS
YEAR. WHAT WAS THE OTHER SEEN
ABOUT OF THAT AND THAT. WE GO.
BUT ONCE YOU'RE JUST SOME OF
THE PROJECTS- YOU CAN SEE WE'VE
NOTED THE CITIES OF THE RENT
BECAUSE I DON'T EXPECTED ALL
NOR CAN IT OUT WELL BUT EVERY
IT IS A BENEFIT WHETHER IT'S
BEEN A TREND TO CENTER VALLEJO
SPAN A ROADWAY PROJECT IN
FAIRFIELD- EVERY COMMUNITY HAS
A PRODUCT THAT THEY'RE WORKING
ON IT THE SHIP WITH THE COUNTY
WITH US TA. WORKING THAT THE
THREE PRODUCTS ARE CURRENTLY
ADVANCING ON MENTIONED JOB PARK
ONLY THAT. THERE'S A LOT OF
THIS IS ABOUT HOW IN FOSTER
HEALTH MORE HOUSING HOUSING
PRODUCTION. THAT JOB SOME PARK
RECORDER HAS LITERALLY
THOUSANDS OF UNITS AND BACKING
FAIRFIELD. WELCOMING ONLINE.
THAT NEED. HAPPEN DOES HAPPEN
PHASES MS. FEE IS ACTUALLY
PROVIDE INFRASTRUCTURE TO MAKE
THAT HOUSING BILLS ALSO BODIES
HAPPEN. ONE CASE STUDY OF. I
DON'T EXPECT IN A WERE REVERSED
AS WELL OFF A HIGHWAY TWELVE
LIMóN ISOLATED THANK YOU JOHN.
IN THE AREA IT IT'S ACTUALLY A
SAFETY PRODUCT ON HIGHWAY
TWELVE AND IT PRIDES ACCESS TO
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT IN THE REAR
OF HYSTERIA WHICH IS GROWING
QUITE A BIT AND IT WAS A- SMALL
PROJECT THAT THE CITY DIDN'T
HAVE THE ABILITY TO FUND AND TO
EASE THE IMPACT OF BARLEY CLEAR
IT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO CONVINCE
CALTRANS TO BUILD AS PART OF A
SAFETY PROJECTS WHAT YOU'RE
DOING IT FOR LACK ACTUALLY
LEVERAGING ABOUT SEVENTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN SHOPS AS
FOUR MILLION. TO LEVERAGING IS
ONLY NINE DOLLARS SHOP PROJECT
WHICH CALTRANS GONNA DO THIS
PROJECT AND THAT PROJECTWHICH
IS GONNA FIGHT SAFER ACCESS TO
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT RIVAS OF
THE TRIGGERING. SO OBVOUSLY
WE'RE GETTING SOME GOOD
LEVERAGING- SOMEWHERE TO LIKE.
THE LAST FIVE YEARS. WE'RE
RECOGNIZING THE INCREASING
PRESSURE INTO MASS DO HOUSING.
IT'S A WERE REVISITING THE
ARTIST FOR AROUND TO SAY CAN WE
FOSTER PROJECTS. THAT HELP
SUPPORT HOUSING PROJECTS NOT
JUST. HOUSING PROJECTS IN
GENERAL BUT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECTS. AND IN THE BAY AREA
WE HAVE A TERM CALLED PRIOR
DEVELOPMENT AREAS WHERE WE TRY
TO FOCUS AROUND. REGIONAL
TRANSIT CENTERS IN AREAS WERE
ONCE YOU HOUSING AND JOBS. SO
WE ARE TRYING TO FOCUS OUR
INVESTMENTS THERE- I JUST
TALKED WITH THE COUNTY CHAU
EXCEEDS YESTERDAY ABOUT. CAN WE
START STEERING WARM OF THE
MONEY TO THOSE PRODUCTS WERE WE
NOBLES. FOUR HOUSING PROJECTS
ARN'T I THINK. LIKE A LOT OF
YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT HOUSING.
MY AGENCY NO ACTUALLY DOES A RE
SCORE CARD. FOR COUNTY. I CAN
TELL YOU WHERE WERE OUT FOR
SEVEN CITIES IS. WERE MEETING
ARE. TARGETS WERE. MODERATE
LIKE EVERYBODY WAS TALKING WITH
FOR ABILITY HOW TO GET THE
AFFORDABLE PRODUCTS TO PENCIL
OUT. AND SO THAT'S WHERE OUR
FOCUS ON HIS CAN THE ARTIFICE
COULD BE IN THE FUTURE IS.
FOCUSING ON THOSE AREAS WHERE.
WE KNOW WE WANT TO. DEVELOPER
QUE CANCEL OUT. HE'S GOT
PARTNERSHIP. WE INVEST ENOUGH.
MAKE TO DIG INFRASTRUCTURE WORK.
SO HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS A COPY OF THE AND
REPORT FOR SIX YEARS THERE AND
I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU MISTER HEALTH I AM
NOW OPEN UP TO QUESTIONS AND SO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. THANK YOU- AND
THANK YOU OFFERED THE-
INTERESTING PRESENTATIONS- FOR
THE MOST PART ABOUT GREAT
PROJECTS IN EUROPE VARIOUS
COMMUNITIES SO- MY QUESTION IS
FOR MR ABRAMS- I DON'T THINK
YOU USED THE TERM BAD ACTOR
CITIES- IN YOUR PRESENTATION
BUT YOU DID AND FOR. THAT THERE
WERE SOME CITIES THAT ARE USING
IMPACT FEES TO STOP
DEVELOPMENT- CAN YOU PLEASE
ADVISE US. WHAT THE
CHARACTERISTICS. OF SUCH A- A
GALA. WHAT WHAT SHOULD WE WELL
I THINK THIS IS THE KIND OF
GETS TO THE TO THE HEART OF THE
MATTER HERE HOW WOULD WE AS
LEGISLATORS IDENTIFY THOUGH
CITIES SO WE CAN DO SOMETHING
ABOUT IT. THANK YOU THAT'S A
GOOD QUESTION I THINK IT'S A
LITTLE HARD BECAUSE IN SOME
CASES THOSE FEES ARE HIGH AND
BUT IT'S ALSO A HIGH GROWTH
CITY ONE OPTION TO DO THAT
WOULD BE LOOK LOOK AT CITIES
THERE REALLY AREN'T PRODUCING
MUCH HOUSING AND HAVE REALLY
HIGH IMPACT FEES- ANYTHING WE
ALREADY HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE
WITH THEIR WITH THE WITH THE
RENO AND THE ANNUAL PERCENTAGE
REPORTS. EVEN SB THIRTY FIVE
WHERE THERE'S CONSEQUENCES FOR
NOT MEETING AND ONE OPTION
WOULD BE TO LIMIT IMPACT FEES
THE CITY REALLY AREN'T AREN'T.
MARK PRODUCE. BUT STILL HAPPILY
HIGH FEES. CHIU JUST A REALLY
QUICK QUESTION ABOUT ME FOR
SURE HANDS AND BY THE WAY I
THINK MOST OF US HERE IN THE
DíAS WE'VE ALL BEEN A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND WE ALL ABSOLUTE
PRECIADO IN VALUE THE WORK
YOU'RE INDIVIDUAL AGENCIES ARE
DOING FROM FIRE FIGHTING TO
PARKS TO TRANSIT TO WATER UP MY
FIRST QUESTION JUST SORT OF A
SHOW OF HANDS. IN YOUR
RESPECTIVE REGIONS HOW MANY OF
YOU WORK WITH YOUR COUNTERPARTS
IN OTHER AREAS SO IF YOU'RE IN
FIRE FIGHTING YOU WORK WITH
PARKS FOLKS TRANSIT FOLKS WATER
TO TALK ABOUT COLLECTIVELY ALL
THE IMPACT FEES THAT YOUR
RESPECTIVE JURISDICTIONS ARE
ARE DOING OR DO YOU JUST FOCUS
ON THIS WITHIN YOUR WORLD I'M
JUST CURIOUS SHOW OF HANDS HOW
MANY YOU COORDINATE ACROSS.
OKAY AND THEN ALSO. BY CHAU
HANDS. I KNOW YOU DO INDIVIDUAL
NEXUS STUDIES TO FIGURE OUT-
THE COST FOR PARTICULAR IMPACT
FEES. DO ANY OF YOUR CITIES DO
AN ANALYSIS OF THE FEASIBILITY
OF NEW DEVELOPMENT BE ABLE TO
PAY THOSE FEES SO LOOKING
COLLECTIVELY ACROSS THE CITY.
WHAT THOSE FEES ARE AND
WHETHER. PROJECTS CAN PENCIL
OUT IN YOUR REGION'S. CARRIES
OF ANY- JURISDICTIONS TO THAT.
OKAY AND IF AND IF YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTS YOU WANT TO MAKE ON
EITHER OF THOSE QUESTIONS. LOVE
TO HEAR BUT HERE THAT. AND SAYS
CITIES DO THAT. CITIES DO NOT
BEND ON BOTH OF THOSE QUESTIONS
SO THERE'S DOESN'T SEEM TO BE A
LACK OF COORDINATION ACROSS.
SERVICES THEY'RE ALSO DOESN'T
SEEM TO BE THE ANALYSIS OF
WHETHER COLLECTIVELY FEES ARE-
ARE ARE STYMIED HOUSING
PRODUCTION SO JUST TRYING TO
GET A HANDLE OF. WHAT THAT'S
LIKE. WHAT TO MAKE WHAT I THINK
THE CONVERSATIONS MORE RECENT.
AT WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IT
WITHIN OUR COUNTY. BECAUSE
WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE THESE FOUR
WALLS OF PRODUCTS HOW PENCIL
OUT SO. WE FORMED A PARTNERSHIP
ACTION BOARD TAUGHT US TO A
WITH OR SEVEN CITIES IN THE
COUNTY. TRY TO ADVANCE PRODUCTS
SUCH POP WE ONLY FOUR MONTHS
OLD. AND WE'RE WORKING WITH-
BUT WOULD BANG UP IT GETS ISSUE
JUST SAYING AND SO WE'RE
WORKING SEVERAL DEVELOPERS
UPSET PROJECTS. AND WHERE OUR-
ALEX HAPPEN. OTHER DEVELOPED.
THE A SERVER FARM AND IT THANK
YOU KNOW COUNTY WELL WE'RE
PRICE THE BAY AREA BUT THE
DEVELOPMENT CAN VIEWS A AS
SINGLE FAMILY MARKET RATE
HOUSING COUNTY TRYING TO
ATTRACT OTHER DEVELOPERS A CAN
COME IN WITH THE RIGHT KIND OF
PRODUCT SO BUT I THINK IT'S-
STILL FAIRLY READ. THERE'S A
LOT OF INTEREST MOTHER SAYS TO
DO IT. ONE OF THINGS ALSO ABOUT
THAT IS- OBVIOUSLY IN MANY
JURISDICTIONS AFFORDABLE
HOUSING UNITS HAVE TO PAY
EXACTLY THE SAME IMPACT FEES AS
MARKET RATE UNITS EVEN THOUGH.
AFFORDABLE UNITS ARE NOT MAKING
ANY MONEY FOR THE DEVELOPERS
AND- AND- PROVIDING A
SIGNIFICANT COMMUNITY BENEFIT
CHOIRS SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC
INVESTMENT AND SO-
HYPOTHETICALLY THERE MAY BE A
BILL MOVING FORWARD- THAT I MAY
BE INVOLVED IN TO LOOK AT. CHIU
JUST LOVE TO CONTINUE ENGAGE IN
THAT CONVERSATION THE PERFECT
TIME. THE BILL. YEAH THANK YOU
FOR ALL YOUR WORK. OF IN TERMS
OF- HOUSING AT THE VERY LOW
INCOME LEVEL CAN YOU DESCRIBE
HOW YOU IS THERE ANY DETERMINE
AT THAT. FEES SHOULD BE. WAVE
REDUCE. FOR THOSE KINDS OF
REALLY. MAYBE FOR BELOW 50% OF
MEDIAN FAMILY INCOME HOUSING IN
YOUR COMMUNITIES AND- DO YOU
HAVE A FEE SYSTEM THAT'S BASED
ON THE VALUE OF THE OF THE
PROPERTY OR IS IT BASED ON A
PER PER UNIT LOOK UP COST. SO
MAYBE RESPOND TO THAT. I'M
STILL SO- YEAH I THINK IT'S A
BEST PRACTICE TO REDUCE FEES
FOR AFFORDABLE DEVELOPMENTS%
THEY THINK SOME CITIES HAVE
POLICIES ABOUT IT MOST DO IT IN
PRACTICE BECAUSE IF THE CITY IS
PUTTING IN MONEY ANY WAY YEAH.
IT'S JUST AN ACCOUNTING THING
FOR THEM TO REQUIRE THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPER.
TO PAY WHATEVER OTHER IMPACT
FEES BECAUSE THEN THE DEVELOPER
WILL NEED MORE MONEY TO MAKE
THEIR THEIR- DEVELOPMENT ITSELF
BUT I DO THINK THAT'S A GOOD. A
GOOD SPROUT. MOST DEE IS WILL
HAVE THEIR FEES JUST BASED ON
EITHER- PER UNIT OR- PER SQUARE
FOOT. SOMETIMES I'VE SEEN
CITIES TRYING TO- IT AS A
PERCENTAGE OF SALES PRICE BUT
IT'S AN ADMINISTRATIVELY
COMPLICATED BECAUSE YOU DON'T
KNOW THAT UNTIL THE END AND SO
MOST CITIES DON'T DON'T USE
THAT METHOD SO. PER UNIT. BY
DEFINITION DISCRIMINATES
AGAINST AFFORDABLE HOUSING
BECAUSE YOU CAN HAVE A VERY
HIGH COST HOUSING UNIT VERSUS A-
STUDIO APARTMENT OR A LOWER
COST UNIT. IT IS IT PER
PREVALENT AT THE USE A VALUE OR
A PER UNIT PROCESS TO DETERMINE
THE FEES. YEAH UNDERSCORE SAY
YES ARE YOU ARE YOU ASKING FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IMPACT FEES
YOU'RE PROBABLY ASKING ABOUT
IMPACT FEES GENERALLY. WELL I
SPECIFICALLY CONCERNED ABOUT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BUT I'M
ALSO- WANNA KNOW GENERALLY IS
THE PRACTICE TO USE THE VALUE
OR IS IT APPROVED- OUTDOORS IS
THE FEE BASED ON THE VALUE OF
THE PROPERTY. OR ISN'T BASED ON.
YEAH LIKE A BUILDING PERMIT IS
BASED ON VALUE RIGHT BUT YOU
GET A BUILDING PERMIT HOW MUCH
IS YOUR PROPERTY HOW MUCH IS
THE CONSTRUCTION COST YOU GET
IT YOU GIVE YOU PAY BUILDING
PERMIT. ON THE VALUE OF. OF THE
CONSTRUCTION. IN THEORY THE
IMPACT FEE IT SHOULD BE MORE
TIED TO THE IMPACT OF SO
THERE'S A GOOD LOGIC FOR
CHARGING MORE FOR LARGER
DEVELOPMENTS- AIMED AT WHAT
PERSON JUST CITIES I DON'T KNOW
THE PERCENTAGE I MEAN I COULD
LOOK FOR THE CITIES THAT I HAVE
DATA POOR BUT IT'S PRETTY. IT'S
BETWEEN THE TWO BOTH AND YOU
SEE BOTH THE- PRETTY COMMON BUT
THERE'S NO- HAVE HAVE
COMMUNITIES ESTABLISHED A-
DISCOUNTING OR- A PROCESS TO
WAIVE FEES FOR VERY LOW INCOME
HOUSING THAT THAT IS RELATIVELY
COMMON IT'S EITHER COMMON IN
PRACTICE THAT THEY DO IT OR
SOME OF THEM HAVE IT EXPLICIT
IN THE CODE. OKAY THANK YOU. IF
I MAY ADD TO THAT- WE HAD WITH
THE THREE DIFFERENT LAND USES
STORIES THAT WE'VE COME UPON
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS OBVIOUSLY
DISCUSSION THERE BUT THIS
HASN'T COME ACROSS THE BOARD WE
DID HAVE. SOME HOUSING THAT
CAME ACROSS WITHIN THE DISTRICT
IN THOSE PARK FEES WERE NOT
WAVE JUST BECAUSE OF THE IMPACT
OF DENSITY TO. RECREATION PARK
SERVICES SO IT IS A FOUR FEET
WITH LARGE DISTRICTS. OVER THE
QUEEN BEE FEE IS DONE THE VALUE
OF THE LEFT HAND AND THEN HOW
MANY PERSONS PER HOUSE THERE IS
A FOR WHAT THE DEAL. IS A
FORMULA THAT INTO PLAY. RIGHT
NOW HE SAID I. THREE PEOPLE PER
CALL SO WHEN YOU AT THOSE IS
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT WE'RE SO AND
WHEN YOU WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING-
PROBLEM THAT WE DO HAVE WE'RE
STILL TRYING TO INCREASE
DENSITY WITH THESE IT IT WITHIN
THESE NEIGHBORHOODS AND GET
PEOPLE INTO HOUSING BUT IT ALSO
DOES TAX SERVICES THAT WE HAVE.
TO USE  THREE POINT ONE. YOU
YOU YOU FOR ANY HOUSING PROJECT
ANY BROWSING CORRECT IF I BUILD
A BUNCH OF STUDIO UNITS FOR.
SOON TO BE HOMELESS EOPLE
WHICH MAYBE BE WATER AT THE
MOST TO PEOPLE IN THE STUDIO.
THAT WOULD PER PERSON BE A TAX
IT WOULD BE HIGHER PER PERSON
THAN THAN THE OTHERS IN THAT
WOULD ONLY BE RELEVANT FOR THE
QUEEN BEE AT THE PARK
DEVELOPMENT FEE EXCEPT HER
UNITS. NINE UNITS BASICS THE
QUEEN BEE ACT IS BASED ON THE
FORMULA WITHIN OUR
JURISDICTIONS OF THREE POINT
ONE. PER HOUSEHOLD AND TWO
POINT FIVE ACRES PER THOUSAND.
YES OKAY I THINK I THINK THIS
JUMBLE NEEDS TO BE KIND OF
LOOKED AT TERMS OF. DOES IT
DISCRIMINATE OR NOT
DISCRIMINATE ON. AFFORDABLE
HOUSING OR ESPECIALLY. UNITS
THERE ARE OR- SINGLE PERSON
ORIENTED NON FAMILY TYPE OF
UNITS YOU'RE TRYING TO BUILD TO
SAY THE- PROVIDE RESPONSE TO
THE GOVERNOR'S DEMAND THAT WE
ELIMINATE HOMELESS IN
CALIFORNIA FOR EXAMPLE. HELLO
THE UNITS ARE GONNA BE OCCUPIED
BY SINGLE PEOPLE. MAYBE TWO
PEOPLE WITH MOSTLY ONE PERSON
BUT THEY'RE CHARGED BASED ON.
THE STANDARD FEE WHICH IS SHOWS
THAT YOU HAVE THREE OR MORE
PEOPLE IN THE- SO I THINK I
THINK THAT TO BE LOOKED AT. SEC
SKINNER. THANK YOU AND-
APPRECIATE SENATOR BILLS-
QUESTIONS IN THE CLARIFICATION
AROUND WHETHER IT'S THE UNIT OR
THE NUMBER THE VALUE OF THE
UNIT OR THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
MIGHT OCCUPIED UNIT BECAUSE
CLEARLY THIS REALLY IMPACTS THE
ULTIMATE COST OF THE UNIT AND
THUS THE AFFORDABILITY OF IT.
AND THIS IS ONE OF THESE. WE'RE
IN A. WE JUST HAVE THESE KIND
OF PERVERSE. PROGRAMS IN IN A
FUNNY WAY IN THAT YES BECAUSE
OF PROP THIRTEEN AND OTHER
ISSUES WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
FUNDING COMING INTO OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO COVER. A LOT OF
THE BASIC SERVICES THAT ARE
RESIDENTS EXPECT IN YET WE ALSO
HAVE A- NEARLY CRITICAL HOUSING
SHORTAGE IN IT IS NOT ONLY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IT IS
HOUSING GENERAL AND WE HAVE OUT
MIGRATION NOW. IN THE BAY AREA
FOR SURE I HAVEN'T LOOKED QUITE
AT THE NUMBERS IN CASH LA AREA
BUT LA IS NOW. JUMP TO THE BAY
AREA IN TERMS THE- RISING COST
OF HOUSING WE WERE THE WORST
MEANING THE BAY AREA AND NOW
ELOISE JUMPED US SO IN THAT IN
THE OTHER IRONY OF THIS IS THAT
THE VERY PEOPLE WHO PROVIDE THE
SERVICES THAT WE ARE TRYING TO
FIND TO DO THESE IMPACT FEES
CANNOT LIVE. COMMUNITIES THAT
THEIR BODY THIS SERVICE SO OUR
TEACHERS PUBLIC KEY PERSONNEL
MANY OUR ANYWAY SO WE WERE JUST
IN THIS- CRAZY CRAZY SITUATION.
AND WHILE I APPRECIATE THE-
THEY NEED TO FIND THE SERVICES
I WONDER IF. OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WOULD BE WILLING TO
CONSIDER A MORATORIUM ON FEES
FOR A CERTAIN PERIOD OF TIME
FOR EXAMPLE FIVE YEARS- ON MY
BILL LAST YEAR WAS LOOK LOOKING
AT TRYING TO GIVE A GREEN LIGHT
TO THE HOUSING THAT ARE
JURISDICTIONS HAVE ALREADY SAID
YES TO SO IT'S ALREADY APPROVED
IMPLANTS DOESN'T EVEN NEED. YOU
KNOW EXTRA CHANGES IN ZONING
RULES OR OTHER RULES AND I
INCLUDED IN THAT AND WHAT'S FOR
ONLY A CERTAIN PERIOD OF TIME
FIRST TIME. TO DEAL WITH THIS
CRISIS AND I THINK NOT ONLY A
WERE MORE TOWARD ON JUST SO WE
COULD DEALS A LITTLE BIT WITH
THIS CRISIS AND COURSE THAT GOT
TAKEN OUT THE BILL. SO NOW THE
GREEN LIGHT BUT WE KNOW THAT
SOME PROJECTS ARE NOT MOVING
FORWARD JUST AS THE OF. SO HI
NOW. AT THE END. IT JUST
DOESN'T ALLOW FOR THE DEFENSE.
NO BUT BE ABLE. AFFORD THE HOW
ONCE COUPLE SO REGION IN THIS
REALLY TRICKY SO OUR VOTERS OF
COURSE WILL POTENTIALLY HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO YOU KNOW
HAVE JUST MADE TO PROP THIRTEEN
IF THEY SO CHOOSE IN NOVEMBER
THAT MAY CHANGE THE WORDING
PICTURE FOR OUR LOCAL SERVICES-
BUT I THINK OUR NEED TO ACT
AROUND THE ICING HOUSING CRISIS
IS NOW BUT I WONDER IF ANY. ONE
HAS COMMON EVEN. ATTEMPTS
CAPPER MORE TO ON THE CITY'S.
US BECAUSE FOR THE FIRE
DISTRICTS AND IN CONTRA CSTA
COUNTY THERE ARE TWO FIRE
DISTRICTS THAT ARE. OF A BASED
ON THE PROP THIRTEEN OUR WAY
UNDERFUNDED- THE AVERAGE RATE
OF THAT ONE PERSON THAT GOES TO
FIRING CONTRA COSTA COUNTY IS A
PROXIMITY ABOUT FOURTEEN CENTS
TO THE DOLLAR. AND I'VE TO
AGENCIES WHERE ONE IS SIX CENTS
ON SEVEN AND ONE OF THOSE
AREAS- PASSING UP PARTIAL TAX.
IS A VERY CONSERVATIVE HE'S
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY AND THEY'RE
VERY CONSERVATIVE OUT THERE BUT
HE IS WHERE WE'RE DRIVING AND
RIDING ON- ENGINES AT- YOU KNOW
WAY OVERDUE FOR EXCHANGE WITH
THE FIRE STATIONS THAT ARE
FIFTY SIX YEARS OLD JUST
THROUGHOUT. THE COSTA COUNTY SO.
NOT HAVE IT. THE FEES AND BEING
ABLE TO PASS ANY KIND OF
MEASURE TO- DIGITALFUNDING I
THINK A CAP ON THE FEES OR
WOULD PROBABLY HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT. DEPENDING
ON THE AGENCY. RIGHT NOW THOSE-
THE QUEEN BEE FEES THAT WE GET
IN AND THE PARK DEVELOPMENT
FEES FOR US ARE THE ONLY
REVENUE THAT WE HAVE OUTSIDE OF
GRANTS FOR PARK DEVELOPMENT AND
THAT'S NOT I MEAN IF THEY DON'T
TOUCH ON MAINTENANCE OR
ANYTHING SO THAT WOULD
COMPLETELY PUT A STOP. TO PARK
DEVELOPMENT. MY EXPERIENCE
WORKING WITH CITIES WHEN THEY
WANT TO INCREASE FEES IS THAT
THE DEVELOPERS THAT ARE REALLY
UPSET BY IT ARE THE ONES WHO
HAVE ALREADY PURCHASED THE LAND
BECAUSE INVEST. KING ABOUT
THEY'RE GOING TO BE THEY'RE
GONNA BE STOCK AND THEY HAVE NO
WAY. OF REDUCING OF THEIR LAN
ACOSTA USING THEIR OTHER COSTS
IF THEY HAVE AN UNEXPECTED
COST. THAT'S REALLY GOING TO
HURT THEM. BUT THE MOST PART
ASSUME THESE ARE OR HARDER. I
HAVEN'T SEEN A LOT OF DEVELOPER
OPPOSITION A LOT OF DEVELOPERS
COMING OUT I MEAN SOME. TALK TO
IT THEY'RE JUST THEY JUST
SPECIFICALLY IT JUST THE LAN
PRICE AND NOT. IS OF ALL OF THE
ISSUES WITH- ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW AND UP THE BUILDING CODE
AND RESTRICTIVE ZONE AND TOO
MANY THINGS AND LIKE AFTER
HOURS IN ISSUE. FOR MOST
OPPOSITE THAT I'VE SEEN IS.
IT'S BUT IT'S JUST NOT IT'S
JUST PRIOR. DRAWS. JUST ALONG
THOSE LINES AND THANK YOU
SENATOR SKINNER AND MR ABRAMS-
FOR THAT TO TRY TO UNDERSTAND
REALLY WHAT ROLE DO FEES PLAY
IN HURTING THE PRODUCTION OF
HOUSING. I MEAN I THAT'S THE
SORT OF FOR ME A BOTTOM LINE
QUESTION IS IT DEPENDS ON HE
REGION IN THE STATE IS THAT
ACROSS THE BOARD I MEAN BECAUSE
WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO GET AT
THIS AND I DON'T WANT IT TO BE.
A FALSE SORT OF CHOICE HERE OF
LOOK AT ALL THE SERVICES ALL
THE THINGS THAT ARE DONE ON AND
HOW AND THEY RELY ON THESE FEES
AND WE'RE TRYING TO GET AT IT
IS THIS A SIGNIFICANT ISSUE.
THAT IMPACTS THE PRODUCTION OF
HOUSING. FOR ME THAT'S A BIG
QUESTION. SO I DON'T WANT TO I
DON'T WANT TO PUT THE SQUEEZE
ON. THE CITIES AND THE AREAS
THAT ARE DOING THAT LIVE NEED
THESE FEET. WEATHER'S FOR FIRE
SERVICES ARE. ARE ARTS WHAT
WHATEVER HOWEVER THEY BEING
USED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. I WANT
TO PUT THE SQUEEZE ON THEM IF
IN FACT IT'S NOT GOING TO HELP
US. ON THE ISSUE- PRODUCING
HOUSING WHETHER IT'S MARKET AND
OR AFFORDABLE BUT ESPECIALLY
AFFORDABLE SO ANYBODY'S. THE
JOB ANYTHING TURNER CENTER IS
GOING TO BE THE BEST PLACE TO
TALK TO BECAUSE THEY'VE DONE
THE MOST COMPREHENSIVE ANALYSIS
TO AID BUT I WOULD JUST FROM MY
EXPERIENCE IT'S JUST A HANDFUL
OF CITY IS A I DON'T WANT TO BE
SORT OF ITS PROPOSED GROWTH
CITIES THAT WHAT THAT HAVE
REALLY HIGH FEES DO YOU THINK
IT'S A PROBLEM DO YOU THINK THE
STATE HAS STRONG ENCOURAGED
HOUSING I. WANTED WILL CITIES
THOUGH ENTIRE CITY STILL HAVE
IS IMPACT FEES BUT- IN I THINK.
IN SAN MATEO COUNTY WHERE I DO
A LOT OF WORK I WOULD SAY
THERE'S ONE CITY THAT I THINK
IS A PARTICULAR CONCERN. BUT
IT'S ONE OF TWENTY ONE SO I
THINK IT'S NOT THE CAN IT'S
LIKE IN THE LIST OF CONCERNS
WOULD BE GREAT IF THERE'S A WAY
TO TAILOR IT TO THOSE THOSE
MOST DIFFICULT PROBLEMS. LISTA
EARNS A JUST. ME BALANCING OUT
ALL THE ESSENTIAL SERVICES. I
THINK. THAT IT'S A IT'S A FAIR
BALANCE WHERE WE'RE AT NOW.
SURE I'M AYE AYE AYE TENDER
CONCUR I THINK MOST OF THE
CITY'S WANT TO BUILD A HOUSING.
THE QUESTION IS HOW DO WE HELP
THEM DO IT I DON'T THINK THE
FEES BY THEMSELVES OF THE
PROBLEM I THINK I SHOULD REVIEW
VISIT THEIR FEES AND TRY TO
STRUCTURE PHASES OF THINGS ARE
BILLS WOULD INTO. BUT I THINK
WITH THE STATE'S DOING WITH SB
TO FUND FUTURE GROWTH COUNCIL
FUNDS MAKE FUNDS. AVAILABLE SO
WE HAVE A PROJECT. THE
CHALLENGES WE ALWAYS. PROGRAM
GRANTS ARE CERTAINLY FOR
DEVELOPER IF YOU WANT TO. GET
THE DEVELOPER JUST COMMIT THEY
KNOW THE STATE FUNDS AVAILABLE
FOR SURE IF THEY COMMIT THE
PROJECT WALGREENS HE COMMITS
THE WHATEVER THE FEE SCHEDULE
IS AND THE AND THE STATE FUNDS
ARE AVAILABLE FOR SURE IS FOR
CERTAIN THEN AND YOU'RE GONNA
GET PROJECTS AND SEVERAL
PRODUCTS ARE CUED UP. WE'RE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
GROUNDS TO GO FOR A MINUTE.
ADAM I DO A HANG IN THERE ARE
NOT. THAT'S LITERALLY THE WERE
OUT TO RIGHT NOW WE'VE GOT
BROAD. WE KNOW WHAT GAP ISN'T
REALLY GAP FUNDING. THE ONE FOR
HOUSING PROJECTS IN THE WRITER
YOU GOT ADDRESS THE GAP
FUNDING. AND IT COULD SOME OF
THAT BE FEE REDUCTIONS IT
COULD. BUT THEN YOU HEAR ALL
THE REASONS WHY GOOD CAREFUL
SHE REDUCE TOO MUCH TO YOUR
SERVICES AND SO. ABOUT ACT.
RIGHT IN THERE OTHER. YES THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR I JUST HAVE A
QUESTION FOR CHERYL KEY JUST TO.
TELL ME A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT- AND IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING IN YOUR UP OF.
THE OF WATER SUPPLIER OR WATER
WATER AND SEWER WATER MISERS
PRIMARILY WHAT DO YOU GET YOUR
WATER FROM CNSERVE THEM SO
WELL WE HAVE MULTIPLE SOURCES
OF WATER WE GET. OUR WATER
COMES FROM GROUND WATER WELLS.
COMES FROM- IS IMPORTED WATER
AS WELL AND ABOUT 25% COMES
FROM RECYCLED WATER. OKAY AND-
THE OTHER QUESTION IS HAVE YOU
SEEN AN INCREASE OVER THEYEARS
I MEAN IT INTERWEAVING FEES IT
CHRIS RIGHT ELECTION ONCE YES.
YOU KNOW WE HAVE IT'S A GREAT
QUESTION AND AGAIN IT'S ALL
RELATED TO THE COST TO CAPITAL
SO THE COST TO SUPPLY IN FIRST
TO GET THE WILL. AND THE SEWER
SERVICES TO A NEW DEVELOPMENT.
AND WHAT WE DO- INITIALLY BE
EAGLE ON PROJECT FEATURED. AND
WE BASED OUR K. R. CONNECTION
FEES ON THAT BACK TO THE BOARD
OF DIRECTORS EVERY SINGLE YEAR
YEAH SOMETIMES CREE SOMETIMES
THEY THEY DECREASE BASED ON X.
DID PROJECTED YEAH AND THEN
THOSE DEVELOPER PAY THE
CONNECTION FEES AS THE ACTUALLY
CONNECT SEWER SERVICE FOR WATER
SERVICE. NOT PAY. QUE CONNECT.
IT DOES THANK YOU VERY WELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME IN YOUR
COMING TO EDGE ALL US UP HERE
SOME OF THE AND THEN WE'LL MOVE
OVER TO SENATOR WIENER. THANK
YOU SO OUR NEXT PANEL- WHICH IS
IN TOTAL LOCAL GOVERNMENT
IMPACT FEES GOOD PRACTICES AND
INNOVATIONS SO I WILL HAVE
THREE- WITNESSES. SO CALLED NOW
ONE PER AS TO SEE IF SYSTEM
COUNTY EXECUTIVE IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY- DAVID ARE GOING WHOSE
INSISTS CITY MATTER- IN SANTA
ROSA. AND TOM PAY SUPPLYING
DIRECTOR FOR THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO AND EACH WILL HAVE
FIVE MINUTES OUT THAT THE-
THIRTY. GO AND WHICHEVER ORDER
YOU LIKE. THE MORNING A CHAIR A
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- I'M ONE PER
AS- WITH THE COUNTY RIVERSIDE
OVERSEE THE TRANSPORTATION I
MANAGEMENT- AGENCY FOR THE
COUNTY. ALSO THAT OVERSEES OUR
GROWTH IN THE UNINCORPORATED
AREAS- JUST A FEW THINGS TO
KIND OF HELP SET THE STAGE FOR
RIVERSIDE COUNTY AS YOU MAY BE
AWARE WHERE THE FOURTH LARGEST
COUNTY BY SIZE AND POPULATION
IN THE STATE. WHERE THE TENTH-
MOST POPULOUS IN THE COUNTRY
AND THAT HAS BEEN OVER THE
COURSE OF THE LAST TWENTY AS WE
HAVE SEEN IN A PRESIDENT A
GROWTH IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY SO
WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO TRY TO DO
TODAY. PERSPECTIVE AS IT COUNTY
THAT HAVE GROWN WE'VE DONE IT.
IS TO HAVE BOTH. BUT IN A
POSITIVE WAY. SO THE COUNTY ACT
GIVEN- IT'LL BUT HOW WE GOT
HERE WE'VE BEEN LOOKING REALLY
FOR THE PAST TWENTY YEARS AS AS
HOW WE'RE GOING TO GROW BECAUSE
WE'VE HAD THE LAND I SHOULD
MENTION THE SEVENTY THREE
CORPORATE MILES OF THE SITE OF
THE COUNTY OVERALL SO THAT'S
ABOUT THE SIZE OF THE NEW
JERSEY TO KIND OF GIVE YOU A
CHECK. THE GEOGRAPHY TRYING TO
COVER. OUR POPULATION THE
CORPORATE. ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE BUT IT IS
SPREAD OUT OVER EIGHTY PLUS
DIFFERENT ON CORPORATE A
COMMUNITY THAT WE DON'T HAVE
CONTIGUOUS LAND MASSES. IN THE
IN A CORPORATE ACCOUNT THAT WE
SEE IN OUR CITIES. WHICH POSES
A CHALLENGE AS FAR AS
INFRASTRUCTURE- SO LOOKING
AHEAD THE CASE YEAH NUMBER OF
YEARS AGO IMPLEMENTED A NUMBER
OF PROGRAMS TO PLAN FOR THIS
GROWTH WE HAD. WE HAVE TO WE
CALL TOM PHùTRANSPORTATION
FOR MEDICATION FEES THAT APPLY.
NOT JUST TO THE COUNTIES BUT TO
OUR TWENTY CITY COUNTY
UNIFORMLY. AND WE HAVE A
PROGRAM. IN WEST DOWN NOT IN
THE- ALLEY. THE ABOUT IT I AM
BACK IN MAY. NINE WITH THE
FIRST OF IT. COUNTRY IT WAS A
FOR TIME THERE WAS A- REGIONAL
FREE PER AND IT WAS IT WAS
ADOPTED AND PARCEL OF OUR SALES
TAX MEASURES ARE SO WHERE SELF
ALL COUNTY- SO PART OF THE
DISCUSSION AT THE TIME WITH THE
VOTERS WAS. AND IN ORDER TO
ENACT THE SALES TAX OF THERE
WERE ALSO BE VEHICLES AS PART
OF THAT TO BE A- PLAN FOR
GROWTH. COACHELLA BEYOND TIME
FOR BI PART OF THAT- AND THEN
SOON THEREAFTER ON SHOW YOU
MORE IN A MINUTE HERE WESTERN
COUNTY FOLLOW ALONG WITH OUR
PROGRAM. IN THIS LETTER OCCUR
HELLO MY ONLY. AND TO. YOU KNOW.
PETITION WILL HAVE AT THE
COUNTY OR AND IN INDIVIDUAL
CITY LOVE WE MIGHT OR ON THE
IMPACT FEE PRO TO COVER OTHER
THINGS UCH AS PARKS- PUBLIC
FACILITIES THAT INCLUDE FIRE
AND POLICE FACILITIES- AND
THOSE TYPES OF OTHER SERVICES
THAT ARE THAT ARE NEEDED BUT
AGAIN I DO WANT TO MENTION THAT
THE FOCUS IS. BUILDING NEW.
SYSTEM FIND ON OPERATIONS THEY
ARE VERY CLEARLY IMPACT FEES
THAT MEET ALL THE NEXUS
REQUIREMENTS- SOFOR US IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY IT'S REALLY
BAD AND PART AND PARCEL THAT
THEY'VE BEEN A CAN. READ OR NOT
AN IMPEDIMENT TO OUR GROWTH WE
WOULD NOT. BE HERE TODAY- WITH
THE POPULATION THAT WE HAVE
WITHOUT THE FEE PROGRAMS IN
PLACE THAT ALLOWED US TO PUT.
SECOND STRUCTURE. AND TO BE TO
MITIGATE OUR GROWTH AS WE GO
ALONG YOU SEE THERE BEFORE YOU.
LITTLE BIT OF A SLOW JOHN CAN
HAVE HISTORICALLY SO WE'VE
ADDED A BOTTOM MILLION
RESIDENTS- ABOUT A 60% GROWTH
RATE OVER THE LAST TWENTY YEARS
NOW THINK ABOUT THE RECESSION
AND THE IMPACT THE REPRESSION
EVEN FAT FACTOR AND WE'RE STILL
AVERAGING AROUND 3% GROWTH A
YEAR IN THE CAT. AND WHAT TRY
TO HIGHLIGHT IS AS THESE
PROGRAMS HAVE COME INTO PLACE.
YOU ARE SEEING A CONTINUED
GROWTH AND THE PROGRAMS ARE
HELPING US PROVIDE THE
MITIGATION AND INFRASTRUCTURE
PROVIDE THAT GROWTH THEY'RE NOT
A BREAK THERE ARE A WAY FOR US
TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE THE BASIC
INFRASTRUCTURE WHETHER IT'S
ROADS. OTHER FACILITIES THAT
YOU NEED TO HAVE HOUSING. AND
THE REASON FOR THAT AND WHY THE
REGIONAL MODEL HAS BEEN
SUCCESSFUL FOR US IS THAT THEY
PROVIDE A WAY FOR US TO. SHARE
OUR COST PROPORTIONALLY. VERY
DIFFICULT ESPECIALLY WHERE YOU
HAVE AREAS THAT ARE SEPARATED
BY GEOGRAPHY TO BE THE FIRST
BUILDER INTO AN AREA YOU HAVING
A PROHIBITIVE COST TO TRY TO
CONNECT THAT INFRASTRUCTURE. BY
BEING PART OF A REGIONAL
PROGRAM IF YOU AN AVENUE. TO
EITHER PUT IN THE INSTRUCTION
THEN BE REIMBURSED OR FINANCE
THE COST THROUGH. THROUGH THE
BOND MEASURES WHAT HAVE YOU
OVER A WIDER POOL OR BILL WOULD
BE ABLE TO KIND OF GO THROUGH
THE INSURMOUNTABLE FIRST COSTS
THAT WE CAN SEE AN ERROR THIS.
ONE SPEC AT REALLY HASN'T. SO
FAR BUT I WANNA I WANNA MAKE
SURE YOU COMMITTEES ARE AWARE
OF AS WE ALSO USE THESE
PROGRAMS AS A WAY TO PROVIDE
CUMULATIVE MITIGATION THERE ARE
UNDER SEAQUEST S CALIFORNIA
BERMAN QUALITY ACT RECALL AS US
TO LOOK AT NOT JUST DIRECT
IMPACTS PROJECTS BUT WHAT OF IT
SOMEHOW PROJECTS FIT IN WITH
OTHERS THAT ARE APPROVED AROUND.
AND THIS IS A OF TO SEE HOW WE
DEAL WITH THE CHALLENGES OF
COMMITTED MITIGATION. WE HAVE
ALSO USES PROGRAMS VERY
SUCCESSFULLY TO MATCH OTHER
DOLLARS WITH ITS FEDERAL OR
STATE DOLLARS AS WELL. AND
WE'RE SO- USE THAT THE BENEFITS
OF THESE PROGRAMS FOR EXAMPLE-
WE HAVE A AN OPEN SPACE. WE
HAVE TO OPEN SPACE PROGRAMS AND
WE'LL TALK MORE ABOUT THEM IN A
MINUTE THAT ALLOW US TO SET
ASIDE OPEN SPACE MITIGATE
IMPACTS ON THE ENVIRONMENT. AND
PROTECT THE ENVIRONMENT AS WE
GROW AND WE USE THOSE TO ALSO
HELP US IN A IN A CHEAP OTHER
PERMITS THAT ARE NEEDED AND
FEDERAL LEVEL WE ARE. WE ARE
FIVE MINUTES SO IF YOU COULD-
WRAP UP IF YOU HAVE ANOTHER
POINT MAKE A FINE BUT- BOB. SO
JUST OF A FIFTH THAT THEY WANT
TO HIRE IS WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
INVEST OVER A- BILLION DOLLARS-
AND BE ABLE TO RAISE THOSE
FUNDS- WE'VE GOT- BEEN ABLE TO
PRESERVE ACRES AS WE GO ALONG.
BEEN ABLE TO SET ASIDE THE
ACRES. TO PROTECT OUR
ENVIRONMENT AS WE GO ALONG WITH
OUR GIRLS GROWTH AS WELL- AND
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
LATER IF I COULD PERHAPS CLOSE
ON THE SLIDE BECAUSE THERE'S
BEEN SOME DISCUSSION OR- TO.
THE AND HOW THEY FACTORED IN
THE- AND THIS IS. A AND- OF
SHOWING. IN CERTAIN CASES ARE
ABOUT A THIRD OF THE COST
COMPARED TO OTHER FEES THAT WE
SEE APPLYING AS WELL TO ACOSTA
DEVELOPMENT. GREAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. THIS WHICH IS A WELL
THANK YOU- IT THANK YOU. SURE
WINNER CHAIRMAN WEAR AND TEAR
AGO CARE CURRY FOR BEING HERE
IT'S AN HONOR TO BE SPEAKING TO
YOU YOU ALL HAVE BEEN VERY BOLD
AND I KNOW SOMETIMES I'M
POPULAR WITH THE DECISIONS YOU
MAKE ANY KIND OF DRESSES CRISIS.
THE POP UP AS WELL JUDGE AT.
PRESENTOTHER IDEAS OUT THERE
THAT WERE. CHOI OUT- I'M
FORTUNATE THAT WE DO HAVE A
FULL COUNCIL- THAT'S FULL
UNANIMOUS CITY COUNCIL THAT-
UNDERSTANDS OUR HOUSING CRISIS.
HAVE TO ADDRESS IS WE HAVE TO
TRY SOMETHING DIFFERENT WE CAN
JUST KEEP DOING THE SAME. THING
SO WE KNOW THAT THAT. IS
AFFECTING OUR- ABILITY TO
ADDRESS OUR HOME THE SITUATION
ARE BECOMING DEVELOPMENT
ATTRACTING BUSINESSES
RETAINING. THIS IS IN OUR
COMMUNITY- OUR WORK FORCE
HOUSING EVERYTHING HINGES ON
HOUSING- EVEN OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE THE TABLE AND-
REDUCING FEAR. AND ADDRESSES
ISSUE WITH US HELLO. I JUST
WANNA BE REAL COULD. FEES ARE
ONE THING BUT IT'S A MULTITUDE
THINGS WE HAVE TO BE DOING SO
THE PAST YOU. AND A HALF. SO
HIS. THE YOU WERE THERE MAP AND
IS A LOT OF THESE. DESIGNER
VIEWING PERMIT SO THOSE ARE IS
MUST RIGHT IF YOU DOWN ON OR
TRY TO PROMOTE MULTI HOUSING
YOUR TRANSIT WEEVIL IN AND FEES
FOR A WE I YOU KNOW WE'VE THAT
THE- AS WIENER HAS. LAST YEAR I
REDUCE BECAUSE YOUR HOUSE
REQUIREMENTS THERE'S MORE USED
TO BE BUILT RATHER THAN JUST A
FEW THAT PAID TAKES UP ONE TIME
GENERALLY HAPPENS YOU PUT.
WOULD BE JUST AS PLANNED
ADDRESS IT WOULD TAKE CARE THAT
REQUIREMENTS THE VEHICLE MOUSE.
LIMIT ALL REQUIREMENTS AND MEET
OUR HIGH CAPS TO MOVE TO FOR.
EACH IS MARKED THIRTY TO. THE
TORQUE ON TAP. THIS FOR IN
WOMAN REDUCE TAKE AN EIGHTEEN
MONTHDOWN SIX MONTH WE DID A
HUNDRED INTENSELY BONE ARE DOWN
TO PUSH DILEMMA DOWNTOWN WE
CREATED A RENEWAL OPPOSED JUST
JP WITH THE K. TO TRY TO
REVENUE OF AND MONEY TO OUR
REGION THE BILL HOUSING I WE'RE
ACTUALLY WORKING ON TAX
ENHANCING ENOUGH. DE WITH THE
COUNTY TO TRY. PRINCIPLE GONNA
REDUCE THESE ARE. THE DISH
THROUGH ON TAX FINANCE ANOTHER
IS. A AND THEN WE HAVE AN- ON
THEN ULTIMATELY OUR FEET FEE
SCHEDULE SO YOU'VE HEARD A LOT
ABOUT FEES IMPACT FEES AND WHAT
THEY DO AND I AGREE ONE. WHOLE
HEARTEDLY ON MY WORK FOR CITIES
OF FEES CRITICAL FOR ALL THE
DIFFERENT THINGS THAT YOU'VE
HEARD ABOUT- BUT THERE ARE
TREAT WASTE REDRESSING I'M SO
WHAT. DID PETER HURLS AT. FOOT
PER UNIT WE LOOKED AT. CAPS WE
WERE AT PHOEBE. WITH PAYMENT
AND WE'VE WE CAME UP WITH A OF
A POLICY TO. TRY AT ALL SO WHAT
WE THREE HAVING A TABLE WE PUT
THIS POLICY AFFECTS VIA
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT FOR CITY
COUNCIL TO DO IT. A TYPICAL
IMPACT FEVER HIGH IT DOES HE
REALLY BUILT ON UNIT IN OUR
DOWNTOWN IS ABOUT THIRTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A DOOR. AND
IT'S BROKEN DOWN IN THIS WAY.
SO WE TOOK A LOOK AT EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF THESE FEES AND
SAID HOW CAN WE ADDRESS SOME
HOW CAN WE DO A- ALL THE-
THINGS YOU. ARE TO ME. TAKE A-
REPROACH TO IT. WATER
WASTEWATER. ARE PATIENTS TO THE-
WITH US. WITH PROP TWO EIGHTEEN
SO WHAT WE DO. IS EXCRETED PAIN
PLAN. FOR YEAR PAYMENT. OR MOVE
THAT PAYMENT OF THAT FEE TO SIX
MONTHS ARE PERMANENT FINANCING.
GET IT OUT OF THE APPLE. THE
STAFF. TO TRY TO HELP THE COST
OF THE CONSTRUCTION MOVE. MOVE
THOSE FEES. TO WEAR MAKE SENSE
WHEN THERE'S REVENUE. CREATED
HOUSING OKAY. THE FIRE FOR A
HOUSING THAT GOES AWAY IF WE
RATHER SEE THOSE UNITS BE
BUILT. AND YOUR FEET THIS CALL
THE- MINUTE. THAT SINCE. AFTER
JUST LET. ME KNOW TOP. THE
BASICALLY THE- FACILITIES BE
PARK IN FACT THE- AND SCHOOL
DISTRICT FEES. IF YOU'RE DE. WE
IF YOU. THREE STE. RECAPPING
THE FEES OF THREE STORIES YOU
PAY FULL FEES TO EVERY FOR YOU
AT ABOVE THAT. IN THE FEE.
THERE'S ACTUALLY EVERY FOR YOU
AT AT THE DOLLAR PER UNIT
DROPS. SO WE AS A CITY GET THE
DENSITY OF ONE. WE ALSO GET THE
BASE. FEES THAT I CAN AND
SUPPORT THE PARKS THAT WE WANT
TO SEE. IF WE NEED. IN CHANGING
THE- LOOK AT PARKS NOT BUILDING
A SOCCER FIELD WITH.
PLAYGROUNDS BUT WE'RE LOOKING
AT MORE URBAN PARKS AND HOW DO
WE BILL GATHERING SPOTS IN
YOUR- FUNDING A DIFFERENT. WAY
THAN WE HAVE PASSED. THIS IS AN
EXAMPLE OF OUR FEE STRUCTURE
CURRENTLY THE ONE ON THE LEFT
IS OUR STANDARD IMPACT FEES- SO
TYPICAL FIFTY FOUR PARK THE FF.
A SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
AFFORDABLE IN FEES ABOUT POINT
SIX MILLION DOLLARS FOR SEVEN
STORY NINETY SIX UNIT. PROJECT
IN OUR DOWNTOWN. BUT WE DID IS.
THE HEIGHT IS THE INCENTIVE- IN
IN OUR DOWNTOWN BASS HE SAID.
RECAPPING THE STORIES- CAPPING
FEES AT THREE STORIES WERE
STILL GENERATING A DISH SET
BASELINE FEES THAT WE CAN PUT
BACK INTO THE SYSTEM. WE ALSO-
DEFERRED THE SURFACE FOR SIX
MONTHS. AND WE DID A COMIC
HOUSES ON THAT SHOW THAT'S
ABOUT SIX. DOLLARS A UNIT IN
SUCH THIGS AND BY DIFFERING
THOSE FEET. I'M FOR THE UPPER.
TO THAT DROPS THE PRICE TO
ABOUT EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS OF IS IT WHICH WERE
COLLECTING FOR TO TRY TO
SUPPORT THIS- URBAN. ELEMENTS
WHEN I LOOK AT. AND IF THIS THE
FULLY MARGAERY PROP IF YOU ALL
THE WAY TO THE RIGHT. SIDE IF
YOU DO OF ONE AYE. AFFORDABLE
SIMPLE PLEASURE POLICY WE DROP
THOSE USED MORE WITH. TO A
PERSON FOOT APPROACH. A FOR THE
REST OF THE IT WAS TRUE WHICH-
WAS. ANY AND THAT'S- BY THIS
ACCOUNT. HOW DO WE- THE TYPE
PRODUCT WE WANT TO SEE OUR.
TESTING IT OUT GET EVERYTHING
WHICH WERE THROWN IT AT THAT
THE WINDOW. SEE IF IT WORKS
SEEING WHAT STATE. SEEN PEOPLE
PICK UP ON AND THEN FINE TUNING
AS NEEDED- AND THEN IT JUST A
THE LAST THING I WANT TO SHOW I
SHOULD THIS IN THE PAST. WE DID
SO. MESSED WITH OUR EIGHTY YOU
FEES I'M EARLY ON TWO YEARS AGO
TO SEE HOW THAT WHAT MIGHT
WORK. AND WE NEEDED TO EIGHTY
USE BILL IN OUR COMMUNITY TO
SEE A- IT'LL UNITS BUILT. ON
THE SIX STATE LAW WHEN EFFECT
JANUARY TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE SAW
A LITTLE BUMP THERE THAT WE
JUST READ WE- THE PARKING
REQUIREMENTS. I'M SOME OF
THOSE. WE HADN'T. BEEN MANY.
CENTERS THE SQUARE FEET SEE
WHAT WOULD HAVE. AND YOU CAN
SEE RIGHT WE HAD IT IN
IMMEDIATE JOE IN TERMS OF
NUMBER OF YOU THEY'RE COMING IN.
CITY AND THE STATE IS CAN. TO
WE START TO SEE THE DENNIS BE
BUILT. ON BOTH. WE'VE WE- AS IN
CITY. DIRECT A COULD
CORRELATION TO HOW DO LOCAL AND
WE SEE RESULT IS HOW WHICH IS
THE KEY FOR A THIS I'M SO WE'LL
BE DOING SAME THING CHIU ALL
THOSE OTHER PA DO POLICIES TO
THE ACT CITY ACTUALLY I AN
EFFECT ON THIS HOUSING AND SO
WHEN IT COMES DOWN TO IT WELL
GONNA BE LOOKING FOR HOW DO WE
HAVE SINCE FINISHED. FOR WE. DO
YOU. BUY AND I DIDN'T. GOOD
MORNING HONORABLE MEMBERS I'M
TOM PACE INTERIM DIRECTOR OF
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT FOR THE
CITY OF SACRAMENTO. I AM
PLEASED TO PROVIDE INFORMATION
TO YOU FROM THE CITY'S
PERSPECTIVE. BY WAY OF CONTEXT
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN GREEN FIELD DEVELOPMENT
AND INFILL DEVELOPMENT. AND THE
IMPLICATIONS THESE DIFFERENCES
HAVE FOR INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCE
HISTORICALLY SACRAMENTO HAD
GROWN OUTWARD BY ADDING NEW
SUBDIVISIONS ON GREENFIELD
LANDS SUCH AS FORMER FARMLAND.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND NINE THE
CITY ADOPTED A NEW GENERAL PLAN
THAT SAID A MAJOR OBJECTIVE TO
GROW INWARD RATHER THAN
OUTWARD. MAJOR NEW DEVELOPMENT
AREAS WERE NOT ADDED TO THE
PLAN. THIS MEANT THAT MOST NEW
DEVELOPMENT WOULD BE
ACCOMMODATED WITHIN THE
EXISTING CITY LIMITS AND IN
AREAS THAT HAD LONG BEEN
PLANNED FOR DEVELOPMENT. OVER
THE PAST TEN YEARS SACRAMENTO
HAS SEEN INCREASING INFILL
DEVELOPMENT HERE IN THE CENTRAL
CITY. AND IN OTHER OLDER
NEIGHBORHOODS. I MENTION THIS
BECAUSE PROVIDING NEW
INFRASTRUCTURE IN GREENFIELD
AREAS IS STRAIGHT FORWARD.
SINCE THERE IS LITTLE EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE. THE DEVELOPER
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR NEARLY ALL
IMPACTS OF DEVELOPMENT. HOWEVER
IN IN FILLED AREAS THERE IS
USUALLY A MIXTURE OF VACANT
LAND AND DEVELOP LAND WITH SOME
EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE. IN
THESE AREASTHE CITY AND
DEVELOPERS MUST ASSESS THE
ADEQUACY OF THE EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUPPORT NEW
INFILL DEVELOPMENT. IN SOME
CASES THIS THING INFRASTRUCTURE
IS ALREADY DEFICIENT AND CANNOT
SUPPORT NEW DEVELOPMENTS. IN
OTHER CASES THE EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE MAY HAVE EXCESS
CAPACITY SO THAT NEW
DEVELOPMENT CAN BE ACCOMMODATED
WITH MINIMAL COST. TO SUPPORT
OUR INFILL POLICY OBJECTIVES
AND RECOGNIZING THAT INFILL
DEVELOPMENT IS CHALLENGING
SACRAMENTO HAS BEEN CAUTIOUS
ABOUT INCREASING DEVELOPMENT
IMPACT FEES. BEFORE WE WERE
AMEND ANY NEW FEES OR INCREASES
TO EXISTING FEES WE ASSESS THE
MARKET FEASIBILITY OF DIFFERENT
DEVELOPMENT TYPES WITH AND
WITHOUT ANY PROPOSED FEE. WE
ALSO REVIEW REGIONAL
COMPARISONS WITH OTHER AGENCIES
BEFORE SETTING FEES. TO SUPPORT
OUR POLICY OBJECTIVES WE HAVE
MADE THE FOLLOWING
IMPROVEMENTS. WE EXEMPT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FROM CITY
IMPACT FEES. WE ALLOW DEFERRAL
OF PAYMENT OF IMPACT FEES
NORMALLY FEES HAVE TO BE PAID
PRIOR TO ISSUANCE OF BUILDING
PERMITS UNDER FEET OF FOR ALL
THE FEET DON'T HAVE TO BE PAID
UNTIL COMPLETION OF
CONSTRUCTION. THIS IS
PARTICULARLY HELPFUL FOR
RESIDENTIAL DEVELOPMENT BECAUSE
IT MEANS LESS UP FRONT CAPITAL
IS REQUIRED TO GET A BUILDING
PERMIT IT. WE INSTEAD OF A HIGH
DENSITY DEVELOPMENT WITH LOWER
HOUSING IMPACT FEES. WE ALSO
CHARGE LOWER FEES IN THE
CENTRAL CITY. NEAR LIGHT RAIL
STATIONS AND IN AREAS WITH
WEAKER HOUSING MARKETS. WE
EXEMPT ACCESSORY DWELLING UNITS
FROM MANY IMPACT FEES
REGARDLESS OF THEIR SIZE. WE
REDUCED PARKLAND DEDICATION
REQUIREMENTS AND THE RESULTING
IN LIEU FEES IN THE CENTRAL
CITY RECOGNIZING THAT THERE ARE
FEW OPPORTUNITIES TO BUY MORE
LAND HERE AND BUILD NEW PARKS
IN THE CENTRAL CITY. WE ALL
REDUCE OUR GRATIFICATION PRINCE
IN THE REST OF THE BY 30%
PARTICIPATE IN THE STATEWIDE
COMMUNITY INFRASTRUCTURE
PROGRAM WHICH CAN FINANCE BOTH
NEW INFRASTRUCTURE AND IMPACT
FEES. WHICH ARE PAID OFF BY
FUTURE PROPERTY OWNERS. THIS IS
AN INCREASINGLY POPULAR
ALTERNATIVE TO FORMING A MELD
USED TO. PROTECT THE FOR SINGLE
FAMILY HOME DEVELOPMENT. WE
CALCULATE MOST FEES ON A PER
SQUARE FOOT BASIS RATHER THAN A
PER UNIT BASIS WHICH REDUCES
COSTS FOR SMALLER UNITS AND
INCENTIVIZE IS MORE AFFORDABLE
MICRO UNIT HOUSING. PROVIDE
ATTACK THE ESTIMATE FOR
PROJECTS DESTINED TO ELIMINATE
SURPRISES AND ASSIST WITH DUE
DILIGENCE WE PLACE ALL OF THE
INFORMATION ON A SINGLE WEBSITE
AND ORGANIZE THE FEES BY
RESIDENTIAL AND COMMERCIAL
DEVELOPMENT TYPES. AND FINALLY
ALTHOUGH NOT A FEE WE'VE ALSO
ELIMINATED OR REDUCED PARKING
REQUIREMENTS IN TRANSIT RICH
AREAS AND INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF PROJECT TYPES THAT CAN BE
APPROVED BY STAFF WITHOUT
PUBLIC HEARINGS. WHICH ALSO
LOWERS DEVELOP BUSTS. WITH
THESE CHANGES IMPACT THE
PROGRAMS WE HAVE SEEN AN
INCREASE IN INFILL DEVELOPMENT.
HOWEVER WE CONTINUE TO SEE
CONSTRUCTION COSTS RISING WHICH
MAKES MANY KINDS OF DEVELOPMENT
IN FEASIBLE. WE ARE CHALLENGED
TO FIND WAYS TO BACK FILL OUR
GENEROUS FEE REDUCTIONS. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND THAT
THOSE FEES WERE ESTABLISHED TO
PAY FOR NECESSARY FACILITIES IN
IT STRUCTURE. SO FEE REDUCTIONS
ARE BIRDS REDUCE THE CITY'S
ABILITIES TO FIND THEM. THE
CITY DOESN'T COURAGE THE STATE
TO LOOK AT WAYS TO INCREASE
LOCAL FINANCIAL FLEXIBILITY TO
RAISE REVENUE TO PAY FOR PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE. THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
YOU'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. I THANK YOU ALL- ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS FOR THE
PANEL OR COMMENTS SOME REMEMBER.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANKS
FOR BEING HERE AND I JUST WHEN
I COMMEND YOU ON THE STRATEGY
THAT YOU'VE BEEN ABLE TO
ADOPTING THE PLAN IN YOUR
CITIES IT'S EXCITING TO HEAR
ABOUT SOLUTION AND- AN APPROACH
THAT ALIGNS INCENTIVES TO THE
OUTCOMES THAT. EVEN THOUGH THE
STATE WHEN OUR CHIEF I'M SO
I'VE GOT TWO QUESTIONS FOR YOU
AS A STATE POLICY MAKE YOURS
WHAT CAN WE DO WHEN YOU STARTED
TO GET SOME OF THAT BUT WHAT
CAN WE DO TO HELP FOR CITIES
PLEASE LAST FALL. AND SECOND
HOW CAN WE ALIGN INCENTIVES GET
MORE CITY. TO WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
I'D LIKE. SUGGEST ONE THING
THAT WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL IN
HERE IN THE CAPITAL THE STATE.
AND HERE IN THE CENTRAL CITY
SURROUNDED BY FREEWAYS WHICH
OUR STATE FACILITIES. I WOULD
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE THE STATE TO
STOP ASKING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND NEW DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS TO
MITIGATE FOR TRAFFIC IMPACT
STATE FREEWAYS WE READ. THE
LETTERS FROM CALTRANS ARE
COMPLAINING ABOUT THE IMPACT OF
NEW DEVELOPMENTS ADJACENT TO
STAY FREEWAYS AND ASKING THAT
THESE DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS PAY.
SOMETHING OR UNDER TWO STUDIES
TO IDENTIFY WHAT THE IMPACT IS
AND THEN WHICH IS COURSES. IN
SOME CASES AND THEN THAT TAKES
TIME TO FIGURE THAT OUT AND
THEN IMPOSE A FEE. CARD OR JUST
ACTION ON THE DEVELOPER. TO FIX
THE STATE'S FREEWAY SO IT'S A
STATE FACILITY NOT A LOCAL
FACILITY BE GREAT IF THE STATE
WOULD FIX THE STATE FACILITIES
AND NOT BURDEN LOCAL AREAS WITH
THAT. AND IT WHEN IT. IS
SCHOOLS AND SCHOOL FEES ARE
LARGELY CONTROLLED BY THE
STATE- THE STATE COULD
DETERMINE YOU KNOW OTHER WAYS
TO FINANCE THE GROWTH OF OUR
EDUCATIONAL FACILITIES. AND YOU
KNOW THEY'RE- VERY CLOSELY
CONTROLLED BY THE STATE. I'LL
JUST ADD THE- FUNDING I THINK
CREATING A FLEXIBLE TACTIC MY
FINANCING TOOLS AND THERE WAS
SOME WORK DONE LAST YEAR TO
MAKE THAT MORE ACHIEVABLE SO
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT IS VERY
HELPFUL. I'M WITHIN ALL LOOK AT
HOW THE FUNDING IS THERE'S A
LOT OF FUNDING PUT OUT THERE
NOW FOR CITIES TO TRY TO
DEVELOP THESE POLICIES THE
CITIES THAT HAVE PUT THESE
POLICIES FACTOR. SO SHE LEFT ON
THE SIDELINES WAITING FOR
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO TRY TO
GET PROJECTS FORWARDED WE KNOW
WE GET A COUPLE POP WHEN IT'LL
START. THE SO. RIGHT AWAY
CONSENT TO SAY IF THE IN SOME
OF THE SAME HOW CAN WE BE MORE
COMPETITIVE FOR SOME OF THE
STATE FUNDS TO TRY TO GET SOME
PRODUCT. ACTUALLY BILL. SOME
AND I SEE IF I COULD JUST AS A
QUICK FOLLOW UP FORGET SOME
REQUIRE- ARE ARE YOU CURRENTLY
RECEIVING THOSE LETTERS FROM
CALTRANS. WE HAVE RECENTLY
WITHIN THE PAST YEAR- SO I'M
GONNA MAYBE THERE'S A CHANGES
HAPPEN LAST FEW MONTHS BUT WE
ARE WE'VE BEEN TALKING WITH
THEM FOR QUITE SOME TIME. OKAY
YOU SEND ME COPIES OF ALL THOSE
LETTERS CERTAINLY- I'M ACTUALLY
HORRIFIED TO YOUR THE CALTRANS.
IS CONTINUING TO DO THAT- I
HAVE- HEARD AND ACTUALLY WAS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN. WHO
INFORMED ME THAT BACK WHEN SHE
WAS MAYOR OF GLENDALE THEY USED
TO GET ALL OF THESE LETTERS
FROM CALTRANS. OPPOSE INFILL
DEVELOPMENT. TAX BASED. WE
CHECKED ON THAT TO SEE IF IT
WAS STILL HAPPENING WE WERE
TOLD THAT IT WAS NO LONGER.
HAPPENING AND- TWO EIGHT AN
ACCURATE AND- BOBBI INTO IN
GETTING THOSE LETTERS AND I IT
IS BEYOND. PER CALTRANS TO
START PROPOSING INFILL PROJECTS
BECAUSE OF IMPACTS AND FREEWAYS
WHEN THE WHOLE POINT OF INFILL
PROJECTS. TO REDUCE TRAFFIC. IN
ADDITION CALTRANS WAS
SUCCESSFUL LAST YEAR IN KILLING
LEGISLATION THAT I AUTHORED AND
GETTING THE GOVERNOR VETO IT TO
EXPAND PEDESTRIAN BIKE AND
TRANSIT OPPORTUNITIES ON STATE
OWNED ROADS WHICH MAKES
CONGESTION WORSE- AND SO- I'M
GOING TO LOOK INTO THIS AND IF
WE NEED TO. PASS LEGISLATION TO
BAN CAL ON FROM THERE IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT I'M OPEN TO- SO
IF YOU COULD SET UP THOSE I
WOULD APPRECIATE IT THANKS. SO
REQUIRE THEN MEMBER. OF RECORD.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR
OF WILL BE VERY QUICK. FIRST
AND FOREMOST THANK YOU TO ALL
OF OUR PRISONERS- ON- THE IN
DEPTH FOCUS THAT YOU HAD. ON
THIS HOUSING CRISIS AND-
SPECIFICALLY TO CITY SANTA ROSA
PRECIADO VERY GRATEFUL FOR ALL
HANDS ON DECK EFFORT ESPECIALLY
AFTER THE FIRES. AT THE
ASSISTANCE A MAJOR REALLY IS
BEEN IN THE TRENCHES WITH THE
CITY COUNCIL ON AND GETTING THE
SMART GROWTH THAT IS JUST
PLEADED FOR THE FUTURE AND- I
JUST WANT TO. ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
HARD WORK- INYO WORK FOR FROM
OVER- WHEN IT COMES DOUBLE HIT
IN THE SET THAT ONE IN TOWN. IN
MY OWN. ASK FOR EACH OF YOU IN.
THAT DOWN ABOUT START CITIES
AND ROSA TELL US WHAT YOU'RE
SEEING NOW YOU'RE STILL EARLY-
IN ON THIS FIVE YEAR BY THE
PROJECT. IS IT WORKING- BECAUSE
I. I THINK SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES IS THAT. AGAIN JUST
BEING CANDID. THERE'S A LOT OF
OTHER FACTORS THAT ARE DRIVING
CHALLENGES WHEN IT COMES TO
PENCIL IN A PROJECT LIKE LABOR
COSTS LABOR SHORTAGES RIGHT
EXCEPT DRESS SO TELL US AT WHAT
WHAT YOU SEEN EARLY THEMES- ON
THAT IS ONE OF ONE OTHER
QUESTION AND- OBVIOUSLY AT THE
PANELISTS PLEASE. SURE AT SOME
OF A QUICK- THAT THE THIS ISSUE
I ATTENDED JOKE THAT WE WERE WE
TRIED TO CALL THE DEVELOPERS
BLUFF IS A WHAT WHAT REALLY IS
THE ISSUE AND I THINK WE TRY TO
ADDRESS EVERY ISSUE THAT WAS
BROUGHT UP- ONE WAY THE OTHER
TO THAT LIST- WE FIND THAT IT
DOES COME DOWN.DEPEND THE
BOTTOM LINE PENCILING IN THE
MARGIN OF CHICAGO AND LABOR
COST AND HOW THAT'S IT YOU KNOW
THE CASA EXTRACTIONS ARE
DISCOVERS. AND BECAUSE- BUT WE
ARE IN THE RED TO YOU JUST
DON'T DON'T MAKE SENSE- THEN
THEN IT COMES TO- DOWN TO THE
FACT THAT WE DON'T HAVE A LOT
OF HOUSING OR DOWNTOWN WE'RE
TRYING TO. CREATE THIS IS A NEW
PRODUCT THAT OUR CITY DOESN'T
HAVE WE ARE THE FIFTH LARGEST
IN THE BAY AREA WE NEED START
ACTING LIKE TO. START TO BRING
THAT TO SEE TOWARD DOWNTOWN-
IT'S- SO A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
NERVOUS TO BE THE FIRST ONE OR
TWO TO GO AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE
LOOKING FOR THAT FIRST PUSHED
ACTUALLY MAKE THAT HAPPEN. SO
NOW WE'RE- WE'RE LOOKING. MONEY
TO WE'VE- REASON EVERY NOW. ON
A PRICE DISTRICT IN. PLACE TO
TRY TO. ACT MONEY TO REGION. TO
TRY TO GET SOMETHING BILL. YOU
TO PLEASE. IF I MAY. AT TO
THAT'S FOR THE COUNTY IT'S A
LITTLE DIFFERENT- OBVIOUSLY
OUR- URBAN CENTERS AND MORE IN
THE CITIES BUT- WE ARE PLANNING
AHEAD AND WE ARE LOOKING AT
AREAS THAT WILL. ORGANIZE OVER
TIME AND RIVER SEXUALITY. AND
WHAT WE HAVE FOUND- AND I AND
I. REALLY WANT TO FOCUS ON THE
RENO TARGETS BECAUSE I THINK
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT PART OF THE
DISCUSSION FOR ALL OF YOU TO
CONSIDER. FOR RIVERSIDE COUNTY
FOR EXAMPLE WE HAVE A- TARGET
OF ABOUT FORTY THOUSAND UNITS.
I THINK WE'RE SECOND HIGHEST.
IN THIS GUIDE REGION TO THE-
LOS. ANGELES AND- I MORE. THAN
OUR OTHER COUNTY. SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. SO ACTUALLY. GONE
OUT OF HIM EMPOWER. GOALS
WE'VE- WE'VE- THE LAND.
PROVIDED THAT. HIRED THE HOUSE.
SO THE ZONING IS NOT. THE ISSUE
SO MUCH AS THE CALL. BRING TO.
AREAS OF THE- I WOULD OFFER AS
ARE WE ACTUALLY MOVED NEEDLE
SEE THE HOUSING BUILT AS HOW DO
WE HOW DO WE ALIGN ST FUNDING
PRIORITIES AND OPPORTUNITIES
WITH RENO TARGETS SO THAT THE
AGENCIES THAT ARE EXPECTED TO
HAVE A HIGHER PERCENTAGE OF THE
GROWTH HAVE THE TOOLS TO BE
ABLE TO DELIVER THAT. IN
ADDITION TO IN JUST KLAY AT
GERMANY AT THIRTY SECONDS OR
LESS BECAUSE I KNOW THAT WE
HAVE A LST PANEL. STRATEGY TO
BE AT THE BACK FILL. FACILITIES
THAT MAY HAVE TO BE DEFERRED.
BASED OFF OF EITHER DEFERRALS
OR CAP ANY FEES AT THIRTY
SECONDS OR LESS FROM EACH YEAR.
SO I MENTION ONE BE CENTRALLY
LOWERED OUR EXPECTATIONS FOR
THE KIND OF FACILITIES THAT WE
WANT TO HAVE. SO THERE ARE
CERTAIN THINGS THAT ARE
ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL FOR HEALTH
AND SAFETY WATER SEWER DRAINAGE
FLOOD CONTROL. AND THERE OTHER
THINGS THAT ARE NICE TO HAVE
AND ARGUABLY IMPORTANT FOR A
COMMUNITY BUT NOT ESSENTIAL TO
OCCUPY A DWELLING UNIT SO I
THINK. THAT'S SOMETHING TO
CONSIDER AB I MEAN IT WE COULD
SEE A DIMINUTION IN THE QUALITY
OF LIFE BUT- IT MAY BE A METHOD
IT'S RIGHT NOW WITHOUT ANY
OTHER FUNDING SOURCE I'M NOT
SURE WHETHER OF. OPTIONS WE
HAVE THANK YOU. I'D SAY- YOUR
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOOSE POINT
EARLIER IS GOOD AND ONE ON THE
TABLE ALL DEPARTMENTS AROUND
THE TABLE LOOKING AT HOW DO WE
SOLVE THIS TOGETHER- AND IT
RETHINKING WHAT PARKS ARE THINK
IT RETHINKING HOW WE- LOOK AT
OUR- WATER SEWER SERVICE- INTO
WHAT KIND OF FUNNY DO WE NEED
BECAUSE TYPICALLY. IN OUR
SITUATION WHERE WE WERE A
SUBURBAN MODEL AND SO THAT'S A
REMODEL CARRIES FORWARD AND
TRIES TO BE IMPLEMENTED IN AN
URBAN SETTING. THAT DOESN'T
QUITE MATCH UP SO READ. IS
CRITICAL- AND THEN NEXUS FEES
TEN TENNIS SO YOU ALWAYS NEED.
A LOT TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM.
HE'S ONLY BE CHARGED SO MUCH TO
MAKE PROJECT WORK IN EVERY CITY
HAS TO REDUCE THOSE FEES TO. TO
MAKE THAT WORK SO. IT'S TRYING
TO FIND OTHER SOURCES TO FILL
THIS GAP AND NOT BEING STUCK ON
THE FACT THAT WE'RE GOING TO
LIMIT THOSE SERVICES WE JUST
HAVE TO FIND ADDITIONAL- WASTE.
THEIR AND RETHINK HOW. BY THE
SERVICE. THANK YOU. SOME OF
RECORD. I'M I WANTED TO JUST
COME IN THE RIVER SAID IT WAS
INTERESTED BECAUSE OF
REGIONALIZATION- I'VE
REPRESENTATIVE TOTALLY RURAL
AREA AND I JUST SEE- A LOT OF-
CHALLENGES TO TRY TO MAKE THIS
ALL WORK WITH WITHOUT HAVING
IMPACT FEES- HOW DID YOU GO
ABOUT IT IN SOME OF THE MORE
RURAL AREAS TO- ADDRESS PUBLIC
OUTREACH TO USE THAT MAYBE SOME
OF YOUR THE CONSTITUENTS IN THE
AREA AT. LET'S GOING THE REGION
OF VIEW RATHER JUST CITY BY
CITY. MY YOU RAISE A VERY
IMPORTANT AND THAT'S REALLY
PART OF THE CONVERSATION AS AS
WE'RE OUT THERE HAVING THOSE
DIFFICULT CONVERSATIONS ON A
GROWTH IN IMPACTS AND THERE ARE
CONCERNS OBVIOUSLY FROM OUR
COMMUNITIES. GOES A LONG WAY TO
BE ABLE TO SAY. THAT THE FOLKS-
COMING IN TO OCCUPY THESE NEW
HOMES ARE ARE PAYING THEIR FAIR
SHARE AND THEY'RE PAYING A VERY
SIGNIFICANT. FEE THAT DOES GO
DIRECTLY TO FUND THEIR
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPACTS. SO IT
IT CREATES A GREATER
ACCEPTABILITY AND MY MOM AND
WITH OUR EXISTING ENTITIES AS
YOU'RE DOING THAT- WE ALSO HAVE
INTERCONNECTED OUR OUR FEES AND
SPECIAL REGIONAL PHASE WITH OUR
OUR CELL TAX PROGRAMS AND WITH
A RIBBON SPACE PROGRAMS AND-
ALSO. THE CONNECTIVITY AFTER.
THAT ALL WORK OTHER. TO PROVIDE
REVENUE GROWTH. PROVIDES FOR A
HIKE OF MOVIE. AND OUR
ENVIRONMENT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS OKAY- WANT TO THANK
ALL OF YOU THANK YOU. RIGHT
STORE NOW OFF TO THE FOURTH AND
FINAL PANEL AFTER GETTING
THROUGH AN OVERVIEW OF LOCAL
FISCAL CONSTRAINTS DISCUSSION
OF HOW IMPACT FEES ARE SPENT
AND LOOKING AT BEST PRACTICES
AND INNOVATIONS AROUND.
GOVERNMENT IMPACT FEES OUR
FINAL PANEL WILL LOOK AT- HOW
IMPACT FEES AFFECT. DEVELOPMENT
AND ARE BUILDING COMMUNITIES
AND BUILDERS FOLLOWING THE
MONEY- WANT TO INVITE UP FRONT
TO HOMES- IT CEO DAVID SAMSON
JAMBOREE- IT'S VICE PRESIDENT
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA JERRY
GLASSER AND FROM THE TURNER
CENTER FOR HOUSING INNOVATION
POLICY DIRECTOR DAVID GARCIA
THE TURNER CENTER- RECENTLY IN
AUGUST OF TWENTY FIFTEEN TO
TWENTY NINETEEN. PUT OUT-
REPORT RESIDENTIAL IMPACT FEES
IN CALIFORNIA WHICH WAS CALLED
FOR- BY MR GRAYSON'S BILL.
COUPLE YEARS AGO OF WITHOUT ONE
WE START WITH MR CHANCE. IT
SOUND HEARING THANK YOU LESS
MEMBER AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME'S SAN WITH
THE OVER HOMES I THE PROOF OF
ALL BEING CHAIRMAN FOR
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION THIS YEAR SO WE'RE
WEARING MANY HATS- OUR FIRM-
HAS BEEN INVOLVED THAT FOR MANY
YEARS MORE OR MULTI
GENERATIONAL SINGLE FAMILY BY
FAMILY DEVELOPMENT AND
CONSTRUCTION COME. THAT WE ALSO
BUILD TRANSITIONAL HOUSING AND-
NOW MOVING INTO THE FIVE OH ONE
C. THREE ASPECTS OF CULTURAL
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR THE NEXT
STEP UP FOR PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING SO. WE HAVE
THE ABILITY TO- COVER A FULL
GAMUT WE ALSO HAVE ON OUR PANEL
HERE IN MEMBERS OF OUR
ASSOCIATION AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS. AND OUR INDUSTRY
REPRESENTS ABOUT 85% OF. ALL
RESIDENTIAL CONSTRUCTION IN
CALIFORNIA TODAY SO WHETHER IT
BE AFFORDABLE HOUSING MARKET
RATE HOUSING. YOU NAME IT WE
BUILD IT SO WE'RE VERY EXCITED
TO BE HERE TODAY TO HELP-
DISCUSS SOME SOLUTIONS TO THE
ISSUE WERE WILLING TO BE AT THE
TABLE AND CONTINUE ON. WITH
THIS PROCESS FOR WHATEVER IT
TAKES- IN TRYING TO DO THIS IN
A VERY SHORT PERIOD OF TIME. I
FELT IT WOULD BE BEST IF WE
BUILD OFF OF SOME PRESENTATION
THAT WE'VE GIVEN TO OTHER
COMMITTEE- FINANCE. GROUPS AS
IT RELATES TO JUST HOUSING IN
GENERAL WHY ARE WE NOT BUILDING
ENOUGH HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA.
WHICH ADDS TO OUR HOMELESS
CRISIS ON AFFORDABILITY ISSUES
SO WERE FOUND MONEY AND HOW
DEVELOPMENT IS THE FACT. IMPACT
OUR BUILDING- IF YOU LOOK AT
THE HANDOUT THAT WE PROVIDED
NEXT TIME I WILL DEFINITELY
HAVE A POWER POINT. HOPEFULLY
ALL GOTTEN- THE HANDOUT HAT WE
JUST PUT ON THE DíAS. VIEW OF
HOW BUILDING WORKS SO THERE'S
BASICALLY CAN LINE ITEMS AT
EVERY DEVELOPER WITH YOUR
AFFORDABLE OR MARKET RATE WERE
ANYTHING ELSE THAT WE LOOK AT
ITS REVENUE AND BOTTOM LINE WE
HAVE TO HAVE A BOTTOM LINE TO
MAKE PROJECT DEVELOPED INTO
SOME OF THE PRESENTERS SAID
EARLIER TODAY THE REVENUE
REALLY IS SET BY THE MARKET
PLACE WE CAN'T JUST ADD COST TO
HOUSING AND THEN INCREASE THE
PRICE NECESSARILY OBVIOUSLY WE
HAVE TO PUSH THE LIMITS. BUT
THAT'S HOW IT WORKS SO WELL IN
THOSE FACTORS YOU KNOW THERE'S
SO MANY THINGS THAT INFLUENCE
HOUSING FEES ARE A VERY LARGE
PORTION OF THAT AS WE GET INTO
AN FORMA AND OBVIOUSLY THERE'S
VERY. THERE'S ALSO OTHER ITEMS
THAT YOU DEAL WITH IT WHETHER
IT BE PROP THIRTEEN- SEQUEL-
ALL KINDS OF INCLUSIONARY
ZONING OTHER ISSUES THAT RELATE
TO WHETHER OR NOT WE CAN BUILD.
UP A PROJECT THAT'S GOING TO BE
ABLE TO PENCIL OR NOT AS YOU'VE
HEARD. SO IN YOUR PACKET YOU'LL
FIND AN EXAMPLE OF AN INFILL
MIX DENSER ELEMENT AYE CHIPS
OUT ONE FOR THE PERFORMER
BECAUSE IT'S PROBABLY THE MOST
STRAIGHTFORWARD ONE TO TRY TO
EXPLAIN IN A SHORT ORDER TIME.
IN THE BACK YOUR PACKET THERE'S
THREE OTHER DEVELOPMENTS WE
TOOK A COASTAL PROJECT WE TOOK.
AN INFILL A GREEN FIELD AND A
HIGH DENSITY PROJECT HERE IN
SACRAMENTO AND IF YOU. VENTURE
INTO LOOKING AT THOSE NUMBERS
YOU'LL SEE. THAT THE VARIABLES
THAT ARE RELATIVELY FIXED AS
YOU'VE HEARD. ARE THINGS LIKE
CONSTRUCTION COSTS. AND ALL THE
FACTORS THAT GO INTO THE ACTUAL
BUILDING OF THE HOUSING UNIT.
THERE'S REALLY ONLY TWO
VARIABLES- THAT HAVE SOME
MOVEMENT AT ALL THAT'S WHAT THE
WHAT WE'RE HERE IS DO TODAY
WHICH IS FEET. THE OTHER ONE
PLAN. AND WE LOOK AT SOME OF
THE EXAM. THE CALL US. X. THE
RIVER NEW. THE PROJECT. AND
THERE'S NO WAY OUT. OKAY AND
MANY OF THE DEVELOPER THAT.
CURRENTLY HAVE INVENTORY AND
CAL ARE GETTING. BECAUSE THAT.
OBJECT ORDERED BUT WITH THE
EXACTION ACOSTA WITH THAT GO
INTO IT. SO YOU TURN THE PAGE
UNDER THE NUMBER FOR WHICH IS
THE IN MAKES DENSITY HOUSING.
THIS IS ACTUALLY A PROJECT THAT
WE PRESENTED TO YEARS AGO I WAS
JUST GETTING STARTED THERE'S A
PICTURE IN YOUR PACKET IT'S A
BEAUTIFUL FORTY FOUR HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE UNITS. INFILL
DEVELOPMENT- IN LIVERMORE
CALIFORNIA AND IT GIVES YOU A
GREAT EXAMPLE OF A PROJECT THAT
PENCILS AND OUR WORKED. AND
YOU'LL SEE FROM THE TOP LINE
YOUR LAND YOUR ENTITLEMENT COST
YOUR SITE IMPROVEMENTS. THOSE
THOSE ARE ALL RELATIVELY BAKED
INTO THE PROCESS THE PERMIT
FEES IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE
WERE A HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
TWO YEARS AGO AND ABOUT TWELVE
AND AFTER. OF PROJECT. AND THAT.
CONSTRUCTION BOSS HEARD IS NOT
REALLY VERY ABLE SINGS WE CAN
DO TO TWEAK AND MODEL. THINGS
BUT FOR THE MOST PART EVERY ONE
OF THESE LINE ITEMS WE ARE
ATTACKING THE AS A DEVELOPER-
WITHIN THE BUILDING COMMUNITY
TO TRY TO MAKE A PROJECT WORK
OR NOT- SELLING BECAUSE
FINANCING COSTS ALL THOSE KIND
OF THINGS. THAT HAVE TO FIT IN
SO THAT I KNOW THE DAY THERE'S-
NO. BUILDING THE CHECK TO PROD
THE PROP BIG MAY SENSE FROM A
FOR WHEEL HOW TO. THAT THEY CAN
GET ENOUGH FUNDING TO BUILD. IF
THERE IS NONE OF THAT THE
PROJECT DOESN'T GO FORWARD. SO
IF YOU TURN TO THE NEXT PAGE.
YOU'LL SEE THAT THIS IS BEEN A
PROCESS OF YEARS IN THE MAKING
WE'VE WE'VE SPENT WITH TALKED
ABOUT PROP THIRTEEN SEQUEL ALL
THOSE THINGS IN THE IN THE LATE
SEVENTIES IT CAME INTO EFFECT
WHICH WERE GREAT TO HELP
PROTECT THE PEOPLE IN THE
ENVIRONMENT ARE NOW COMING TO
ROOST FORTY YEARS LATER WE'RE
DEALING WITH A CRISIS THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO FIX ON A FAIRLY
SHORT WORK ORDER- PROBABLY
GONNA TAKE SOME PRETTY BOLD
MOVES ON YOUR PART I DON'T. I
DON'T REALLY RELISH SITTING IN
YOUR CHAIR BUT I GUESS THAT'S
WHY YOU'LL MAKE THE BIG BUCKS
TO- SET UP SAID YEAH AND THE
LEGISLATURE IN. AND TRY TO MAKE
THESE OF CRITICAL DECISIONS FOR
US ALL. IF YOU LOOK AT THE RISE
IN FEES ON THE NEXT PAGE.
YOU'LL SEE WE GAVE YOU A
SMATTERING OF ABOUT A HALF A
DOZEN PROJECTS- FROM ANY ACTOR
TRACY. AND THE FEES RANGE
AROUND 10218% ON ALL THE
PROJECTS THAT WE CURRENTLY WORK
ON. I PUT LIVER MORE IN THERE
AS WELL BECAUSE YOU'LL SEE
THESE ARE CURRENT TWENTY TWENTY
DOLLARS. FOR TWENTY TWENTY FEES
IN THE EXAMPLE THAT I GAVE YOU
ON THE PRECEDING PAGE WAS
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. THOSE FEET
HAVE GONE UP FORTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS OR 40% IN TWO YEARS IN
LIVERMORE ALONE. AND WHAT THAT
DOES. IS IT THE ROADS THE
DEVELOP ABILITY OF THAT PROJECT
BECAUSE OF THE REVENUES OF
ACTUALLY GONE DOWN AS YOU CAN
SEE THEIR AVERAGE REVENUE TODAY
IS SEVEN NINETY. IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN IT WAS EIGHT HUNDRED.
SO THE REVENUES WENT DOWN THERE
FEES WENT UP. THEIR STOCK IS AS
YOU HEARD FROM SO THE OTHER
PRESENTERS THAT DEVELOPER- THEY
HAD TO PUSH THEIR WAY THROUGH
THE PROJECT BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE A CHOICE OUR COSTS WENT UP
THEY WERE ALREADY. GOING
FORWARD WITH THE PROJECT. AND
COULD MAKE IT HAPPEN. SO I
THINK IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
REALLY NEED. TO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON TOGETHER AND ADDRESS.
AND I WILL TURN OVER THE
REMAINDER OF MY TIME. THE VOTER
WHO IS OUR CHAIR ONE FROM THE I
A- GOOD MORNING THANK YOU FOR
LETTING ME CRASH RELIGIOUS
SESSION HAVEN'T ON DO THAT BUT
DAVE ASK ME TO BE HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT ONE SLIDE TO YOU. AND
IT'S ACTUALLY THE NEXT PAGE AND
IT'S AND THE LITIGATING TO
CONTROL FEES. IN MY CAPACITY IS
THE CHAIR FOR BE A BAY AREA I
CAN GIVE YOU A LITTLE BIT OF
BACKGROUND ON THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE HAD TO FILE SUIT. IN ORDER
TO ENFORCE CURRENT CALIFORNIA
LAW ON FEES AND THAT IS AN
ADDED PROJECT COST NOT ONLY ARE
WE PAYING INCREASED USE BUT
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO GO AFTER
THAT IN A LAWSUIT. THE US MONEY
TO AND- RECENTLY WE HAD. A
HOST. I'M ACTUALLY A NINE FOR
THE FEW WHO HAVE SOME
BACKGROUND THE NINE NINE EIGHT
WAS. ASSIGNED IN ENTERED
YESTERDAY'S NO PROBLEM TELL.
THEY HAVE A HUGE CLOUDS MEANT
THE- OUR FATE. WE WILL BE ABLE
TO. TELL TO GET FEES. BUT FOR
THOSE EIGHTEEN MONTHS WE HAVE
BEEN PAYING INCREASED PERMIT%
FEES AT A RATE OF ABOUT THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS A DOOR. AT
THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS A DOOR
TIMES THE TOTAL NUMBER OF HOMES
HAVE BEEN BUILT OVER THE
EIGHTEEN MONTH PERIOD WE'RE
LOOKING AT A COUPLE OF MILLION
DOLLARS THAT HAVE BEEN
COLLECTED- AND THAT TRANSLATES
DIRECTLY TO THE COST OF
HOUSING- FOR EVERY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS OF INCREASED HOUSING
COST. WE LOSE EIGHT THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
HOUSEHOLDS WHO CAN BUY A HOME.
AND ANY H. B. PUTS OUT A STUDY
EVERY YEAR- THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF HOME BUILDERS.
AND IT TALKS ABOUT OUT PRICING
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN PEOPLE ARE
PRICED OUT OF HOMES. SO IT
HOLLISTER THIS YEAR WE ACTUALLY
HAVING TO SUIT. WELL WE WERE
SUCCESSFUL. WE ARE UNLIKELY TO
EVER RECOVER THOSE TWO MILLION
DOLLARS IN COSTS WE'RE SEEING
THIS MORE AND MORE AND WE'RE
HAVING TO USE IT AS A TOOL
LITIGATION IS NOW OUR TOOL. TO
TRY AND ENFORCE EXISTING
PROCEED OR SO I'VE GONE AHEAD
AND GIVEN YOU THE CASE
INFORMATION THERE I HAVE THE
ANY H. B. STUDIES THAT. ABOUT
PRICING THAT I'M HAPPY TO
PROVIDE AND I'M CERTAINLY HAPPY
TO PROVIDE ANY ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION THAT YOU MAY HAVE.
MAY NEED. ABOUT HOW. GEN THAT
IN ORDER TO REINFORCE EXISTING
FORMULA THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LET'S MOVE TO NEXT BAKER ARE
FROM GYMBOREE. GOOD MORNING
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SHARE MY COMMENTS TODAY MY NAME
IS JURY GLASSER HEDRICK I FROM
JAMBOREE HOUSING CORPORATION
AND THE VICE PRESIDENT OF THEIR
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA OPERATIONS.
JAMBOREE BY WAY OF BACKGROUND
AS AN AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPER THAT'S BEEN IN
BUSINESS FOR TWENTY NINE YEARS
WE OVERSEE NINETY THREE
PROJECTS THAT INCLUDE NINE
THOUSAND UNITS IN SERVICE
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED
INDIVIDUALS ARE FULLY- SPANS AS
FAR SOUTH AS SAN DIEGO COUNTY.
AND AS FAR NORTH AS SACRAMENTO
AND YOLO COUNTY- JAMBOREE AND
ITS STAFF AS WELL STEVE IT
SEASON AT GATING THE
COMPLEXITIES OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FINANCING AND ALSO WELL
VERSED ON HOW DIFFERENT COST.
ERRORS OF FACT FINANCIAL
FEASIBILITY. IT TO PROVIDE SOME
CONTEXT TODAY WITH REGARD TO
THE INTERSECTION OF IMPACT FEES
AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING FIRST
IRATE AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT WE PUT TOGETHER A
CASE STUDY WHICH IS BEFORE YOU
WHEN IS DISPLAYED ON OKAY. WHAT
WE DID. FOR AFFORDABLE. JACK
OUR EITHER COMPLETE OR IN THE
PROCESS OF RECEIVING FUNDING TO
TRY TO DEMONSTRATE THE
CONNECTION BETWEEN IMPACT FEES
AND TOTAL DEVELOPMENT COST- I
WILL NOTE THAT- THREE OF THE
PROJECTS ARE NEW CONSTRUCTION
WHICH INCLUDES THE FIRST
PROJECT WHICH TO MANCHESTER AND
IT'S LOCATED IN ANAHEIM.
GATEWAY WHICH IS IN SACRAMENTO
JUST ACROSS THE- TOWER BRIDGE
AND SUNRISE POINT WHICH IS OUT
IN CITRUS HEIGHTS WHICH IS THAT
I NORTHERN INCORPORATED IN THE
COUNT SACRAMENTO I ALSO
INCLUDED- A PROJECT CALLED THE
AKON A LARGE WHICH IS DOWN IN
ANAHEIM IT'S AN ADAPTER USE
PROJECT AND I THINK THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT IS OUT YOU KNOW
KIND INTERESTING TO TAKE. OUT
AS A FORT AND. THE FATE. THING
WE- EXPENSIVE PRICES THEY'VE
TURNED TO. UNDER UTILIZED
PIECES OF PROPERTY TO TRANSFORM
THEM INTO HOUSING AND YET THESE
DEVELOPMENTS ARE SUBJECT TO
IMPACT FEES AS WELL- AS NEW
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS ARE. AND
DEPENDING ON THE TYPE OF
DEVELOPMENT- IMPACT THE FEE
STRUCTURE BUT IT'S AN
INTERESTING STOCK TO TAKE A
LOOK AT. GIVEN THAT I AM FROM
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA I HAD SOME
PRECONCEIVED NOTIONS OF HOW WHO
WOULD HAVE HIGHER IMPACT FEES
AND I WAS SURPRISED- TO
DISCOVER THAT REALLY THE
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND THAT
PROJECT AND STRESSED HEIGHTS
HAS THE HIGHEST BE LOAD
PROXIMALLY TWENTY SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER UNIT- AND EAT WHICH
IS LESS THAN THE ORANGE COUNTY
ANAHEIM EXAMPLE I WILL NOTE
THAT THE ADAPTIVE RE USE THAN
IT HAD IT'S A PERMANENT SO
HOUSE JACK AND DIDN'T HAVE THE
SAME ACT ON RULES THAT LIKE. MY
PROJECT HOW. BUT MOST. FULL AND
HER OUT IMPACT FEES ARE PER YOU.
I WILL ALSO NOTE THAT THE TOW
PER. OF IMPACT FEES AS A
PERCENTAGE OF TOTAL DEVELOPMENT
COST RANGE FROM THREE TO FIVE
PERCENT- AND I YOU KNOW I THINK
YOU HEARD DAVE'S- COMMENTS HE
WAS TALKING MOSTLY ABOUT THE
BAY AREA OF HIGHER FEE
STRUCTURES I THINK WHAT YOU'LL
FIND- IS THAT FEE STRUCTURE.
VERY DIFFERENT AND ARE VERY
JURIST SPECIFIC YOU LEARN A LOT
ABOUT WHAT A JURISDICTION VAL
WAS AND THEY'RE INTERESTED IN
FUNDING BY THEIR FEE STRUCTURE.
AND AGAIN IT'S REALLY RENTS AND
IT'S AN IN ON WHERE YOU ARE AND
WHAT THE NEEDS ARE OF UNIT.
THESE PROJECTS ALSO ARE ALL
INFILL PROJECTS THEY ARE NOT
GREEN FIELD DEVELOPMENT SO THAT
ALSO HAS ITS IMPACT THE TOTAL
FEE STRUCTURE. ALL IMPACT IS
DON'T ACCOUNT FOR MUCH. OF THE-
TOTAL PROJECT. AS YOU'VE HEARD
FROM OTHERS- IMPACT FEES AND
LAND COSTS ARE ONE OF THE TWO
OF THE FACTORS THAT DEVELOPERS
HAVE SOME AMOUNT OF CONTROL
OVER. CONSTRUCTION COSTS- THEY
DON'T AND TO THE EXTENT THAT
YOU KNOW THE STATE THROUGH
LEGISLATION AND LOCAL JURISTS
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS THROUGH
INNOVATION. CAN FACILITATE OUR
REDUCE FATE FEES WAIVED FEES
THE FIRST FOR DEFERRED FEES IT
REALLY DOES HELP AFFORDABLE
HAPPENING AND THERE
AFFORDABILITY. I WILL ALSO NOTE
THAT FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECTS THERE IN A VERY
DIFFERENT SITUATION THAN MARKET
RATE PROJECT. BECAUSE THE RENTS
ARE. THEY REALLY CAN'T LEVERAGE
MORE DEBT BECAUSE THEY RELY ON
FEDERAL TAX CREDITS FOR THEIR
EQUITY PORTION. EIGHT ONE HOW
BILLION LEVERAGE ANY PRETTY AND
I WILL KNOW AS I'M SURE OF YOU
KNOW AFFORDABLE PROGRAMS THAT
ARE RUN BY BOTH THE TAX CREDIT
ALLOCATION COMMITTEE. AND THE
DEBT LIMIT ALLOCATION COMMITTEE
ARE OVERSUBSCRIBED SO ANYTHING
THAT WE CAN DO TO REDUCE THE
COST OF HOUSING. ONLY NOT ONLY
IMPACTS FINANCE FEASIBILITY BUT
THE POTENTIAL TO PRODUCE MORE
UNITS WHICH I KNOW IT.
GOVERNOR'S A SEVEN REALLY I.
JACK GIVE THAT THE SHORE THAT
WE- RIGHT NOW. BUT WITH ALL THE
SAYS I'M JIM READ ONLY
UNDERSTANDS THE IMPORTANCE OF
THAT IMPACT BEAT PLAY ON THE
LOCAL LEVEL. AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT LOCAL INFRASTRUCTURE
DEPENDS ON IMPACT FEES I HAVE A
COUPLE OF IDEAS- THAT I'D LIKE
TO DISCUSS WITH THE COMMITTEE
TO CONSIDER. HELP SPUR HELPING
AFFORDABLE DEVELOPMENT AND
POTENTIAL LEVY A SOME OF THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE QUINCES
OF THE EXISTING PEACE ACTORS
ONE- IS ONE THAT HAS BEEN
ARTICULATED TODAY AND IT'S THE
CONCEPT THAT LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS IN THE STATE.
REALLY NEED TO START LOOKING AT
THE STRUCTURE TO TRACK
INCENTIVIZE. DEVELOPMENT THAT
THEY WANT TO THE CENTURY STATE
IS ONE GET A LOT. OR WHAT TO
DEVELOP YOU KNOW UNDER UTILIZED
MOTELS ARE REALLY TO DEVELOP
EIGHTY YOU UNITS ARE WANT TO
DEVELOP MIXED IN DEVELOPMENTS
THERE NEED TO WRITE. BACK THE
STRUCTURE. THIS CONCEPT IT'S
MORE OF A BROAD BUT WE'VE HER A
LOT TO THAT YOU KNOW THE NEXUS
STUDIES THAT ARE DONE TO
ESTABLISH FEES ARE HAVE A LOT
OF ASSUMPTIONS THAT ARE BASED
ON YOU KNOW POTENTIALLY DATA
THAT EXISTED- YEARS AGO AND I
THINK ALL REALIZE THAT WERE IN
THE MIDST OF A HOUSING CRISIS
WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH U. S. TO
HOUSE- THE RIGHT BUTTONS THAT
YEAH THAT RESIDE IN CALIFORNIA
AND AS A RESULT AND PEOPLE ARE
SLEEPING UNDER. I'M SAYS THERE
ARE ON THE RIVER BEDS AND THE
HOMELESS CRISIS IS JUST
INCREASING GETTING WORSE AND SO
I THINK THE CONCEPT IS TO RE
THINK THE CONNECTION BETWEEN
DEVELOP STRUCTURE TO THE X.
WHAT A PORTABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS ARE TAKING. IS
TRYING TO HELP HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS. STE INFRASTRUCTURE
THIRTY. ON UNDER IT YEAH SAME
CAN THAT YOU STICK WITH NEW CAN
YOU THE SAME AS IT IS AT THE
SAME TODAY AS IT USED TO BE
SHOULD HOMELESS PROJECTS REALLY
BE GETTING A CREDIT VERSUS
BEING CHARGED FOR THE STRAIN
THAT THEY'RE PUTTING ON
INFRASTRUCTURE SUCH AS THE KIND
OF OUTER IDEA TO THINK ABOUT
THE LAST IDEA AND I THINK I
DON'T HAVE- EXPERIENCE WORKING
IN ALL JURISDICTION MY IN
JURISDICTIONS MY INCLINATION
IS. MOST RESEARCH TRYING TO DO
THEIR BEST TO BALANCE BETWEEN
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS AND TO
PRODUCE HOUSING I THINK THEY'RE
LIKELY ARE OUT LIARS THAT ARE
TRYING TO EITHER DEVELOPMENT OR
ARE TRYING TO PLAY I FEET.
DEVELOPMENT HOWEVER COSTS THAT
IN A- SO SEATED WITH THE TO.
THE AFFORD HOUSING SITES ONE
IDEA MIGHT BE- FOR THE STATE TO
LOOK AT IMPACT FEES AND TO
CREATE YOU KNOW PROBLEM EITHER
REGIONAL OR PROJECT TYPE
CEILINGS FOR IMPACT FEES AND
GIVEN THAT MOST- AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS HAVE TO MAKE
A STOP AT THE STATE TO RECEIVE
STATE RESOURCES. AT CONDITION
OF THIS SOURCES POTENTIAL IN
THESE- IMPACT FEE THE CEILINGS
THAT ARE CREATED CAN BE A
CRITERIA FOR RECEDING FEET SO
IT INCENTIVIZE IS JURISDICTIONS
OR BELOW THE CEILINGS BECAUSE
THEY HAVE ACT AS TO STATE
FUNDING PROGRAMS THAT IT
COURAGE'S STIRS AND- CAN I GET.
CENTER BILL WILL HAVE. REGISTER
IS TO BETTER OVER FRESH TO
ACTUALLY LOWER THEIR SO THAT
THE ACCESS THE RESEARCH. AM I
APPRECIATE THEM TODAY AND THE-
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE MY
THOUGHTS AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANKS
THANK YOU EN ARE SPEAKER MISTER
PERCY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
HAVING ME THIS MORNING MY NAME
IS DAVID GARCIA I AM POLICY
DIRECTOR HAD PETERSON OF
HOUSING DIVISION. AT UC
BERKELEY APPRECIATE THE- THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK ABOUT A
TOPIC THAT THE CENTER HAS BEEN
VERY ENGAGED IN OVER THE LAST
TWO YEARS AS YOU ALL KNOW WE'VE
ISSUED. A HANDFUL REPORTS ON
THIS EXACT TOPIC- THE LATEST OF
WHICH WAS IN HIS LAST SUMMER
TWENTY NINETEEN- WHICH WAS DONE
AT THE BEHEST OF THE STATE
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT SO. I'M
GONNA TALK. ARE THINGS FROM
THIS RESEARCH ARM AND ALSO SOME
OF OUR OUR RECOMMENDATIONS AND
CONCLUSIONS FROM THIS WORK AS
WELL- ONE THING TO NOTE IS THAT
WE ACTUALLY HAVE ANOTHER PIECE
SEARCH. ON HOW THE COUPLE WEEKS
THAT WILL TAKE THE RESEARCH
WE'VE DONE AT THIS POINT- EVEN
A STEP FURTHER STILL. FOR THAT.
THE BIG. THAT BEEN. I THINK A
LOT FOLKS TAKE WHEN THEY LOOK.
THAT IN SOME. NOW ALSO DUE TO
IN SOME CITY HE'S GONNA UP
BECAUSE HIGH IN FACT IN OUR
PORT WE FOUND THAT. IS SINCE IS.
ON HE PERSON. READY PROJECT
EXPERIENCES UPWARDS OF A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
YOU. SOMETIMES UNDER. DOLLARS
UNIT. WE KNOW DEVIOUS.
LITERATURE THAT. FEES OFTEN
TIME DO YOU. ARE PASSED ON TO
THE CONSUMER IN THE FORM OF
HIGHER. RENTS OR HIGHER HOME
PRICES AND I THINK THEY THEY
THERE IS A COMMON EARLIER THAT
YOU KNOW IF HE IS OR NOT. INTO
PLAYING THE TOP. AT THE
PRESERVING. I NOTE NOT. OF THE
SAME AND IF YOU'RE PUTTING IN
EIGHTY OR YOU BUILDING THIS
MIDDLE HOW THE BILL NUMBERS ARE
ACTUALLY QUITE HIGH FOR. TO
ABSORB AND IT DOES HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT AS YOU GO
FURTHER DOWN THE DEVELOPMENT
SCALE SO SMALL UNITS ISIS
THINGS LIKE THAT- ALSO JUST A
TOTAL NUMBER. HE'S A WEEK. ALSO
FOUND SIGNIFICAN ISSUES
TRANSPARENCY SO IT IS REALLY
DIFFICULT TO OBTAIN FEE
SCHEDULES IN MANY INSTANCES TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THOSE FEW
SCHEDULE SAY AND HOW THAT
RELATES. TO YOUR PROJECT AND SO
AGAIN. IS A BIGGER ISSUE FOR
SMALLER BUILDERS WHO MAY NOT
HAVE THE RESOURCES OR TIME TO
DIG THROUGH ITS CITY WEBSITE TO
FIND FEE SCHEDULE AND
UNDERSTAND HOW THAT IMPACTS THE
PROJECT THAT THEY LIKE TO. AND
ONE OF THE LAST MAJOR FIND.
THAT WE HAD WAS THAT MOST
CITIES ARE NOT CONDUCTING
REALLY ROBUST FEASIBILITY
ANALYSIS TO TRULY UNDERSTAND
WHAT THE IMPACT OF THEIR FEES
WILL BE ON. THE ABILITY OF THE
MARKET TO DELIVER HOUSING SO-
MANY CITIES ARE RELYING ON AN
INFORMAL COMMITTEES OR AN
ANALYSIS OF WHAT THEIR
NEIGHBORING COMMUNITIES ARE
CHARGING AS JUSTIFICATION FOR
SITTING THERE FEES. NEITHER OF
THESE ARE A BUS ENOUGH TO TAKE
THE PLACE OF AN ACTUAL FULL
FEASIBILITY ANALYSIS TO REALLY.
MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE GETTING
THE BEES THAT THEY NEED BUT
ALSO NOT STOPPING. AND SO.
SEVERAL RECOMMENDATIONS AND-
INS FROM RESEARCH JUDGES TO
QUICKLY SUMMARIZE THEM I THINK
IT IS IMPORTANT TO THINK ABOUT
THAT TOLL FREE NUMBER- I THINK
IT'S BEEN STATED A FEW TIMES
HERE THIS MORNING THAT. YOU
KNOW THE IT'S REALLY- OUT LIAR
THOSE HIGHER FEES- SO TO THAT
EXTENT THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
THINK ABOUT. MEASURES TO
CURTAIL SOME OF THOSE INSTANCES
WHETHER THAT'S LOOKING AT-
ACTUAL LANGUAGE IN THE
MEDICATION FEE ACT OR REQUIRING
SOME SORT OF FEASIBILITY
ANALYSIS- THATWOULD KICK IN
AFTER A PERCENTAGE OF THE FEES
ARE ARE HIGHER THAN. THAN
AVERAGE RENTER AVERAGE HOME
PRICE OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT
BUT I ALSO WANT TO STRESS THAT
SUCH TOTAL FEEL. IMPORT OTHER
LIST BEFORE FROM A HANDFUL OF
CITIES THAT HAVE DONE SOME
REALLY I THINK INNOVATIVE.
THINGS TO REFORM THE WAY THE
AMP FEES THERE IS OFTEN FEET
PEARL. CHANGE WHAT TO SAY. AS
FAR AND- SOME OF THE OTHER
PROGRAMS TO DEVELOPERS CO WITH
THAT BECAUSE REALLY SPREAD IT
OUT OVER A LONGER PERIOD OF
TIME SO ARE IDEA I THINK WE
SHOULD BE EXT AS WELL ON IN IN
THE ONE LAST A TO IT'S BEEN
MADE A FEW TO A THAT THESE
THESE ARE ARE REALLY IMPORTANT
CITIES ANY CASE RIGHT THERE
BANG FOR. THINGS THAT WE ALL IN
AND WE WILL SEE PARKS BERRIES
ARE FIRE SAFETY. THINGS OF THIS
NATURE. AND CITIES ARE REALLY
CONSTRAINED IN THE WAY THAT
THEY CAN RAISE REVENUE RIGHT
AND THAT'S BECAUSE OF. A
LARGELY BECAUSE OF OUR PROPERTY
TAX STRUCTURE AND SO AT THE
SAME TIME AS WE'RE DISCUSSING.
THE NEED TO REFORM THE WAY
CITIES. CALCULATES AND IMPOSE
FEES WE SHOULD ALSO BE
DISCUSSING WAYS IN WHICH WE
CAN- PROVIDE RESOURCES SO THAT
WE CAN CONTINUE TO. UPGRADE AND
BUILDING INFRASTRUCTURE TO KEEP
OUR COMMUNITY IS TO THE LEVELS
OF. THAT THE WE ASPIRE. TO BE
SUB. I'M GONNA STOP. AND THANK.
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
LOOK FOR TO THE CONVERSATION.
YOU OF YOUR TEST. LET ME UP.
THERE ARE LIKE SO ONE ASK WHAT.
ANYONE ANYONE IF NOT I WILL- I
WILL JUMP IN SO THERE IS SOME
SENSE WITH CITIES THAT HAVE
HIGHER FEES- THAT THESE ARE
CITIES THAT DON'T NECESSARILY
WANT TO BUILD SO THEY'RE FINE
WITH THE FEES HIRAM CURIOUS
FROM YOUR EXPERIENCES- GIVE A
SENSE WITH REGARD TO THE CITIES
THAT HAVE THE HIGHEST FEES IS
IT BECAUSE- YOU ARE HAPPY FOR
THERE NOT TO BE HOUSING OR DO
YOU THINK IT'S MORE THAT
THEY'RE JUST. TO BACK THAT THE
M. THE IN FEES. I'M IT'S HARD
TO SAY- I THINK A LOT OF TIMES
IT IT MAY BE THAT THEY DON'T
HAVE THE RIGHT INFORMATION TO
MAKE THE RIGHT DECISION ON WHAT
THE FEE SHOULD BE. RIGHT AND
THIS GOES BACK TO WHAT I
MENTIONED BEFORE THAT THERE'S
NO FEASIBILITY STAND CITIES
HAPPEN PLOY TO SET THEIR FEES
AT A LEVEL THAT THEY KNOW WILL
NOT HINDER HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
AND SO THEY MAY HEAR THAT. A
COMMUNITY NEXT DOOR HAS SYMBOL
THE HIGH FEES AND SAY WELL IF
THEY CAN HANDLE IT AND YOU KNOW
ARM CAN HANDLE TO. ANSWER THIS
IS A BET THIS IS TURNING FEE
SHOULD BE AND- I. BUT THINK THE
OUR INTENTION HOLD ON SOME OF
THE TIME BUT A IT'S REALLY HARD
FOR SEIZE MAKE THESE DECISIONS
WHEN THEY DON'T HAVE ALL THE
INFORMATION NECESSARY TO
REALLY- FIGURE OUT WHAT THE
RIGHT RATE IS RIGHT WITH THE
RIGHT TO THEIR FEES AT THAT
THERE HAS BEEN DISCUSSION YOU.
TO ABOUT THE FEASIBILITY OF THE
IMPACT OF THEIR FEES IT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT CITIES CURRENTLY
DO CURIOUS HOW YOU MIGHT WANT
TO THINK ABOUT STRUCTURING THAT
PERCEPTION OF WEST SO. IDEA
THERE WOULD BE TOOLS AVAILABLE
THE SYSTEM THE TURNER CENTER
HAS BEEN WORKING ON IT TRYING
TO DEVELOP MORE MORE BROUGH BUS
VERSION OF. YOU WOULD BE ABLE
TO SEE IN IN REAL TIME AND
TAKING INTO ACCOUNT EXISTING
WORKING CONDITIONS ANOTHER. HOW
DIFFERENT LEVELS WOULD IMPACT
FEASIBILITY DEVELOPMENT IN YOUR
COMMUNITY SO IF WE'RE ABLE TO
PROVIDE CARE TO RESOURCE TO
CITIES SO THAT THEY DON'T HAVE
TO. GET A- WHAT IS. YOU KNOW
MONTHS TO. THIS ON THAT MAY NOT
BE A TO DATE PUBLISHED I THAT
WOULD GO LONG WAYS TOWARDS
PARTICULARLY SMALLER AND MID
SIZE CITIES HAVE THIS KIND OF
INFORMATION- BUT THE FEELING
THAT THERE COULD BE SOME SORT
OF- TRIGGER IF THERE IS A THAT
THAT THE FEES EXCEED A CERTAIN
PERCENT. I'M SERVE IN A TWO.
ACOSTA THAT THEN YOU'LL TO THE
STATE WOULD HAVE TO REQUIRE A
FEASIBILITY ANALYSIS OF THIS TO
BE SIMILAR TO WHAT. SEC
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN OH FIVE
DID FOR INCLUSIONARY ZONING
POLICIES RIGHT SO IF IT GOES
ABOVE A CERTAIN PERCENTAGE. YOU
SIMPLY HAVE TO PROVE THAT
YOU'RE MARKET COULD. SUSTAIN
THAT HIGH OF A FEW THROUGH
MARKET STUDY. AND ONE FINAL
QUESTION FOR MISTER. TURNER I
KNOW YOU MENTIONED BEFORE THAT.
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS-
THAT YOU MAY OR OTHERS MAY WANT
TO BUILD- REQUIRING THE SAME
LEVEL OF IMPACT FEES FOR THEM
IS- COULD BE SELF DEFEATING
WE'RE TRYING TO ASK
COMMUNITIES. TO BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING- THESE ARE
UNITS THAT ARE NOT ACCRUING
PROFIT TO DEVELOPERS AND YET
WE'RE SETTLEMENT WITH THE EXACT
SAME FEES. CURIOUS IF WE WERE
TO REDUCE IT THESE ARE A
LIMITED IMPACT FEES FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS. HOW
WILL IT CHANGE THE CALCULUS OF
WHETHER YOU. DEVELOP MORE. FOR
WHAT. IT'S YEAH THE IT'S A
GREAT. ON A INDIVIDUAL LEVEL AT
REDUCTION OF ANY COST- RESULTS
IN NEEDING TO ASK FOR A LOT
LESS TAX CREDITS LESS BONDS
LESS LOCAL SUBSIDY SO-
ESSENTIALLY WHAT YOU WOULD BE
DOING IS SPREADING THE LIMITED
AMOUNT OF RESOURCES OVER
POTENTIALLY MORE UNITS- AND TO
THE EXTENT THAT THE DESIRE OF
THE STATE AND BUT I'M LOCAL
DURING. I JUST SAY IT WAS TEXT.
ALL THE- AND JUST THE CHANGE IN
THEIR ABOUT HOUSING AND NEEDING
TO SERVE THEIR CONSTITUENCY IN
THE HOMELESS PROBLEM HAS HAS
REALLY I THINK CHANGE THE
DYNAMICS ON BOTH IN SACRAMENTO
AND AT THE LOCAL LAW REGARDING
HOUSING AND I THINK YOU SEE A
LOT OF JURISDICTIONS WANTING TO
TRY TO MAKE THINGS WORK BUT
BEING CAUGHT UP AND- KIND OF
THEIR EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE
IN KIND OF STRUGGLING GIVEN
THE- REDEVELOPMENT. THE THING
OF ALL OF THE LOCAL WELL WITH
WITH. TO BUILD CAPACITY IN I
KIND OF GET ON THE RIGHT TRACK
BUT BUT TO THE EXTENT FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS- IMPACT FEES COULD
BE REDUCED- IT WOULD IT WOULD
RESULT IN THE DIRECT PRODUCTION
OF MORE UNITS. THANK YOU I KNOW
SKINNER HAS A QUESTION. THANK
YOU THEN APOLOGIES THAT I
MISSED SOME OF YOUR
PRESENTATIONS- BUT I WONDERED
IF ON THIS NOTE IF WE ARE
SEEING TREND OF CITIES REDUCING
THE FEES. THE I DON'T THE PRICE
PERCENT AFFORDABLE BUT ALSO
MEAN LIKE IF YEAR WE HAVE THE
BUILDING WOULD SAY SIXTY MARKET
RATE THIRTY YEAR TWENTY
AFFORDABLE ARE THEY REDUCING
THE FEES FIND IS THE TREND TO
REDUCE THE FEES ON THOSE OR IS
IT NOT AND THEN ON THE E. U.'S.
SO WE HAVE IN OUR PACKET THAT
FOR EXAMPLE THE CITY OF SANTA
ROSA ORDINANCE BASICALLY
LIMITED AMIDST ALL THE FEES ON
YOU SO THAT IT'S ONLY IF
THOUSAND DOLLAR. BUILDING I'M
THE PLEDGE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED LAST YEAR PUT SOME SOME
LIMITS ON EIGHTY FEES BUT NOT
IT'S STILL BE QUITE HIGH IN IN
A LOT OF JURISDICTIONS EVEN
THOUGH WE GET OUT A LITTLE BIT
BUT IS THERE A TREND NOW.
REDUCING THOSE FEES OR NOT. I
CAN TRY TO ADDRESS THE EIGHTY
YOU IN THE MARKET RATE UNIT
QUESTION AND THEN WE'LL BE
HAPPY TO LET YOU TURN THINGS
OVER ON THE AFFORDABLE SIDE- ON
THE- ON THE EIGHTY USE I THINK
THAT EXAMPLE WAS REALLY A
PERFECT REFERENCE TO MAYBE SHOW
EVERYBODY THE OKAY OF FEES AND
HOUSING PRODUCTION. AND I KNOW
ON THE STATE AND GLOBAL BASIS
WE HAVE A HOUSING SHORTAGE
EVERYBODY RECOGNIZES THAT'S WHY
WE'RE HERE TODAY YOU CAN SEE IF
YOU DO PRICES YOU MORE. THE WAY
WITH. THE PROBLEM IS WE STILL
NEED THOSE IN AND ALL THE JOY.
LOCALLY THAT WE BUILD AND
WHETHER IT'S PARKS ROAD SEWER
WATER ALL THOSE KIND OF THING
SO IT'S NOT THAT WERE
ADVOCATING TO JUST DO AWAY WITH
FEES WHAT WE'RE REALLY
DISCUSSING HERE IS TRYING TO
MAKE SIMPLE DECISIONS ON HOW TO
WE SHOULD THE BURDEN OF
RESPONSE THEY KEEP THE HIGH
CALL OF LIFE. PENSIONS MANY THE
JURISDICTIONS WE HAVE THE HIGH
FEES ARE ACTUALLY THE ONES THAT
ARE BUILDING THE MOST HOUSING
IN CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW SO IT'S
CONVERSE TO THE HIGHEST CITIES
PRETTY LAST HOUSING BECAUSE
THAT THAT THAT'S JUST KIND OF A
BAD ACTOR DURATION BUT NORMALLY
THE- COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
TRYING TO BUILD MORE HOUSING
HAVE HIGHER FEES. WITH IT RATE
AND THEN DOING CLUES ARE UNITS
WERE THIS THE TOP. FORTY THAT
WOULD REFER TO SAN. UP I'M NOT
FEE REDUCTIONS IF ROSESTO
GOVERNMENT SUBSIDY PROGRAM AND
THEN WE END UP BECOMING A
PREVAILING WAGE REQUIRED-
SITUATION SO GENERALLY SPEAKING
NOW ON ON THE COMBINED PROJECTS
THROUGH INCLUSIONARY ZONING WE
CANNOT TAKE ADVANTAGE OF ANY
FEE REDUCTION. AND I. YOU CAN
REST OF IT SURE. FROM MY
EXPERIENCE- MOST JURISDICTIONS
ARE STILL LIMITING THEIR FEE
WAIVERS ARE DEFERRALS WHICH IS
THE TWO CAN REMAIN PROGRAMS
THAT THAT- JURISDICTIONS ARE
USING TO REDUCE FEES- FOR
AFFORDABLE UNITS AND WHETHER OR
NOT THEY DEFINE AFFORDABLE
UNITS SAYS THE PERSON. IN AN 8%
HUNTER AND TWENTY I THINK IT
REALLY VARIES AMONG
JURISDICTION- BUT BUT I WILL
NOTE- THAT- IT IS TRUE THAT AS
YOU KNOW FEE WAIVERS I'M DUE
IN. DEVELOPMENTS IN IN A WAY
THAT THAT TRIGGERS PREVAILING
WAGE A LOT OF JURISDICTIONS
HAVE DEFERRAL PROGRAMS AT LONG
TERM REFERRAL PROGRAM SO I'M-
AND THAT'S THE WAY IT I AND
SURE THAT THE PROJECT IS ABLE.
TO MOVE OR AND THE SUBJECT
PREVAILING WAIT SO THAT WAY.
THE STRUCTURE. TO FOUND THANK
COSTS OF. IN DIFFERENT THAT ARE
MORE ADVANTAGEOUS TO FOR
HOUSING DEVELOPERS THAT. ONE
THING ALLOWED TO YEAR. SENATORS
AT- YOU KNOW WE TRY TO TRACK
EIGHTY USE PRETTY CLOSELY AND
WE HAVE SEEN MORE MORE CITIES-
START IF THEY'RE IMPACT FEES
FOR TO SPEAK TO ONE UNITS ARE
ON IT WE ARE TOO BECAUSE OF
THAT EARLIER AND IT IT ALSO.
BECAUSE PUSHING SIT. HERE THIS
DO WE WANTED TO ALLOW THE STATE
DOES GO ABOVE AND BEYOND THAT
SO THAT IS. SO WE SEE THIS AS A
POSITIVE STEP. ASKING THE
QUESTIONS CENTER ALSO FREE HI
SORRY I MISSED- SOME OF YOUR
PRESENTATION- YOU MENTION THAT-
I THINK IT WAS YOU I'M SORRY
YOUR NAME DAVE. THE YOU
MENTIONED THAT THERE ARE AREAS
WHERE HIGH FEES ARE PRODUCING
MORE HOUSING COULD YOU EXPLAIN
HEALTH IT CAN BE. THAT CAN BE
THE- RIGHT GIVE ME A COPY THING
AND THAT THANK YOU FOR THAT
THE- AS IS INDICATED THAT FROM
THE GENTLEMAN FROM RIVERSIDE
COUNTY WHERE YOU HAVE A LOT OF
THE GROWTH IN CALIFORNIA MOST
OF THE EXAMPLES IN THERE ARE IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA BECAUSE
THAT'S WHERE WE PUT ON THE MOST
OF OUR WORK AND I HAD TO QUIT
SACKS TO THE IN. FOR TODAY. ALL
THIS IS. IN THE FEES ARE REAL
HIGH THERE TO EAT PER WHICH IS
A BIG CHUNK IS YOU HEARD SOME
OF THE TESTIMONY TODAY OF WHAT
GOES INTO THE ULTIMATE-
PRODUCTION OF A HOME. VERSUS
SOME OF THE INFILL THAT YOU'LL
SEE HERE ON THE AFFORDABLE
WORDS MUCH MORE MODEST IN THE
324% RANGE WHICH WE WOULD LOVE
TO SEE THAT BE THE CASETHIS IS
ACTUALLY THE CASE THAT WE BUY
OUT OF. HOLDEN WHY STATE AND
IDAHO ARE FEES ARE USUALLY 123%
PER AVERAGE- SALES VALUE FOR
THAT PRODUCT VERSES THE 10218%
YOU SEE THERE. BUT ALL THE
COMMUNITIES WHICH- WERE
PRODUCING THE MOST AMOUNT OF
HOUSING FOR CALIFORNIA. HAS TO
BE ABLE TO BUILD THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE AND PROVIDE
THOSE COMMUNITY SERVICES IS A
GENTLEMAN FROM RIVERSIDE
INDICATED SO. IT'S A TRADE OFF
WERE WERE BUILDING HOUSES WHERE
WE CAN BUILD. AND TRY TO MAKE
IT WORK- FINANCIALLY FEASIBLE.
AND WE'RE NOT BUILDING HOUSES
WHERE THE JOBS ARE SO THEN WE
PUT THE AND WE PUT THE STRESS
ON THE INFRASTRUCTURE WE NEED
MORE MEDI XIN MORE IMPACTS.
THAT MISSIONAL STRUCTURE MEETS
THE BILL LIKE PARKS AND ROADS
AND SEWER AND WATER AND SUCH.
BUT BECAUSE THERE'S- NOBLE AND-
IN THE MARKET FOR. WE CAN MAKE
IT WORK AT A LOT OF THE EXTENT
AND BUT DO SEE HIGHER FEES AND
MOST PLACES THAT WE BUILT.
BECAUSE THAT'S A NEWER. THAT
DOESN'T HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE
CORRECT. SO I WAS GOING TO ASK
WITH SOUNDS LIKE I'M GETTING
PARTIAL ANSWER HERE IS WHAT IS.
WHAT IS THE SORT OF ACCEPTABLE
FEES AND I ASSUME THAT DEPENDS
ON WHERE YOU'RE DOING THE
BUILDING NO THE CONSTRUCTION
AND AT WHAT POINT DO THESE FEES
REALLY HELP. MORE CONSTRUCTION
MORE MORE BUILDING AND
ESPECIALLY OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. THE THOUGHTS OF IT YOU
KNOW RIGHT OTHERWISE I THINK WE
JUST SHOOTING IN THE DARK OF
LET'S REDUCE FEES BUT WE DON'T
REALLY KNOW AT WHAT POINT. IT
KICKS IN TO ACTUALLY HELP.
ABSOLUTELY AND ACTION AND
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION WITH A
VERY COMPLEX RESPONSE I THINK
YOU HAVE SOME OF THE BEST
EXPERTS- HERE BEFORE YOU THIS
MORNING AND AT THE TABLE RIGHT
NOW. RELATED TO THIS AND IT THE
PROBLEM WITH WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO IS WE CAN'T COME UP WITH
A PIECE OF LEGISLATION THAT'S
GOING TO BE A WITH A ONE ALL
FIX ALL FOR EVERYTHING. BUT
WHAT I THINK I'M HEARING TODAY
IS THAT THERE ARE SOME
SUGGESTIONS AND IT'S KIND OF
THE CARROT AND THE STICK
APPROACH MAYBE MAYBE WITH
INCREASE PRODUCTION THIS COULD
OFFSET SOME OF THE BURDEN. TO
THESE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS FIRE
AND WATER AND SEWER AND- PARKS
AND ROADS- TO INCENTIVIZE THEM
TO BRIDGE THAT GAP FOR THAT
COMMUNITY. BENEFIT OR COMMUNITY
IMPROVEMENTS OR QUALITY OF LIFE
FOR OF THE ENHANCED
CONSTRUCTION AND DEVELOP
ANOTHER PRESSURE HOUSING THAT
WE NEED I YOU CAN READ. SEE
COMPLETE. IF DID FROM. THEM HI
BUT THAT DOESN'T FIX. OUR LONG
TERM ISSUE AND IT IS DIFFERENT
EVERY YEAR YOU SEE THE ARE.
PROJECTS AND CAL. IN AND MOST
OF OUR BILL. REPRESENTED ARE
DOING AND A LOT OF THE CITY'S A
THAT I PROVIDED FOR YOU WERE
FEES ARE MUCH MUCH MORE
EXPENSIVE AND SO THERE'S JUST
NOT A GOOD FIX FOR EVERYTHING
BUT I THINK THAT THERE'S- SOME
TOOL THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
AMPLE. PLATE AVAILABLE ENSUE
MUCH MORE RESIDENTIAL
DEVELOPMENTS OF ALL TYPES
AFFORDABLE. MARKET RATE AND
EVERYTHING IN BETWEEN. AND I AM
FROM IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PERSPECTIVE- THE WAY I AM THINK
ABOUT THINGS IS EVERY DOLLAR
REDUCTION IN FEES STRUCTURE
CREATES ANOTHER DOLLAR FOR AN
ADDITIONAL HOUSING UNIT- TO PUT
IT IN CONTEXT TWO THOUSAND AND
SIXTEEN- WAS THE LAST YEAR IN
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY WHERETHE
MAJOR FUNDING PROGRAMS THE TAX
CREDIT ALLOCATION COMMITTEE AND
THE DEBT LIMIT ALLOCATION
COMMITTEE WERE. ESSENTIALLY
FULLY SUBSCRIBED AND WE
PRODUCED- TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
UNITS AND- THE FUNDING PROGRAMS
ARE ALL PREDICATED IT YOU KNOW
THERE'S A LIMITED AMOUNT OF
FUNDING SO THE TOTAL PROJECT
COST THOSE TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
YOU. USE UP ALL OF OUR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. IS WE CAN
STRETCH THOSE RESOURCES THAT
MUCH FURTHER SO- PROMOTE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PERSPECTIVE
YOU KNOW A ONE TO HER HUMAN YOU
KNOW A VERY NOMINAL DECREASE
IN- IN FEES OF ANY NATURE OR
COST OF ANY NATURE WILL
DIRECTLY- RIPPLE IN THE
PRODUCTION OF MORE AFFORDABLE
UNITS. THANK YOU I MEAN MIGHT.
OBVIOUSLY EVERYBODY'S CONCERN
IS WE WANT MORE HOUSING WE NEED
MORE HOUSING WE NEED MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND YOU KNOW
WHERE YOU KNOW AT WHAT COST ON
OTHER ON OTHER ISSUES- I KNOW
YOU MENTIONED PREVAILING WAGES-
I DO BELIEVE IN- AND REALLY WAY
JUST BECAUSE I THINK IN THE END
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE ARE. GETTING THE WAGES
THAT THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO
BUY A HOME OR TO BE ABLE TO DO
THE THINGS THAT THAT WE ALL
BELIEVE IN. AND SO. THAT'S WHY
I ASK ABOUT THE FEES BECAUSE IF
FOR. LOWERING THE FEESSO MUCH
THAT WE CAN'T DO THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THEN. WHO WHO
IT'LL SOMEBODY'S GOT TO PAY FOR
IT I GUESS THAT'S IN THE END
SOMEBODY'S GOT PAID FOR SO.
WHERE AND HOW AND WHO PAYS FOR
THIS BECAUSE IT'S NOT THE
LUXURY OF SAYING WORRY ABOUT
THE- SEWER SYSTEM DON'T WORRY
ABOUT THEM. COMING SYSTEM DON'T
WANT AT THE INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDED FOR ALL THESE. NEW OUR
HELP. IT'S SO YOU GOT TO PAY
FOR IT SO I GUESS THE QUESTION
YOU KNOW THAT'S THE QUESTION WE
ALL HAVE TO GRAPPLE WITH. IS
WHO PAYS FOR IT- BECAUSE WE
CAN'T ELIMINATE THE NEED FOR
THOSE THINGS. ONE THING I THINK
IT'S BEEN ABSENT FROM THIS
CONVERSATION IS REALLY
IMPORTANT IS THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT USED TO PLAY A BIG
ROLE BUILDING THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE A LONG TIME AGO-
AND SO TO THE EXTENT THAT WE
RECOGNIZE WE NEED TO BE
CONTINUALLY INVESTING IN.
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT HAS NOT
BEEN THE OTHER PARTY THIS
CURRENT ADMINISTRATION- THAT
BEING SAID THERE ARE MANY
PARTIES- THAT A- AND NEXT
ADMINISTRATION- MAY PRIORITIZE
AS INFRASTRUCTURE RIGHT SO.
THAT THE BEES MAY CONSIDER AS
WELL OKAY. OKAY I WILL ADD FROM
THE VA THERE'S PERSPECTIVE THE
TWO THINGS THAT ARE BUILDERS
ARE CONSTANTLY LOOKING FOR OUR
CERTAINTY REGARDING TIME. AND
CERTAINTY REGARDING COST SO
INSTEAD OF PERHAPS LOOKING AT
WHO'S GOING TO SPEND THE DOLLAR
BY REDUCING COLLECTIVELY HOW
MUCH IT'S GOING TO COST OF WE
CAN ALL BENEFIT AND THE TWO
THINGS THAT HELP US WITH THAT%
ARE CREATING CERTAINTY IN TERMS
OF THE TIMING FOR OUR PROCESS.
AND HOW MUCH WE WILL BE
SPENDING TOTAL- ON FEES SO IF
WE'RE LOOKING AT POTENTIAL
LEGISLATIVE SOLUTIONS I WOULD
SAY. THE TIME THAT IT TAKES TO
PROCESS THE PROJECT IS A HUGE
IMPACT THAT. IF CAN'T IF IT IS
ULTIMATELY REDUCED THEN ARE
CARRYING COSTS THE OTHER PIECES
OF THE PROJECT WE CAN MOVE
MONEY FROM ONE POT TO ANOTHER
TO HELP CREATE A TO PRODUCTION.
THANK YOU. SO MORE LOCK. THANK
YOU CHAIR AT DAVID. YOU'RE
STILL BUILDING HOUSES IN
CALIFORNIA. WE ARE PROUD TO SAY
THANK YOU YOU. SO I JUST WANT
TO GO OVER THE MIDDLE A BRIEF
SUMMARY AS QUICK AS I CAN A
WHAT IF YOU KNOW THE WHAT I'VE
GLEANED FROM TODAY THAT- YOU'RE
STILL BUILDING- WE HAVE CYCLES
FOR RIGHT NOW WE'RE IN A CYCLE
WHERE WE HAVE PENT UP DEMAND SO
THIS IS LIKE THE IDEAL TIME FOR
YOU BUILDINGS- IN PROVIDING A
PRODUCT- YOU HAVE YOUR COST TO
SAIL SO THANK YOU FOR GIVING US
THE SLIDE UP YOU KNOW THE
DETAILS. OF WHAT IT WHAT IT'S
ALL ABOUT- IN THE END WE KNOW
THAT YOU'VE YOU'VE COME UP WITH
THE PRICE OF THIS JUST USE THE
EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND AND
THAT'S BECAUSE THE MARKET WILL
PAVE AT- SO YOUR RISK IS IF THE
MARKET CHANGES IT COULD BE
SEVEN FIFTY IT COULD BE SIX
HUNDRED AND IT'S A GOES IT GETS
A TO DIE FOR YOU OR TO GO TO.
AND YOU REALLY GET A- YOU KNOW
NAY LOW. OF THE MARKET CAN
CHANGE ON A DIME WE SAW THAT
THIS WEEK IN THE STOCK MARKET-
SO YOU HAVE THAT RISK- AND WHAT
I'VE HEARD TODAY IS THAT IF WE
REDUCE THE FEES THEN THE LAND
PRICE GOES UP. SO YOU GET YOU
STARTED DON'T GET A NET.
BENEFIT SO AT THE END OF THE
DAY I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT WHAT WE CAN DO TO HELP YOU
AND HELP EVERYONE ELSE. SO YOU
MENTIONED SOMETHING THAT KIND
OF SPARKED MY INTEREST THAT IS
WHAT YOU'RE DOING IN OTHER
STATES SO WHAT ARE THE BEST
MANAGEMENT PRACTICES WHAT ARE
OTHER STATES DOING. THAT WE
SHOULD BE IMPLEMENTED HERE. YOU
DON'T WANT ME TO REALLY SAY THE
ANSWER PUBLICLY. YES YES I DO.
WELL I'VE I'VE AD IT IF YOU
HAVE THE GUTS YEAH I KNOW I DON.
ON I'M SORRY. I THINK YOU KNOW
SOMEONE ELSE YEAH I KNOW E
NEED SOME OTHER DEVELOPERS TO
ANSWER THAT QUESTION FOR YOU. I
THINK THE MY DEVELOPER PRINTER
BUILDING COLORADO YEAH. AND I
RECENTLY SIR BUILDING AND IN
IDAHO AND WASHING SURE STATE
BECAUSE WHAT WE LIKE MOST
PUBLIC BUILDERS HAVE TO PRAY
OUR RESPONSIBILITY OUR
LIABILITIES. AND IT'S BECOME
VERY SPECULATIVE IN VERY RISKY
IN CALIFORNIA TO. BE A PRIVATE
HOME BUILDER. I TRIED TO GET MY
SON THIRD GENERATION HOME
BUILDER TO DO ANYTHING ELSE
THAT HE WANTED BESIDES BECOMING
A HOME BUILDER BUT I COULDN'T.
HIM IS THIS IS WHAT HE REALLY
WANTS TO DO HE KNOWS THAT HIS
FATHER'S PASSIONATE ABOUT IT. I
THE THERE IS NOT A ONE SIZE
FITS ALL BUT YOU'VE SEEN
THROUGH A LOT. INFORMATION
TODAY IF YOU CAN REDUCE COST
YOU CAN. MORE AND CALIFORNIA
HOME BILL. ARE TRYING TO USE A
HUNDRED THOUSAND HOMES ARE
TRYING TO PRODUCES MANY HOMES
AS WE POSSIBLY CAN BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE HERE FOR
WE'RE HERE TO BUILT AND IF WE
CAN BUILD MORE WE WILL. THEN
THE DILEMMA IS WE CAN'T GET THE
REVENUES TO MEET THE EXPENSE SO
IF WE CAN REDUCE. THE EXPENSES
AND ALSO SLIGHTLY REDUCE OUR
REVENUE SO WE CAN MEET MORE OF
THE CONSUMER PROFILE THE NEED
FOR THE WORK FORCE HOUSING FOR
THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING. FOR THE
HOUSING STOCK THAT'S REALLY
GOING TO PUT PEOPLE BACK IN.
THE SHELTER INSTEAD OF BEING ON
SHELTERED. THAT'S OUR GOAL AND
SO IF WE CAN REDUCE. ANY PART
OF THE COST EQUATION I GIVE YOU
THE TEN LINE ITEM THERE'S EIGHT
OF THEM THAT WE CAN WORK ON. I
WOULDN'T NECESSARILY SAY THAT
THE MONEY WOULD GO BACK TO THE
LANDOWNERS RIGHT NOW WE'RE NOT
BUILDING HOMES BECAUSE THERE'S%
NO RESIDUAL LAND TO A LOT OF.
LAND THAT IS BUILDABLE FOR
HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA- THERE
MAY BE SOME INSTANCES WHERE THE
VALUES DO DO GO UP. SLIGHTLY
BUT WHAT BUT LEAVING THE
REVENUE WHERE IT IS RIGHT NOW
ISN'T THE ANSWER WE NEED TO
BRING THE COST OF ALL HOUSING
DOWN OF THE REASON WHY THE COST
KEEPS GOING UP IS. YOU CAN
EASILY SEE FOR MY INFORMATION
IN THE PERFECT. IF THE FEES FOR
A FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR
HOUSE. REPRESENT 10% OF THAT
COST I IN THE FEES ARE PER UNIT
AS WE DISCUSSED EARLIER. I
COULD REDUCE THAT LINE ITEM THE
5% IF I BUILD A MILLION DOLLAR
HOUSE. AND THAT'S WHY SO MANY
HOMES BEING BUILT IN CALIFORNIA
TODAY ARE FOR THE HAVES OR THE
HAVE NOTS WE'RE MISSING THE
MIDDLE WHICH IS THE WORK FORCE
HOUSING. AND ONE OF THE
IMPLEMENTS IS FEES IT'S AN
ISSUE. THAT HAS GROWN OVER THE
LAST FORTY SOME YEARS TO. THE
VERY DISPARAGING SITUATION AND
I THINK THAT WE DO NEED TO
ADDRESS IT IT'S JUST IT NEEDS
TO BE ADDRESSED ADEQUATELY AND
FAIRLY. SO THAT WE DON'T IMPACT
ALL THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS.
AND AS- THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN SAID
WE IT'S YOU GOT A TRADE THE
MONEY FROM ONE POCKET TO
ANOTHER YOU CAN'T. YOU CAN'T
JUST AS A SURLY TAKE ABOUT A
ONE LINE ITEM AND PUT IT INTO.
ANOTHER ONE SO WE TAKE IT AWAY
FROM THE CITIES AND LOCAL
RESTRICTIONS I GUESS THIS. FOR
AFTER. PICK UP THE BALLOT. SO
HEAD. MORE HERE I'M ASSUME
MAYBE YOU BUILD MAREADY OR BOY
IDAHO CORRECT WHAT WOULD IT
LOOK LIKE SIDE SIDE IN IN
MERIDIAN RIGHT NOW HAVE COUPLE
DEVELOP THAT WE'RE CURRENTLY
WORKING ON HER FEES FOR A FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND. DOLLAR HOUSE
THAT WOULD PROBABLY BE CLOSE TO
A MILLION DOLLARS IN LIVERMORE
ARE SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
ABOUT ONE AND A HALF PERCENT OF
THE TOTAL VALUE OF THE- IN THE-
END THEY HAVE GREAT PARKS GREAT
SCHOOLS GREAT INFRASTRUCTURE WE
HAVE ALL THE WATER AND SEWER
AND EVERYTHING ELSE THAT WE
NEED SO. WHERE WHERE THE
BREAKDOWN BETWEEN THERE AND
HERE BECAME I THINK IT'S A
FORTY YEAR PROCESS THAT WE'VE-
EVOLVED THROUGH. PROP THIRTEEN
AND SEE CA AND OTHER THINGS
THAT HAVE EVOLVED THE WAY I WE
DEVELOP. IN THE REGULATIONS
THAT WE'VE IMPOSING CALIFORNIA
MAKE HOUSING SO EXPECT. BECAUSE
I CAN GO THROUGH EVERY ONE OF
THOSE EIGHT LINE ITEMS WITH YOU
AND SHOW YOU WHERE REGULATION.
HAS INCREASE OUR COSTS OF
FINANCE INCREASE R. COSTA SALES
INCREASE OUR COSTS AND
INSURANCE. HOUSING PRODUCTION
WHETHER IT'S MATERIALS OR FOR
LAND USE WE CAN GO THROUGH
EVERY ONE OF THOSE AND
REGULATION IS INCREASE THE COST
WE KEEP REGULATING TO TRY TO
BUILD MORE HOUSING. BUT WE MAKE
IT MORE EXPENSIVE. AND THAT
ISN'T THAT THAT'S WHY YOU BILL
TO GIVE ME. THERE YOU GO I WISH
I WAS HERE FOR FIVE MINUTES
WITH JUST FEES BUT I'D BE HAPPY
TO. AFTER WE GOT IT WE GOT IT
TO GET THE HATE OUT OFF THE
LINE OFTEN ON THE FLOOR AND WAY
THERE. THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE.
TODAY IS HERE TO BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION. YOU KNOW I'M WITH THE
GOVERNMENT AND I'M HERE TO HELP.
EARLY ADOPTER THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE TO HELP. THEY MAY
ASK ARE THERE ANY OTHER MEMBERS
THAT WISH TO ASK ANY QUESTIONS.
IF NOT I WANT TO THANK THIS
PANEL IN ALL OF THE PANELISTS
FOR YOUR EXCELLENT
PRESENTATIONS AND DISCUSSIONS-
THERE ARE OBVIOUS IS A LOT FOR
US TO DIGEST AND I'M SURE IT
WILL BE TAKING THESE LEARNINGS
AND TWO. MORE POLICY
DISCUSSIONS THIS YEAR. SO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU- WITHOUT THIS IS
NOW TIME FOR PUBLIC COMMENT IF
THEY'RE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT TO WISH TO SAY A FEW
WORDS- PLEASE LINE UP. AND WE
WILL HEAR FROM THE FOR SPEAKER.
OKAY. GOOD AFTERNOON WE CAN
HEAR CHAIRS MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE KIANA VALENTINE ON
BEHALF OF THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA THIS AFTERNOON- WANT
TO COMMEND ALL OF THE
COMMITTEES AND THE STAFF THAT
PUT TOGETHER AN ABSOLUTELY
FANTASTIC HEARING THIS MORNING
I AGREE A LOT TO DIGEST AND
WORK ON AT RATHER THAN COMMENT
ON ANY OF THE SPECIFIC POLICIES
AND ISSUES THAT YOU
CONTEMPLATED TODAY I WOULD LIKE
TO USE MY TIME TO- OFFER THE
URBAN COUNTIES OFFER AT THE
ASSOCIATION AND OUR STAFF TIME
AND RESOURCES TO ASSIST ALL OF
YOU INTO A SINCE THE
LEGISLATURE IN COMING UP WITH
WORKABLE SOLUTIONS. AT THAT GET
THE COST OF HOUSING- THE
AFFORDABILITY OF HOUSING SO-
SOLVING THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CRISIS AND HOMELESSNESS CRISIS
AT AS A I OF US WHO REALLY IS
JUST AN ALL OF SOME AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT EXPERTISE AT HELP
YOU DEVELOP THE LIST THANK YOU
THANK. GOOD APP SO THE BAND
THAT WHAT HAS PUBLIC AFFAIRS
HERE ON BEHALF OF HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY. I JUST WANTED TO
BRIEFLY TOUCH UPON SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT WE'VE HEARD FROM.
OUR FORTY ONE AFFILIATES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE- HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY- SERVES IN
PARTNERS WITH LOW IN VERY LOW
INCOME WORKING FAMILIES THERE'S
AND VETERANS. THE HABITAT
FAMILIES THAT WE ARE WORKING
WITH THEIR OFTEN WORKING TWO TO
THREE MINIMUM. WAGE JOBS JUST
TO GET BY AND ARE OFTEN PAYING
FIFTY PERCENT. OF THEIR GROSS
MONTHLY INCOME ON RENT ALONE-
THROUGH HABITAT THESE FAMILIES
HELP BUILDING PURCHASE THEIR
RESALE INDEED RESTRICTED HOMES
BY PUTTING IN FIVE HUNDRED
HOURS OF SWEAT EQUITY-
ALONGSIDE VOLUNTEERS AND THEY
PURCHASED IT FOR A 0% THIRTY
YEAR- MORTGAGE. IT'S IMPORTANT
TO KNOW THAT THEIR RESALE ON
THE DEED RESTRICTIONS TYPICALLY
SURPASSED THE LENGTH OF THE
LOAN. AND IN MANY CASES THESE
REMAIN AFFORDABLE IN PERPETUITY
KEEPING IN AFFORDABLE HOME IN
THE COMMUNITY FOR FUTURE LOW
INCOME FAMILIES. SO AS WE KNOW
THE HOMEOWNERSHIP- AND HOUSING
PRODUCTION RATES ACROSS THE
STATE- IT STARTLING LOWS AND
ONE REASON IS IMPACT FEES WHICH
WE ARE ALL HERE TO DISCUSS
ACROSS THE STATE THESE COST
HABITAT. AMENITY AFFILIATES IN
CALIFORNIA 25233% OF THE TOTAL
PROJECT COST PER UNIT- THESE
CAN RANGE FROM TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
THOUSAND DEPENDING ON WHERE.
THE HOME IS BEING BUILT- AND
MANY OF THESE HOMES ACTUALLY
ALL THESE ONES ARE NOT ELIGIBLE
FOR THE STATE INCOME TAX CREDIT
PROGRAM I TACK. AS THESE ARE
BUILT FOR HOMEOWNERSHIP AND SO
WE- WE- SAY THAT THE HIGH
IMPACT THESE CAN NOT ONLY BE
CRIPPLING BUT CAN BE THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN ONE TWENTY-
OR EVEN THOUSANDS MORE
INDIVIDUALS HAVING THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR A STATE FOR
STABLE HOUSING- AND A HAND UP
OUT OF POVERTY. SO WE NEED TO
BUILD MORE AFFORDABLE HOMES IN
MITIGATING AND LOWER LOWERING
THESE FEES FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS LIKE HABITAT
IS ONE STEP IN THAT AND WE
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
TODAY ON FOCUSING ON THIS
ISSUE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THE MIXTURES MEMBERS CHASE
RILEY CALIFORNIA CITIES. I
THINK I THINK IS VERY MUCH FOR
HAVING THIS YEAR AND I THOUGHT
WAS WELL DONE. STAFF WAS
EXCELLENT THE PRESENTATIONS
WERE WERE FANTASTIC AND I GOT I
LEARNED A LOT. I'M TODAY SOBRE
BILLS DID AS WELL- YOU KNOW IN
THIS DISCUSSION I MEAN I THINK
YOU WE CAN ALL AGREE. ON THAT
AND THAT THESE SERVICES ARE
IMPORTANT THE FACILITIES AND
THE INFRASTRUCTURE ARE
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT. I MEAN WE
NEED A BETTER JOB TRYING TO
FIND WAYS TO FUND THIS- IN THAT
WE CAN'T TRACK ONE. WITH ALL OF
THOSE COSTS AND I. HAVE IN IDEA
HERE TODAY I THINK A CENTER
RAZA HIT ON THE HEAD AND THIS
IS REALLY ABOUT WHO'S GOING TO
PAY. FOR THIS INFRASTRUCTURE IS
IT IS CRITICAL WE ALL WANT
VIBRANT COMMUNITIES TO LIVE IN
WITH ALL ONE GOOD
INFRASTRUCTURE PARKS. I DON'T
IT. I KNOW IMAGE THAT TODAY BUT
THERE'S THIS REAL BATTLE. WE DO
TO IMPROVE THAT. TODAY YOU KNOW.
TO STUDIES KNOW HAPPEN FEES IT.
SAID HE'S- TAKING ALL AT THE
MITIGATION FEE. I MEAN. I
DON'T. THINGS WITH. IT FOR A
COUPLE DECADES SO. YOU KNOW IS
A TIME TO TAKE FRESH LOOK. IT
DOING. TO REQUIRE. OUR CITIES
TAKE A LITTLE BIT CLOSER LOOK
AT. HOW THEY GO ABOUT IMPOSING
THESE FEES I MEAN. AT THE
LEAGUE GETTING WE'RE CERTAINLY
OPEN TO ALL OF THOSE THINGS.
I'M ONE IMPORTANT THING THAT'S
MISSING TWO IS REALLY. WHAT IS
THAT ALTERNATIVE FIND STRANGE
IF WE ARE GOING TO. REDUCE
FEES. IS IT A CA ONE I MEAN I
THINK IT'S AN AMAZING BILL
THAT'S IT NOW THERE. THAT'LL
HELP OUR CITIES BEING CONTROL
OWN DESTINY. IF WE CAN'T GET
MONEY FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. IF WE GET
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES FROM THE-
FIRST. OR STATE TO FIND THE
SUPPORT INFRASTRUCTURE. BUS
MAKE IT EASIER FOR US TO ASK
OUR COMMUNITY. FOR THAT MONEY
BECAUSE THEY WANTED. ONE OF THE
FIRST. THE WANT HAVE BEEN AND
WE CAN JUST. HOLD NINETY WITH
THAT COST. WITH THAT LOOK FOR
THE YEAR'S TO. HOW WE'RE GONNA
HAVE A LOT OF. THANK YOU. MUCH
NEXT BIGGER. AFTER OFTEN IT
DOES CAN ONLY ONE ALIGN MYSELF
WITH THE CALM FROM THE COUNTIES
CAL AND LEAGUE OF CITIES THANK
YOU FOR A GREAT ARE OF
DIRECTORS PUT TOGETHER SOME
POLICY PLANKS AND WE'RE WE'RE
REALLY INTERESTED IN LOOKING
ABOUT HOW WE CAN BETTER
ADMINISTER THESE PROGRAMS MORE
ACCOUNTABILITY TRANSPARENCY
CERTAINTY FOR DEVELOPERS I
THINK WE ALL RECOGNIZE IS
IMPORTANT- I'M LIKE THE LEAGUE
WE ARE WORRIED ABOUT CAPS OR
REDUCTIONS IN AND REALLY HERE
THE MONEY COMES FROM TO
PROVIDE. THAT THIS IS AN AND
CHECK THAT OPERATE NEED BACKED
BUT WE DO THINK THERE'S ROOM
HERE TO HAVE A GOOD DISCUSSION
ABOUT THINGS LIKE PROMOTING
AFFORDABILITY BY LINE UP THE
OPTIONS FOR DEFERRAL AND JUST
GENERAL- BETTER ADMINISTRATION
OF. THAT WE ALL LIVE SO THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MARKETS ARE
LEADING A R. LEADING A DRAW.
NONPROFIT PROVIDERS OF SENIOR
CARE AND SERVICES INCLUDING
AFFORDABLE SENIOR HOUSING
DEVELOPERS COLLECTIVELY OUR
MEMBERS SERVE OVER A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND OLDER ADULTS
ACROSS THE STATE. THE AVERAGE
HOUSEHOLD INCOME RESIDENTS
LIVING IN OUR AFFORDABLE SENIOR
HOUSING COMMUNITY STATEWIDE IS
UNDER FIFTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS A
MONTH MOST OF OUR BUILDINGS
THAT SERVE EXTREMELY LOW AND
VERY LOW INCOME OLDER ADULTS
WERE. USING REDEVELOPMENT FUND.
WE ALSO READ IT MEANT WE'VE
SEEN SEVERAL THINGS HAPPENED
OUR MEMBERS HAVE EITHER STOP
BUILDING NEW COMMUNITIES ALL
TOGETHER OR SPEND A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF TIME AND ENERGY
PERSON TOGETHER DIFFERENT
FUNDING SOURCES. THIS NUMBER OF
PROFIT ABOUT SEVEN ABLE TO FIND
FUNDING HAVE SEEN IMPACT HE'S
CALL- I DON'T. ONE OF OUR
MEMBER SUPPORT IT FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN FORTY TWO YEARS SHE'S
BEEN CHARGED COOL IMPACT FEE TO
BUILD HOUSING RESTRICTED TO
SENIORS. COUNTIES ARE CHARGING
IMPACT FEES FOR THE FIRST TIME
WHEN THE DEVELOPMENT IS WITHIN
CITY JURISDICTIONS WITH NO
COUNTY SERVICES PROVIDED. AND
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ARE CHARGING
IMPACT FEES THAT ARE
DUPLICATIVE OF ONE'S OTHERS ARE
CHARGING. UNLIKE MARKET RATE
DEVELOPED- DEVELOPERS WE CAN'T
PASS THESE NEW FEES ONTO OUR
RESIDENTS INSTEAD WE MUST
ADJUSTER PROJECTS AND SERVICES
THAT WE PLAN ON PROVIDING.
THERE'S A HUGE DEMAND FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES AND LOS ANGELES ONE
OF OUR MEMBERS RECENTLY OPENED
UP THE WAITING LIST. AND
RECEIVE SIX THOUSAND APPLICANTS
WE WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE TO
BUILD A WIDE HELPS FOR STATES
POOR SENIORS BUT WITH A
SPECIFIC FIND IT SORT FOR
SUPPORT OF A HOUSING PROJECT.
MORE ON IMPORTANT ISSUE AND
LOOK FORWARD TO POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT COME OUT
OF THIS PROCESS SPECIFICALLY WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE POLICIES THAT
ONLY ALLOW JURISDICTIONS THAT
ARE PROVIDING SERVICES TO THE
PROPERTY THE ABILITY TO CHARGE
FEES THE ELIMINATION OF SCHOOL
IMPACT FEES FOR SENIOR
RESTRICTED PROJECTS AND REDUCED
FEES FOR FOUR HOUSING PROJECTS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND OUR
FINAL SPEAKER. CORRECT AND
THOMAS CAL SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION ONE ON ONE MY
COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF OUR-
BROTHERS AND SISTERS OF THE
LEAD AGENCY SACK IN IRVINE
COUNTIES IT'S A TEAM SPORT AND
WE'RE HAPPY TO BE A GAME AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK
THAT YOU GUYS HAVE DONE SETTING
THIS UP I ALSO HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE OF. ON THE MORE- WITH
THIS PLAN GRAYSON. I PER THAT
WERE BEING THOUGHT. AND
DELIBERATE. WE DON'T WANT TO
END UP. AT THE OTHER SIDE OF
THIS BACK HERE. WITH A-
DIFFERENT CRISIS OF OPPORTUNITY
IN QUALITY OF LIFE AND
INFRASTRUCTURE SO LET'S KEEP
TALKING I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
ROBUST DISCUSSION. PLEASE
CONSIDER AS PART OF YOUR
RESOURCE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THAT CONCLUDES PUBLIC COMMENT-
LET ME JUST AGAIN THANK
EVERYONE FOR YOUR ENGAGEMENT-
CERTAINLY OUR EXPERTS FOR A
GREAT DISCUSSION I WANT TO
THANK THE FOR COMMITTEES AND
POLITICALLY OUR STAFF OR-
PUTTING TOGETHER- A GOOD
AGENDA. WE OBVIOUSLY HAVE A LOT
TO WORK ON I THINK EVERY
LEGISLATOR AGREES WE HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO FUND
INFRASTRUCTURE- BUT I THINK
ALSO IN THE WAKE OF PROP
THIRTEEN. REDEVELOPMENT DEMISE
A FUNDING CUTS- WE ALSO KNOW.
THAT SETTLING THE FOLKS THAT
HAVE TO SOLVE OUR HOUSING
HOMELESSNESS. WITH THE FULL
BRUNT OF THOSE COSTS IS
SOMETHING THAT'S VERY
CHALLENGING AND- I KNOW WE'RE
GONNA HAVE A ROBUST DISCUSSION
THIS YEAR I FOR ONE. OR TWO
SPEAKING WITH STAKEHOLDERS IN
WEEKS. THIS AT THE- BACK TO
MARCH. WHO COULD ALL OFF TO SEE
IF EVEN IF I COMMENTS. THANK
YOU MUCH FOR THE CHAIR AG ONE
ECHO THIS AT BIG. THE STAFF IS
WELL AS OFFER. A WE ARE A YOUR.